at the End of
[Music]
Time 13
O hey you guys what's going on it's
Wednesday night yeah and here we are for
the main show main show main show we're
already drinking we're finally talking
about this
[__] been wanting to do this show for
a long time I figured you had yeah yeah
I just I kind of forgot about it I meant
to like add it to the list a long time
ago and then like people kept suggesting
stuff and then right a couple weeks ago
I was like oh yeah we never did do a
show about that [__] did we well kind
of became safer to talk about it on
YouTube after Netflix put out that [__]
that program about it yeah yeah and that
was a few years ago now yeah that was um
called Filthy Rich that came out in 2020
I think or late 2020 there was a time
where if you talked about this you could
probably just get banned they didn't
want anybody talking about it you know
how they are well I mean for sure for
sure it's going to be demonetized yeah
they'll probably demonetize it I'm sure
sure so we have to depend on on
on passing the collection plate around
this we're not going to make any money
on this one we're absolutely they don't
want they don't want us talk they don't
want us talking about their friends
well like I said anytime usually if the
show is like about a serial killer or
something like that it just immediately
gets demonetized yeah or limited
monetization sometimes it still runs ads
but most companies don't want to uh put
stuff on there but yeah people are still
coming in yeah yeah yeah okay we'll wait
till everybody's in we'll start getting
into the meat of it in the
meantime
um this
was this is a trip case all right and uh
over the years I've picked up a lot of
details I was able to hear interviews of
some of of one of the
girls and a lot of that interview some
of the things that she said in that
interview weren't in this version that's
on Netflix if you haven't seen the
Netflix series about it see it and they
that one came out in 2020 and then they
just put one up about gilain Maxwell
which is only one episode because I
guess they didn't want to repeat stuff
but it's mainly like focuses on her and
her court case right and that just came
out like recently they had to be careful
you know what they were talking about
because they didn't want to get sued but
everything that's discussed in that or
in in that entire series was all things
that I had heard from other sources you
know what I mean that uh uh that were
kind of like on on other platforms that
don't demonetize you you know people
that were there people that heard about
it so it's a good version of the story
it's not 100% complete it doesn't have
all the little [__] dirty
details or suspected dirty details
because sometimes they were dropping
names and you can't so and they don't
you can't really prove that that person
was there that kind of stuff you know
what I mean yeah I mean as far as it
goes it's just kind of like and I'm
going to say the same thing about this
it's like because I'm just going by what
people said like what they reported I
wasn't there so I don't know what the
[__] happened I don't really have any
dog in that fight well they have logs
and stuff and the witnesses you know
right and it does the the ones that do
check out that they can prove that
they're there at least at the time of
the making they do talk about them yeah
prince Andrew Bill
Clinton now it's funny how you throw
Bill Clinton's name in the
mix one of the main Witnesses named
Virginia what's name Virginia what
Virginia uh uh Jeffrey her name is now
but it was Roberts at the time she's
married oh okay okay her name her name
was what was her original name Roberts
okay Virginia Rob Roberts yeah that was
but she got married later so her last
name changed she saw Bill Clinton there
and but she said she didn't see him
doing anything on towards yeah she said
they were just like hanging out on the
porch him him and FC yeah and another
guy who worked on that island doing all
the Telecommunications he saw stuff yeah
he saw Clinton there but he didn't see
Clinton doing anything he did see Prince
Andrew doing something yeah taking out
with Virginia yeah who at the time was
underage probably like 15 yeah 15 16 17
I can't remember how old she was she was
under age to be honest you see the
pictures of her at that age that they
show of her you know like with her and
prince Andrew and [__] hanging out or
whatever she doesn't look that young she
if you said she's 18 or 19 I would have
believed it um she's tall and real
good-looking at that
time so but evidently in person when you
saw at least they said she looked lot
younger it's hard sometimes it's hard to
tell how old somebody is I can see a 20
I can I've run into 20 year olds that
looked underage so you in person you
know but uh yeah it's really hard to
tell just by looking at somebody to be
honest with you yeah so uh
anyway uh it's a good version that's up
there there's more to it than that but
and they don't get into certain aspects
of it um
like the moneymaking and blackmail
angles they don't get into that they did
bring it up some they brought it up and
to be honest like um a lot of the stuff
that you said and about the the
intelligence angle and stuff like that
all that's on the Wikipedia page okay
yeah um so because I mean basically they
can say that on Wikipedia because
they're like hey these journalists like
wrote this book um you know that said
that he was involved in intelligence and
blah blah but you know we'll get into
that during most of that their version
on on Netflix they kind of make it look
like it's just Jeffrey and gilain doing
this and then their friends sometimes
are there it was a lot bigger operation
than that well like I said one of the
and then later on though like near the
end they did have one of the victims
yeah um Sarah Ransom I think it was um
and she said you know this is much
bigger this is like an international sex
trafficking ring pretty much so they did
kind of get into that but they didn't
like I said it's four episodes it's
really good there's a lot of [__] to
cover yeah cuz I was kind of worried
about it I you know I watch all these
documentaries about it and then I was
trying to like put together all these
notes and I'm like holy [__] this is
going to like take forever to cover I
had to take a bunch of [__] out um you
know what I mean I wanted to keep most
of the I I kind of most of the stuff I
took out was just like the financial
[__] yeah um because I mean that that's
interesting too but I think a lot of
people are less interested in that than
they are in like the sex trafficking
yeah another angle that they do talk
about that I hadn't really thought of is
that there was an element of pyramid
scheme into this yeah where some of the
girls didn't like doing the massage
thing but they would turned around and
be basically became talent scouts for
for $200
ahead like a bounty yeah turning their
little high school friends out yeah all
right and the thing that was amazed
amazed me although I believed it this
this is very they were getting them from
workingclass trailer parks in South
Florida they got some cute girls in
there that's where they were getting
them all right
um she was telling them UPF front what
it was and they were doing it okay you
know they're like in high school I'll do
that yeah he's Rich he's you he's a
billionaire shirt 200 was it clear like
I feel like some of the people that were
on there that had recruited other people
yeah said that they told the girls what
it entailed but I don't know if that was
the case with everybody because like I
said some of these girls were young I
mean some of them are like 13 14 years
old they're like children and some of
them are girls that are
1920 where some hot chick met him in a
club a nightclub in New York saying hey
we're going to go out to this [__]
Island you know uh guy named Jeffrey
he'd love you to meet you you know and
she's got no money and so she goes to
this exotic island and the next thing
you know she's got to put out [__]
three times a day and she's that one was
she had no idea let me tell youall
something if you're listening to this
program and you have
daughters and a certain stent if you
have boys too you got to tell them
nothing's for free if some saudy oil
prince or some rich person says hey come
to my island or let's go travel around
the world you're going to have to give
up some ass that's why they're asking
you to go there's a whole culture of
that those Instagram girls do that they
go go to Dubai they they're going to
give up ass or sell it
well some in those days this is pre-
internet or early
internet that 20s something year old
girl went on that trip thinking well
they look nice they're rich they're just
asking me to go to the damn island with
them yeah it's supposed to be like a
party or like a party yeah and you're
you're the main party popper you know or
one of them you know that's why they
take you you know they're not going to
take some girl who to this island is not
going to put out
and Jeffrey would just take it he
wouldn't ask he'd just take it yeah he's
the rapist yeah he'd rape you yep and
what are you going to do you can't mount
a legal assault against him he's [__]
got billions of dollars he [__] knew
that too and yeah he knew it knew all
his buddies were in the [__] justice
department had armies of private
investigators that could Hound you and
your family into Oblivion if you fell
into this dude's clutches and he wanted
you you were going to
[__] one way out of it these girls I
feel sorry for these girls cuz they were
just way over their head all right like
a deer to headlights they just regular
like high school girls they just lived
in some like workingclass neighborhood
and suddenly it's like somebody's like
hey we'll give you $200 to massage this
old guy yeah and she gets there and it's
a [__] Palace and then um it goes
further than that and then uh next thing
you know you're he's handing you over to
Prince Albert or whatever his guy's name
wasw prince Andrew yeah Prince Albert
that's that's the one that's going to
through your
dick but uh yeah
so make
sure your kids are
aware of this that this is a reality now
I'm sure nowadays it's probably people
know better but back in the 90s no they
didn't they didn't they didn't know
about this yeah this is like '90s and
2000s well actually goes back kind of to
the 80s but I think it was mostly going
on the 90s and 2000s
yeah but it's it's a wild program yeah
it's some crazy [__] it's some crazy
[__] um you know it just goes to show
that you give a dude some money and uh
he just turns into a [__] monster I
guess well I think it was his job too
yeah I don't know about that um maybe
but I think he also enjoyed it because I
think he was a [__] pervert uh him
and gilain both I think they were both
[__] perverts and they got off on it
um you know and they you know and and
obviously they were blackmailing people
yeah that's what intelligence that's
what does right yeah but but I think
they enjoyed it also yeah well you had
to enjoy your job so a lot of the
predation he was doing on these girls
he's three of them a day okay that's how
big his Little Empire his little hooker
Empire underage hooker Empire it's like
three of a day he was also Talent
scouting from that on he was picking the
best ones so he could have a [__]
special forces under
age hooker team basically to take them
to those islands so they could get
recordings of them having sex with dudes
that were ran big business get dirt on
them to get dirt on them yeah yeah and
uh I guarantee you that's that wasn't
just his idea he was being paid to do
this by Foreign intelligence agents I'm
sure either the CIA or the
mad then you could run a big part of the
United States just on remote control
and they were penetrating universities
corporations governments justice
department I mean to be honest I'm
actually shocked that they finally like
yeah like convicted himay too what
you're talking about is right out of
[__] Ian Fleming's books it's Spectre
yeah Spectre is what it is and I think
the victims were shocked also like when
he actually got arrested they were like
holy [__] we didn't you think anything
was going to get done about it
but there did seem to
be um you know some people who were
investigating that case who were really
really wanted to [__] get him you
know what I mean yeah and they just like
stuck with it for years and years and
years so you know hats off to them man
but yeah it was a rough road let's let's
say that high desert says that was aab
oil shakes have been doing this for ages
this has been going on for ages I mean
it's just that it's the internet the
internet has really kind of helped
expose this and the first time I heard
about this I didn't believe it back in
the it must have been around 2008 2009 I
was on YouTube and there was this crazy
[__] named Alex Jones talking
about this and I didn't believe a word
of it turned out everything he said
those in 2008 2009 turned out to be true
was before anybody knew about that
island and he was naming names
and it's not he wasn't he wasn't making
it up it was just that people that
worked on that island were telling him
the shitty thing about it though is that
they
knew I mean um we'll kind of get into it
in a bit but there were at least two
women who were girls at the time we were
minors uh or at least one of them was a
minor they were sisters and they
reported uh Epstein and gilain Maxwell
to the FBI back in
1996 but nobody really did anything no
part of that because they worked for
them so yeah they were in they were part
of the system they didn't really like
get until like almost 10 years later
when all these other stories started
coming out and then they went back and
state of Florida try to do something
about it and uh the response was you we
can't do anything to him he's he he's
int he's he's working with intelligence
that's what they
told um State of Florida I believe it
was Florida State Police Chief they said
we can't do anything about it so yeah
that's what that's how they got rid of
the floor flid the Florida eventually
came back and got him though yeah but
they tried to keep him locked up he had
to to serve a 18-month sentence yeah
we'll get in but they kept telling them
you know evidently the higher ups in
Washington
DC probably FBI or CIA kept telling no
just let him do what he want you know
let him leave he because he really
didn't stay in prison he left anytime
yeah he wasn't really I thought it was
funny because like on the documentary on
Netflix like they had like a journalist
who I think she worked for a paper in
West Palm Beach I think and um or maybe
the Miami Herold I can't remember but um
she said yeah she's like he was just
like walking around like going to work
and [__] like that she's like so it was
just like it wasn't even like jail it
was like staying at like a really bad
Motel you're right like pretty much and
uh another thing that that I I like
Netflix for is that they also said that
his death was very suspicious if he did
die I'm not 100% convinced that he died
well like I said I don't know I wasn't
there but to pull a mission off like
that
to get into a prison and kill him and
then take his body out if you were s
trying to silence him and you have the
ability to do that then you also have
the ability to just extract him from the
prison alive pretending to be dead and
then make up a [__]
bogus [__] um what do you call it
coroners
report I didn't see the body I wouldn't
trust anything from any of these people
until I saw [__] with myself I wouldn't
even trust photographs I'd have to be
there there That's how little
credibility they have for me they just
lie Nicholas said I heard somewhere that
Epstein wanted to clone himself or
believed in some form of reincarnation
technique I don't think it was so much
cloning he wanted to um basically seed
the human race with his DNA we'll get
into that he was real into like Eugenics
and stuff yeah he was trying to make
copies of themselves with these girls
yeah like he was going to have a
breeding population and like dude was a
[__] like [__] basically uh like
[__] jangus Khan
yeah like a it's just it's a crazy
[__] story like I said these people
just have entirely too much [__]
money and the thing about it is that I
was kind of thinking about this while I
was watching because I actually watched
the documentary two times because I
watched it while you were in
Mississippi because I didn't know if I
was going to be doing the show about
that but then you know I was like well
do you want to see it so we watched it
again the other night and we watched the
gilain Maxwell one too which is just one
episode but um so we're were watching
that and I'm thinking to myself
did he just get like this after he made
all this money or was he just like a
[__] sociopath from the jump cuz he
seemed like a pretty normal kid from
everything that he was a sociopath from
the jump I mean he lied and cheated to
get to where he did in life that he was
that's true I mean he was a little bit
older then but and he was [__] that
old dude to get that money that's the
story oh yeah they called him the
boyfriend they did yeah yeah they
mentioned that on the Netflix show too
yeah
um but yeah we'll get into all this but
like I said hopefully the show isn't
like five [__] hours long I did kind
of trim some [__] out like I said most
of the [__] I trimmed out was just stuff
about like the financial kind of [__]
cuz he was up to all kind of shenanigans
there which like I said it's interesting
but I think that that's probably not
what most people are want to know about
right um so yeah so before we get too
far into the the Meer uh I would like to
say thank you to our newest Patron yes
we have a new Patron oh okay Named Dave
Baxter from New Zealand oh cool all
right so thank you very much uh welcome
on board also um our friend mut who who
sent us this book I think I showed this
the other day sent this book the other
day he sent another one about the same
topic right there which is kind of about
this crazy case that happened in um
Minnesota I think so he clearly really
wants us to do a show about this so I'm
going to have to like read these books
and like get into that so we will
definitely do a show about that cuz I
don't know hardly anything about it so
thank you very much for sending the book
also um I just wanted to mention as if
this year hasn't been uh full of death
already uh my stepdad uh passed away
yesterday oh family dying off um yeah
well and I don't know I think I
mentioned on the show that like at the
end of 2023 my grandmother died and then
one of my uncles died too like a couple
weeks after that he had Alzheimer's so
like I said it's just kind of like none
of it was
unexpected but it just kind of happened
cuz I mean your dad just died like last
week right it was just like last week so
then like my my mom just like texted me
like yesterday and she was like yeah
he's going to hospice like I knew he was
doing bad but I didn't know he was that
close uh to death you know what I mean
so I'm kind of worried about my mom I
don't know she's going to the funeral
home tomorrow my brother's going with
her cuz he lives kind of over there
nearby so we'll see how that goes but
yeah it's [__] crazy so you know not
not too great a start to the year but
you know what are you going to do it's a
cycle of life well I know sorry every
time somebody says that I always think
of like The Lion King yeah yeah the
circle of
life you know what I mean I just I
always think of that I don't know why
it's it's my curse I suppose my dad
couldn't stay around his health wasn't
good enough yeah I mean you know kind of
the same thing uh kind of the same thing
Oscar says have either of you read A
Confederacy of Dunces I did but it was a
long time ago I loved it but um it's
actually due for a reread probably but
uh but yeah I read it I don't know if
you did but I did I really liked it a
lot never heard of it yeah it's yeah
it's real
good um yeah so everybody saying like
condolences thank you very much thank
you very much like I said I'm mostly
worried about my mom how she's GNA how
she's going to get on because she kind
of lives out in the middle of nowhere
and now she's going to be out there by
herself so we'll just kind of see how
that
goes um but but yeah so you want to get
into this yeah [__] story yeah let's
start this off like hopefully it doesn't
take all night everybody's here
everybody's here hopefully it doesn't
take all night so let's kind of start
I'm not going to jump in too much I'm
just going to I mean you can but you
know what I mean cuz you watch the same
[__] too so if you and and the thing
about it is that I tried to remember and
like put in things that you know in the
notes that were in the thing that that
were in the documentary that maybe
weren't in some of the other sources um
so I tried to get it complete but I
don't I don't know so you might remember
something that I didn't remember yeah
from the show so let's kind of start out
so okay so Jeffrey Epstein um was from
as I said kind of a working class
background like his mom just worked like
at a school she was like a teacher's aid
or something like that his dad was a
groundskeeper for the New York City um
uh what do you call it uh Parks and
Recreation Department so he grew up in
like I said kind of a workingclass area
in uh Coney Island now everyone said it
was a real nice family and he seemed
like he has a brother named uh Mark I
think his brother's name is but um
everybody said he seemed like a pretty
good kid like he seemed real sweet he
was kind of nerdy uh he was super super
good at math uh he actually ended up
skipping two grades so he graduated from
high school at 16 he was also um I don't
know if you'd call him a musical prodigy
but he was like a real good uh musician
like he could play piano he started
really young and uh went to like a music
school for a little while so he actually
ended up taking advanced math classes
and I think this probably helped him
[__] his way through life like later
on because he was really good at math so
he went to Cooper Union for a little
while like a college and then he went to
um like a kind of a fancy math School in
New York but he didn't get a degree
though like I guess he dropped out after
a couple couple of years now even though
he had dropped out of school and never
got a degree he was still able to get a
job in 1974 as a teacher like he taught
math and physics at the Dalton School in
uh Manhattan in the Upper East Side
which is kind of a fancy school um
apparently he lied on his resume
basically um and they didn't check
because it's the 70s and it was a lot
harder to check back then or they didn't
bother um so a lot of the students
seemed to like him but there were also
rumors even back then that he
was um kind of showing inappropriate
interest in the students the female
students who were underage at the time
and would sometimes like hang out with
like he would show up at student parties
and stuff like that you know what I mean
which is a little weird like if you're a
teacher um you'd probably really get in
trouble for that nowadays but it was the
70s so they they did think it was weird
back then it was weird enough for them
to think it was weird but you
know now while he was a teacher at this
school um two of his students their dad
was Alan Greenberg who at the time was
the CEO of be Sterns which if you
remember anything about the financial
collapse of 2008 that was kind of one of
the big players in that so that guy's
son and daughter went to the school and
apparently uh he met
um Greenberg at like some kind of parent
teacher deal and after after um epine
got fired from Dalton he um was able to
wangle his way into a job at be Sterns
now they gave him a job like kind of
lower level but apparently he was super
[__] hot at whatever I don't understand
[__] about financial [__] so I don't
really know what he was really good at
numbers but yeah but but he was really
really good at that like so good that
they were like super impressed and he
like went like really Rose through the
ranks like really really quickly um I
mean they basically gave him he worked
there for four years and then they made
him like a partner you know what I mean
that's how quickly like he moved up in
the [__] now the thing about it was that
and one of the guys that had hired him
or had been one of the people that hired
him was on the Netflix documentary and
he said that after about only about two
months of him working there they're like
holy [__] he was amazing and he could do
all this stuff and he was really good at
his job after about 2 months of him
working there they happened to discover
that all of his all the [__] on his
resume was fake he hadn't gone to any of
the schools and anything like he just
pulled it out of his ass right yeah um
so they confronted him about
it and well because the one guy he's
like he went to his boss and he's like
what should I do like he just totally
made all this [__] up and the boss was
like well treat him like you treat
anybody else like you know fire his ass
but apparently uh Epstein was able to
charm his
way to into giving like them giving him
a second chance essentially like um and
the guy was explaining it he's like he
was just really charismatic and he he's
like when we said hey you lied on your
resume he admitted it like right away
but then he just had this kind of story
like oh well I didn't think that I'd get
a chance because I didn't have the
credentials and blahy blah and they're
like why didn't you tell us though and
they're like well I thought you know I
taught at Dalton and I thought they
would find out and I didn't want to lose
my job there and yada yada so he
apparently had this kind of Saab story
and he was really good at putting it a
class they kind of felt sorry for him I
guess they didn't want to kick him out
to the woles yeah so they like let him
work there so this guy is just kind of
like I still regret that to this [__]
day I never I should have just like
thrown him out on his ass would have
ruined him for life this never would
have happened right well it's you know
hindsight's 2020 I I felt kind of bad
for that guy um cuz he didn't know like
what monster this dude would become um
but he's like you know every day he's
just kind of like I really wish I just
fired his dumb ass and like thrown him
out in the street so he was kicking ass
in a job that he wasn't qualified for
actually or the way these
companies way they figure people being
qualified or unal unqualified I think is
full of [__] anyway and they probably
knew that they were full of [__] if the
dude could do the job who cares how he
learned it and so they let him stay he
could do it he was he was [__] hot at it
yeah who gives a [__] he lied that's why
I think that I mean that I think that
probably went a long way toward them
giving him a second chance um other than
him just like admitting it as soon as
they confronted him with it because he
was really good at his job evidently um
you know had he been just mediocre or
something like that yeah they probably
would have just caned there there was a
guy who was a con man while he was in
prison read a bunch of books about uh
medical stuff and medical procedures and
when he got out he conned his way into a
hospital as a [__] surgeon yeah and
was in there doing surgeries well Frank
abil did that too I've been wanting to
do a show about that [__] he
didn't just do surgeon he did he flew
airplanes he did all kind of crazy [__]
yeah and but that one guy who was a
surgeon he um he said he was real good
yeah he was a real good surgeon and he
faked the whole [__] thing so so he
was intelligent he knew what he was
doing he read the books it just makes
you it makes it just makes you think you
know how hard is that stuff really well
I always kind of feel like here look
okay so here's something that my
grandfather always told me he told my
mom this like and all his kids that he
had and he told me this he always said
you know if someone else can learn to do
it you can learn to do it yeah but the
thing about it is that
um okay if it's something like surgery I
would rather that that person had gone
to a school had been monitored like they
for sure knew that they knew how to do
that I'm not saying that like a person
that didn't go to school couldn't teach
themselves to do that cuz obviously you
can you can teach yourself to do
anything if you're um if you have the
motivation to do that but it's just like
I kind of feel like it's not so much oh
you know they didn't go to school so
they don't know how to do that it's just
like you have to have some level of yeah
transparency of like we know that you
know how to do that because everybody
checked on you you know what I you got
to be a real sociopath or a real
psychopath to go you know what I'm not
really a doctor but I know what I'm
doing stand back let me cut into this
woman you know what I mean that's what I
mean that's horrifying first time and
never done it before and they're they're
expecting like a an advanced complicated
surgery to happen that's horrifying sure
you got you got nurses around you you
know what I mean who might be like what
the [__] are you doing dude he knew the
procedure right he knew the procedure he
read it before before he did it yeah but
you got to have serious balls it reminds
me well yeah my buddy Eric when he got
when he got out of active duty he went
to a reserve Airborne unit I think was
called I think it was the
173rd and while he was there one of the
dudes that would go on jumps and
everything uh uh he had been in that un
that reserve unit for years as like a
spec four they uh he shows up to uh to
uh uh to some training exercise and the
MPS arrested him and took him away came
back later that was not a real
soldier that was a guy whose brother was
a soldier he adopted his
[__] identity stole his identity and
was going to the reserve in that guy's
place and [__] doing [__] like
jumping out of
airplanes and [__] going to life fire
rages and and and doing things for the
first time he had no training but he
heard all the stories that his brother
told him so he kind of I can do that
knew how to fake Well he kind of knew
how to fake right he would tell fake
Army stories of what he did at Bragg
Fort Brag yeah but those are stories he
heard from his brother and he just fit
in like one of the guys guys and but he
was doing it for years so I guess he was
a soldier but he didn't have any
training for that he just learned on the
job and just did what everybody else
did and I think most people could
probably do that like I said if they had
the motivation to do that it's just
that I don't know it's it's weird to me
because I've always been fascinated by
people with that kind of personality
because there are some people that are
just kind of pathological liars and they
just like make [__] up all the time and
to me it just seems like so much work
like to have to keep track of all of
those [__] stories that you're
telling and it just seems like too much
trouble when you could just be honest
but you know some people seem to get off
on that like I said I think that's why I
was always so fascinated by Frank abing
nail um they made a well they wrote a
book about him and then they made a
movie about it called Catch Me If You
Can which is really good but the book is
much better think what balls you need to
do just to insinuate yourself
into I don't have that and fit in like
why would I even want to do that he
wanted to do army stuff I mean okay but
he didn't want to go he just wanted it
but he just wanted to like take the easy
he wanted to take EAS he just wanted to
walk in and start doing it yeah he's
like I don't want to go to all this
training basic training and [__] go
to active duty and [__] [__] all that
yeah I just want to go over there and
I'll jump out of that
airp I mean okay fair enough like I said
some things I guess it wouldn't matter
but you know somebody like Frank abigil
who you know was doing surgery on people
and also flying airplanes um that's a
little more problematic like obviously
he never killed anybody or anything like
that but still I don't I don't want to
think that some fraudster is like flying
my [__] plane around or cutting my
stomach open or something we know those
people are pretending to fly the
plane probably AI now well much of it is
uh automated for sure but you know you
probably Twisted some of those put those
guys but you still have to know you
still have to be trained in all the
procedures like if some [__] goes wrong
yeah but it still makes you wonder how
good those guys are yeah well there's
probably a lot of them that are very
mediocre well most people are mediocre
yeah I mean I'm not saying that to be
like
a I'm just saying most people are
average that's why it's called average
yeah you know what I mean not everybody
can be like really good at [__] they're
going to maess up and you know and
humans are humans they make mistakes you
know what I mean Gan could fly a
helicopter and she was never trade for
it they just taught her to do it she
didn't have a privot license well like I
said if I really wanted to learn how fly
a helicopter and somebody said I'll show
you how to fly a helicopter I could
learn how to fly a helicopter that's
some wild [__] I just don't really want
to do that the very very rich people
don't need licenses to do anything and
they don't need they don't need
passports well they live in an entirely
entire yeah they can fly into any
country World um they land in in in in
private airports that their friends owns
nobody they don't even know that they're
there yeah and it's like an
international agreement between these
countries which means that if you wanted
to you could load that bit [__] up with
expensive white powders and drive it and
fly it all around they probably do I'm
sure they probably do well they were
doing it with underage girls well yeah
flying them all around a lot harder to
smuggle than drugs that's for
sure so you know like I said you have
money you can get away with anything I
mean that's always been true since yeah
since money was
invented um but yeah so so basically I
think while he was still working for
Bear Sterns he actually started his own
company and this was in
1981 and the job of this company was
like a consulting firm I guess and what
they would do is that they helped people
that you know rich people that had had
their money embezzled like they would
help them get it back um also I think
they also worked to the other side and
helped embezzlers also but at least that
was the
story um and also around this time in
the 80s this was when abstein started
telling people that he was an
intelligence agent now whether or not
because there have been cuz like you
said we'll get into a little bit later
but there have been allegations that he
actually was an intelligence agent but
if he was I kind of feel like it's dumb
to tell people but maybe he's doing some
kind of like weird oh well I think fake
out thing I don't think he was just well
I know he definitely wasn't humble he
smart but he wasn't humble he would brag
about something he was an arrogant
[__] because it wouldn't matter
if you knew or not think about it and I
don't think I don't think he went was
trained by them or a member of an this
was still fairly early so I don't even
know if he was I mean this was the early
' 80s May oh early ' 80s okay maybe he
just wanted to yeah but then later on
maybe he was just [__] a lot of the
guys that do that kind of stuff are they
just happen to be civilians in a certain
position to where they can get
information and sell it to a foreign
agent to a foreign government or to an
or to an intelligence agency they're an
agent all right or an operative I think
is what they called an agent I think is
a controller to them if I remember
correctly I don't remember the
terminology but you could probably call
him an agent yeah so I don't really know
if he was just bullshitting because he
wanted to seem cooler than he actually
was or if he was actually an agent is
like a mercenary yeah he could he's just
possible like yeah he's not do have a
badge or a gun he's not even on their
payroll in that particular sense as a as
a as a member you know what I mean it's
just a like a somebody you can pay to do
something you know what I mean you're
bribing people intelligence agencies
bribe people to do stuff and I think at
this point yeah I don't think he was
quite I mean he was probably still rich
but I don't think he was as rich as he
became later on because this was kind of
before he started doing the the Hedge
fun [__] he probably would had a fantasy
of doing that yeah maybe so that maybe
came true eventually when you got strong
when you got rich enough now I will note
that they did find when they raided his
house like and I'm jumping way ahead
when they raided his house like for the
um sex trafficking charges in a safe
they did find a fake passport it had his
picture on it but it had a different
name it was an Austrian passport yeah
but it had expired in
1987 as far as I know yeah um but you
know what I mean he didn't need
passports though that's what I mean it's
like why would you even have that he did
it one time like I think he said yeah it
had been used like it had stamps in it
and stuff but by the time they found it
it had expired like a long time ago he
had his own aircraft so he could fly it
yeah he had like a 727 or something yeah
so when you have your own aircraft you
can fly it to private airports and land
in one of your friends Landing strips
you
know there's like a transponder on the
aircraft their radar can see you coming
in they go oh that's a private plane and
they they kind of know oh that's a real
Rich dude's private plane they don't pay
any attention to that [__] yeah you know
what I mean because you know Rich
there's agreements that you don't
there's already agreements be with those
oh yeah he's a [__] billionaire or a
head of state or something yeah well the
thing about it is if you say boo to them
for doing something then they'll have
you killed so or sued or they'll or
they'll sue you into like [__]
Oblivion they didn't have to kill you
probably no just sue the [__] out of you
and well the thing about it too and I
think that was uh a factor with a lot of
the girls um that were abused by him was
that you know these girls were just
regular workingclass school girls and
what the [__] are they going to do I
mean he has billions of dollars
allegedly um you know there's some
dispute about that but um and we'll get
to ACC uh according to the um Miami what
was it Miami Police is that what what
was the name of that yeah it West Palm
West Palm Beach uh police department the
girls ran the cabinet great Gambit from
get this [__] away from me he's
crazy all the way up to I love this
[__] I'm GNA marry Jerry you
know or Epstein I'm gonna marry so some
of the girl at least half the girls
liked him they didn't all rat on him he
was very evidently he had a he he was he
was could was mesmerizing he could charm
you so a lot of those girls liked him
yeah yeah um some of them girls didn't
and he seemed to prefer the ones that
didn't like him we were talking about
that last night we were watching the
thing because he really seems to be one
of those to be honest his pathology
seems very similar to a Serial Killer's
pathology in the sense that he can't
really get off unless he's doing
something that the the the victim
doesn't want yeah like he seems to get
off on making them uncomfortable and to
be a power trip and it's yeah like it
seems like if they're too compliant like
he's almost like not into that yeah he
gets bored with them so I mean that's
the impression that I got that he just
really got because Tom was like look he
had billions of dollars he knew all
these powerful people it's like if he
really wanted to [__] all these girls
like you could just do that there's like
escorts there you could even go to other
countries where it's not illegal or
whatever you like whatever you wanted um
so why just get these girls that don't
really want to do it right like you know
that's non-consensual and I said I think
he gets off on it that's why I thought
it I think it was might might be going
too far ahead but maybe I'll talk about
it
now I think it was two things happening
at once he was trying to recruit a dream
team of sex
operatives the clientele that he was
going for were heads of state royalty
dudes that were uh big up in the
University system professors they're not
going to be turned on by hookers they're
going to be turned off by
that so they had to have a good girl
image and they had to come off as a
regular civilian chick but they had to
be real
beautiful and they had to be very young
or the black male wouldn't
work so he was trying to
find based on the ones that he kept
around for a long time ones that seemed
innocent but they were
obedient and that they would do the job
and they didn't come off off as Pros if
they came off as a pro he'd just do them
but then he wouldn't keep them yeah it
was kind of like failing the uh cuz he
always had new ones yeah he always had
new ones it was I mean we're talking
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds three
of them a day for years of girls three
brand new ones a day uh [__] three
years average
now if he was doing this for himself
just for sexual
gratification there was a lot easier
ways to do that especially with the
money that he had
he didn't need three new ones every day
he could have had four or five ones that
liked him that wouldn't rat on him that
he could could have kept for years I
mean it seems a much easier way to stay
out of prison right and then he's having
like a real relationships with them
they're like girlfriends they're just
very young and then when they're no
longer interesting you can damn buy them
off and retire them buy them a house
take care of them whatever put them out
the pasture make sure they have Norm
noral lives he wasn't doing that though
nope what he was doing was
uh chewing through a bunch of them to
look for specific one and then the
relationship is kind of abusive mentally
abusive to him he and physically abusive
in some cases in some cases you're right
yeah yeah he liked he liked to uh
non-compliance he liked or he liked
submission that'd be a good way to put
it that they don't want to do it but
they're going to do it anyway yeah I
think he enjoyed like I said I think he
enjoyed having power over people it's
like I know you don't want to do it but
you're going to do it anyway yeah and if
it was just
sex there was no reason why he had to go
with the underage thing he would have
been a dream client because I mean
that's just ask him for trouble really
he would have been a dream client
for professional girls you know 18 19 20
21 25 he did have sex with older women
yeah they weren't all
underage most of them but he had enough
money and power where he could get them
of legal
age a lot of them and keep them around
and and they he they and and there would
have been no problem dudes are doing
that that's what I mean and the thing
about it it's like look it's not it's
not great okay but had he and even his
scumbag girlfriend yeah had they just
been like Hey we're going to we're into
weird [__] and Kinks and whatever like
these girls and we like these girls so
we're just going to hire you know
18-year-olds and everyone's consenting
yeah um no one would have complained
that's not really illegal no and those
girls would be fighting to come back you
know what I mean those those girl like I
said if you look in that if you
understand that industry that type of
escort the high-end escort they would
have been fighting to get back on that
island they would have loved it and like
I said it's just kind of like look I
don't there's really I you know I don't
want to hang out with people like that
cuz it's still kind of sleazy but it's
not like illegal he wouldn't have been
like in trouble uh yeah I I don't know
CU like I said everyone's consenting so
well in some of in some of those States
any kind of prostitution is illegal I
think in yeah yeah but I'm just saying
that if he had money and if G would have
been misdemeanor right yeah because I
mean usually it's just like a [__]
fine or if he could have just gone to
other countries like the Netherlands or
something like that where it's not like
the same that might have been
prostitution may have been legal on that
little isot maybe I don't yeah I'm not
really sure what the law I don't know
what the jurisdiction was I mean that's
the us there be no way to get caught
there anyway because there's no cops on
that island right so and you got to fly
to get into it or go to a boat but the
fact but see the fact that he had to
have well like you said the underage
girls I think one he was into that um
and two they had to be underage for
blackmail black purp because if you just
had I mean if you just recorded somebody
[__] 19 an 18 19y old hooker like you
know that's bad but everybody be like n
that's not black male not really like
you know their wife might be mad but
other than that it's not illegal at that
at that level though the wives don't
give a [__] because that's going out
anyway and then so they had to be
underage yeah they had to be they had to
be
underage but like I said by the same
token I think he was into that too yeah
well I think you have to be into it in
order to know how to proc procure it and
to work with that you he liked him young
oh yeah big time um and he had a
reputation for that like I said even
going back to like the old days yeah
going after like students and stuff so
uh so yeah so what was I saying oh okay
so about the passport that he had the
passport it was an Austrian passport but
it actually said that he lived in Saudi
Arabia now when he had his consulting
firm one of his big clients at that
consulting firm was a Saudi Arabian
businessman whose name I'm not even
going to attempt to pronounce now he was
actually the dude that helped like he
was transferring the American weapons
like from Israel to Iran like that was
the whole Iran Contra thing so that was
one of his uh clients
and he actually they knew that he did
travel in the mid1 1980s between um he
went to Asia and you know in Europe and
stuff like that so he was doing some
sketchy [__] like around this time now
during this period where he was
traveling all around the world he met
this dude this you know businessman Big
Rich Mogul or whatever named Stephen
hoffenberg now hoffenberg actually hired
Epstein in 8
and he was um he hired him as a
consultant for this uh collection agency
essentially it was called Towers
Financial Corporation and what they
would do it was at first it was this
company that would buy people's debts
like the people you know that had
medical bills or whatever they would buy
people's debts and so at first he sets
Epstein up in an office in Manhattan
pays him like 25 Grand a month back then
which is now like 65 Grand a month which
is a lot of money um so they did that
for a little while but then they decided
and hoffenberg was on the Netflix
documentary too talking about him um so
then um they decided Well we can make a
lot more money as like corporate Raiders
essentially so um so yeah they they went
that
direction uh which so they were doing
illegal stock trading [__] like that uh
hoffenberg like I said he admitted it
and he said Epstein was right there
helping out they made all kind of
[__] money they think that's where a
lot of Epstein's like initial money came
from was from this period um
so what happened after that so they did
that for a few years then in the early
90s um the whole thing came tap came
tumbling down because it was a Ponzi
scheme essentially and even hoffenberg
admitted as much uh they lost $450
million of their investors money uh
which is uh more than 900 million in
today's money and um even though
hoffenberg said that Epstein had been
with him every step of the way he knew
everything that was going on he was
doing all the illegal [__] too but EPC
never got charged um I think I know why
that might be which I'll get into a
little bit later on um and they they're
not sure if he got any of the stolen
money it's probable I would imagine
hoffenberg actually did uh get in
trouble he got
convicted well he plad guilty actually
to the um SEC and he um it was $475
million in fraud so I think he did do
some uh prison time but he's out now
because he was he was on the documentary
talking and he's very open about the
illegal [__] they were doing you know
what I mean he already did time for he
already did time and I guess he can talk
about it and it's fine but he was like
yeah Epstein um the a l a lot of people
on the documentary you know like the
older dudes that knew him and stuff like
that said that Epstein one of the things
that was kind of a Common Thread running
throughout their [__] not so much the
women didn't say this but the men did
they said that he could basically talk
you into anything like he was super
charismatic and super
manipulative and he just had a way of
getting people to do what he wanted it's
funny that that he's described that way
because as soon as that dude opens his
mouth of any recording that I've heard
of that guy he just an immediate turn
off from me you know being a southerner
we to to us that accent just sounds
really trashy and real greasy is it's a
Brooklyn he has a ACC it's just a nasty
although they say the same thing about
Southern Accents they do it just says a
nasty
nasally sounding slimy it's not as bad
as the Long Island accent yeah it's like
you're talking to a criminal like a
stereotypical gangster out of the old
like I said not everybody from Brooklyn
is a criminal but yeah for some reason
well like I said it's just kind of like
how people have a perception that people
with Southern Accents are dumb yeah they
didn't have education a lot of people
that think people with Brooklyn accents
yeah are criminals yeah for whatever
reason lot of those very educated people
you know uh [__] that you're that in
in the main stream are actually like
from Mississippi and Alabama they just
don't use the
accent was there was actually what was
it what was that damn uh author from
Mississippi Mitchner I think no was it
James Mitchner I think yeah I think he
was from Mississippi was he okay I don't
know oh yeah there's a lot of I think
actually his books are boring as [__] I
have to say I think it was they're like
[__] a thousand P yeah it's like a
[__] door he writes it one door stop
after I think it was him I don't hold me
to it one I think I read one of his
books that I could have kep I was just
like and I've read some long [__] but I
was just kind of like dude oh my God
it's so long but yeah um but yeah I get
it it's I to me like he didn't have like
a super thick Brooklyn accent like I've
heard way thicker ones but yeah I see I
see what you're talking but like I said
it's not fair to anybody's like I this
happens a lot cuz when I lived in the UK
um I it's probably different now but
when I was there back it was like a big
thing like what accent you had because
over there um you know even though it's
very small like you can tell where
someone's from like down to like a
[__] square five miles pretty much
like by what accent they have if you
were show them but it but it's very um
it's very tied into class yeah class if
uh Alabama Mississippi Alabama Florida
Panhandle Kentucky Tennessee if you show
up with that Brooklyn style accent the
defenses will go up if you're talking to
those people especially out in the the
more rural area they they're probably
not going to believe you unless you know
depends if you're a cute looking chick
then that that's very different but uh
no
it's immediate especially the older
Generations yeah not so much mine but I
never really ran into I mean I don't
have a I mean I'm from the South but I
never really had a super thick
uh southern accent at least not in my
perception my very mild yeah my dad's
side of the family had much stronger
Southern Accents um because they were
from Tennessee and various other areas
but it I guess it was because my mom's
side of the family was from
Baltimore um and they didn't really you
know they just had kind of generic white
people accents you know what I mean so I
guess it just kind of evened out I do
kind you know I do say Southern things
like y'all and stuff but yeah cuz I grew
up around my grandma but I don't really
have like a super thick southern
accent um but yeah
so so I kind of feel like this and and
this was kind of what the Netflix thing
thing was saying too it's like this
might have been where epsteen got a
large portion of his wealth at least at
the beginning because like I said
there's kind of a the weird thing about
it is that when he kind of first showed
up in society or whatever because he was
live he had a house in in New York City
and he had a house in West Palm that he
bought in the 90s and um a lot of people
when he showed up cuz he was new money
and they didn't really know where his
money came from like everybody like he
would show up at parties and stuff but
he was kind of like this man of mystery
type of thing so a lot of people thought
he was like really interesting because
he's like hey he's apparently a
billionaire but they didn't really know
like what he did or anything like that
but um I kind of feel like this the
corporate rating that's probably where a
lot of his money came from I think he
stole a lot of it to be honest from
various investors and what with thieves
yeah I think that's where he got a lot
of all his money and at least according
to several sources that I've read he
might not have been as rich as he was
pretending to be like he was still rich
I'm not saying that but they're saying
that you know they're saying oh he's a
billionaire they're like probably not he
had power though cuz they said that in
2008 when the when the [__] collapsed
like he lost a lot have money so they
don't think that he had as much money as
he pretended to have at some point but I
don't know if that's true I'm just
saying like I saw a bunch of sources
that said that that he wasn't as rich as
he pretended to
be now so while him and hoffenberg are
still doing their thing in the 80s late
80s um he founds another company like a
financial management firm now his thing
now is like okay well I'm going to
manage all of these rich people's money
and I'm only going to deal with
billionaires now no body knows if that's
true or not because the only for real
billionaire that they know was his
client they don't know about the other
people was Les Wexner now Les Wexner was
the CEO of he um he owned the limited
and Victoria's Secret among other things
so he was a billionaire like he had a
[__] ton of money this is an interesting
part of the story because I think this I
think this is where estein started to
develop himself into basically a sex
operative
yeah perhaps so perhaps so so so this
guy Les Wexner was his client so he was
managing his wealth now this guy like I
said now anybody that's a billionaire is
probably doing illegal [__] I'm just you
know I don't think that's controversial
to say but he did own a bunch of big
Brands like I said so it's not crazy to
think that he had a lot of money so he
hires Epstein to manage his wealth now
interestingly
um within like a year of this dude being
his
client the dude hands
over full power of attorney to
Epstein meaning that Epstein can do
everything like on this dude's behalf he
can sign his checks he can hire people
he can spend the dude's money he can
like buy properties he can sell
properties he can do everything on this
dude's behalf
now somebody on the Netflix documentary
that knew the dude was like this is not
the type of dude I mean he was a
billionaire this was not the type of
dude that would just give up control of
his money to somebody like that you know
what I mean like especially after not
that long a time I think it was like I
said only a
year so you know so a lot of people
thought that was a little fishy they
said around this time period there were
rumors I don't know if this is true or
not there were rumors that Epstein had
maybe got into a sexual relationship
with Wexler Wexner rather um in order to
either manipulate him and or uh
blackmail him like into giving him
control of his money both and all I yeah
I kind of think probably both of those
things are true I mean it's in the kind
of
pathology of this dude to have success
in Victory at all
cost if that means he's got to blow some
old dude or give up the booty to get
billions or his hands on billions or
millions of dollars he'd do it yeah he
does stri trying to climb up do that and
if he could do it in his
mind he could get these girls to do it
he's not asking them to do anything that
he wouldn't do that's his thinking
that's like his justification like his
justification he's going to turn them
into a sex operative to get money and
power over powerful men but he's going
to gain from it not so much that girl
but they but you when you hear
interviews with like
Gan they did not see regular people as
as
people they you were unimportant you
were you were like a nobody the only
people that mattered were like
Millionaires and billionaires those were
people everybody else were just animals
basically so that's why they could tell
the girls to do it they told a girl to
just carry her to carry gan's baby they
didn't even give her a choice they
Virginia Virginia yeah Virginia has the
most was with was with them the longest
she had like the best stories about her
you can find a lot of her interviews
actually on bitshoot
because they're not censorious over
there she yeah and she was on the
Netflix documentary too like talking
about it I think she was with them for
maybe two years but the thing about it
was that when they asked her I thought
it was three or four maybe it was longer
I thought she said two years but um she
said when they asked her to carry a baby
for them yeah um she was basically like
what the [__] and she just like that was
a step too far I guess which didn't ask
her I get it they didn't ask her they
told her and so they said she said okay
well I'll tell you what um you pay for
me to go and get my cuz she was training
to be a massage therapist so um they
said she said okay will you pay for me
to get my degree or my certificate or
whatever and then we'll do it so they
sent they paid to send her to
Thailand to get the certificate because
that's where you learn to be a massage
therapist evidently so when she was in
Thailand she's like I'm getting the [__]
out of here yeah and apparently in
Thailand she met you know the guy that
she would eventually marry and then she
moved to Australia with him because he
was Australian and she basically just
called him and said hey not coming back
sorry bye yeah the funny thing she
escaped the funny thing funny thing
about these people is that they have
access to
millions and they're paying these girls
like
$200 well the I mean they were paying
like the teenage girls that because they
probably thought Ah that's all they're
worth that's probably what they thought
$200 for something that's like that's
like a quarter to them yeah but but you
know what I mean they they they kind of
script on them on them uh in one of
Virginia's um interviews she saw a book
that Jeffrey had it was like a fetish
book on how to manage slaves yeah I I
was going to get into okay yeah I wrote
that down yeah and D told her that she
was a slave yeah yeah so that was one of
the things that they I'll get into that
later after they raid raided his [__]
like what they like all these books that
he had or ordered or
whatever but yeah so he apparently got a
lot of money out of this dude um and he
got a lot of money in fees like for
managing other people's money too so I
think that's kind of where some of the
money came from but for real either like
I said he was [__] this dude or and
or he was procuring maybe underage girls
for this dude too like for blackmail
purposes because everybody that knew
this dude was like no way would he give
up power of attorney like over his
entire Fortune essentially because
Epstein could do he could sign checks
for the dude he could buy property for
the dude he could sell property for the
dude and [__] like that and they're like
that's not the type of dude that would
be like handing over control like that
so he must have had something on him I
feel
like um but yeah so so there was that um
and another thing too is that because um
Wexner owned Victoria's Secret Epstein
would of course use that as like a
leverage for like to meet girls that he
wanted to exploit because he'd be like
hey I know the owner of Victoria Secret
which technically was true um he's like
I can get you in the catalog you know
what I mean uh they did have one girl on
the Netflix thing that said that she was
in Santa Monica I think and um he had
come up and yeah she was a model and you
know and then he just came and like
started groping her and [__] and she's
like [__] that and she got the hell out
of there but you know yeah that was it
was that in hotel or was it it was it
was a hotel he was staying at in
California yeah she walked in and she
saw the photographs she I'd like to see
in you bra and panties and she did she
stripped down she's like uh which isn't
crazy if you're going to be in the
Victoria Secret catalog but still a
little sketch and then without a word he
just starts get just starts trying to
[__] her and she freaks out and [__]
ran yeah I mean uh and I'm sure I'm sure
Jeff was like well what the [__] a
problem because he was used to dealing
with very compliant females and to into
his mind if you came to him looking for
money you're G to [__] you're a hooker
he just assumes that so he's like he I
guess he thought he was a Hollywood
director he's just gonna cast her like
on the couch because he was friends with
Jeffrey with uh Eric what's it Weinstein
yeah Harvey Weinstein Harvey Weinstein
he's friends with him and that's what
that's what Weinstein did he didn't give
you a choice if you wanted that
multi-million dollar movie roll you were
go
[__] what are you going to do leave the
industry become escort I mean that's
kind of their livelihood yeah they don't
yeah you these those actresses can't do
anything they can't work at McDonald's I
mean they could but it's like who
they're not going to do that who wants
to if they get kicked out of Hollywood
you have to get married or you become an
escort that's what they do yeah it's
just well it's [__] sad but then
people know that so they take advantage
so yeah right yeah so these guys know
that so that's you know you want the
[__] will do anything yeah just ask
Tom Cruz I mean a done bad about it
Tom I think some bad it's all just a
rumor I think some bad [__] happened to
him I think some bad [__] happened to
him too but you know we've already gone
into all that Scientology they do it to
the dudes too it's not just the women
yeah it's everybody like like I said any
well anybody that wants something y you
know there's going to be a certain
contingent of people that have that
thing that are going to exploit the
people yeah Hollywood isn't based on
Talent Hollywood acting isn't based on
Talent no so I think and the thing about
too and they went into this a lot on the
documentary was that uh Epstein and
gilain were very good at targeting girls
I mean these were school girls I mean
they were middle school high school
girls that were vulnerable in some way
uh a lot of them were like I said from
workingclass background some of them you
know were essentially homeless or you
know came from broken families like
their parents were alcoholics or drug
addicts or you know some of them had
been sexually abused in the past so they
kind of knew who to Target you know what
I
mean um so I think they were very
deliberate like in the way that they
went about
it so now we're uh at
1996 so Epstein um has this company
still where he's managing all these rich
people's money and he changes the name
of the company and then he moves the
whole operation to the Virgin Islands
because it's a tax shelter right you pay
90% less federal income tax if you B
your [__] there so a lot of people do
that and that's what he
did um and so throughout the 2000s he
just kind of kept investing money in all
these different funds and there was a
bunch of other like I said financial
[__] that happened um he was involved in
a lot of that hedge fund Scandal like
all those collapses and stuff like that
but like I said I kind of left a lot of
that out because it wasn't all that
interesting um and as I mentioned there
is some question about whether like
where his wealth came from or if he was
indeed as as wealthy as he purported to
be a lot of sources seem to think no uh
like I said he's still rich but they
didn't think he was a billionaire um but
I think that a lot of the money like I
said came from that [__] all that
corporate rating and [__] yeah some
people thought or still think that his
money was actually the money that gilain
had inherited from her father that he
had that he yeah that was another rumor
that he had stolen a lot of money from
his investors and [__] yeah I got to PE
and then when he
died his [__] businesses all started
to collapse because they they just they
didn't make any sense it's just more
chicanery that this type of dude
does you know cons and
[__] but there's a possibility that that
money got squirreled away in some kind
of a the stolen money got squired away
in some kind of hidden account that Gan
had access
to so when her dad's dead
she starts scoping out
abstein to be her next man you know and
that she might be funding some of this
see she's [__] gilain and her dad
were some skevy [__] too
evidently her dad had connections to
msad which is an Israeli intelligence
agency allegedly I can't I don't want to
get suit or
allegedly he may have been a sex
operative
himself and he may have trained gilane
also to be a sex operative to get
information and sell information to
governments
allegedly they had a very unusually
close relationship for father and
daughter allegedly it looked very
suspicious to everybody that kind of
matches up with some of the information
that you find in Operation Paperclip
with the Germans that got sucked into
the American military industrial complex
how they did things how they ran
intelligence agencies using orphans and
orphanages or people who were involved
in incest they would sometimes do things
to their own children to help make them
a sex operative that was all his J
1930s even 1930s
German bent cross mustache man
secret uh [__] technology on how to
make sex
operatives it was alleged that maybe
gilain and her dad would had some [__]
yeah they kind of on the Netflix show
that was about her they kind of like
implied that but didn't want to say it
outright it seemed like cuz they did
have a lot of people that knew her and
stuff like that saying their
relationship was was very close you know
what I mean they'd say [__] like that
yeah so I'm not really sure like I said
I wasn't there I don't know but it could
be that her dad died and she got all the
secret money that has stolen and
squirrel away and she linked up with
estein at some point and together they
cooked up a new business plan for
intelligence work uh because you can
gain control over people and information
out of people and sell the sell that
information and sell
the the uh the pull what do you call it
the influence yeah of very powerful
people you know oh you want a certain
drug approved it's okay I know all the
[__] scientists and all the guys in
the FDA and Department of Justice for x
andx amount of dollars we can make sure
your drug gets
approved you know okay or you're foreign
you're China oh you want to know about a
bioweapon we're working on I can find
that out or oh a new jet engine yeah I
know a guy that knows about all the jet
engines that are being built right now
would you like some plans it's going to
cost you well they got access to those
people and that information and all that
pull through sex
operations well like you said sex
operatives are um probably the most
effective yeah kind of it's not 007 it's
some chick that's blowing you and she's
under age and you pictures of you
together you got to do what they say
pretty much another thing is is that you
can join The Gang That Way knowing
what's going on okay I'll go to your
Island take all the pictures you want
you can trust me just break me off some
of that money that's another thing yeah
because they know that they can't [__]
him over because like hey we have
pictures of you and the thing we trust
you now you like with a 13-year-old so
you can't ever [__] us over right so
it's leverage leverage yeah you
know um that's exactly what that is so
as we mentioned earlier and like I said
I had to mention this because this is
[__] crazy but um so yeah so like I
said he was kind of a math whz and all
this other kind of stuff so he was real
into um science and like transhumanism
and he had a lot of money so he would
give a lot of money to um you know
scientific foundations and like research
and stuff like that like in the days
kind of before anybody knew what was
going
on
um and one of the things that he was
interested in was um kind Eugenics kind
of um
in a way that very specifically I think
he wanted to um kind of uh seed the
human race with his DNA as he put it um
I don't know if he put it like that or
somebody else put it like that but um
that's kind of what he wanted to do he
had this whole thing where cuz he had a
ranch in uh New Mexico among his many
other uh properties that he owned and he
wanted to basically have like all these
broodmares like all these ladies out
there um you know just
[__] horrifying this [__]
horrifying he wanted to have them out
there where he could like impregnate
them and he'd have like uh you know all
all kinds of babies and [__] like that
I'm like cuz I guess he thought that can
you imagine the [__] narcissism
you're like I need to like spread my my
DNA around cuz I'm so awesome I'm like
no thanks we have plenty of sociopaths
okay we don't really need any more of
those so let's not thanks but no thanks
uh we don't need any more of your DNA
thank you very much um trying to spread
his seat yeah he was also really into
cronics um apparently he uh wanted to
have his head and his dick
Frozen for future
edification again no thank you you know
thanks for the offer but no thank you um
we we will not be needing your services
um you know I just can't imagine I can't
imagine the narcissism it just guy
thinks that the girls in the trailer
park have bad teeth no no those girls
down those trailer parks they're young
they they're too they're too young to
have bad teeth you should see the ones
that they show pictures of them they
cute I might need another FL is packed
with cute girls cute PK girls got a lot
of them I mean I the thing about it is
that I grew up in a trailer park for a
lot of my life and I didn't really have
dental insurance for most of my life and
my teeth are pretty okay I think I've
only had like one or two cavities like
in my whole entire life I lucked out
like I got genetically I got like pretty
decent teeth so I never even had to have
braces or anything like that for my
parents because I don't think they could
afford have afforded it but it doesn't
it doesn't always happen but you know uh
so yeah baby ranch in New Mexico yeah he
wanted to spread his DNA around I'm like
great so yeah um as I mentioned he was
rolled into uh science and threw a lot
of money around there um also gave a lot
of money to political causes candidates
and stuff like that on both sides uh
Democrat and Republican uh he also put a
lot of money
into uh local races like Sheriff you
know [__] like that um in New Mexico cuz
like I said he had a ranch there and I
think there was even one I can't
remember what um candidate he was giving
to but I think he was trying to get like
off the sex offender registry This was
later on like after he was on the sex
offender registry but he was trying to
like buy his way off of that so there
was that um oh and he also gave like a
bunch of money to various police
departments like buying them equipment
and [__] like that again you know you
can see he's just buying influence is
what he's doing he's like you know he's
a good guy he gave us like
$200,000 to buy new [__] so it's like
how could he possibly be raping teenage
girls you know what I mean um you know
he knew what he was
doing um so yeah now as we mentioned uh
he had a lot of very
famous uh friends here you go and you
know yeah Camp guy he's saying that the
girls didn't have [__] dental
insurance you go go look at look see how
cute those girls were that they were
getting out of trailer park and you'll
see that one of them clearly in her
little picture at [__] 14 has braces
so they got braces in the trailer
park yeah I don't know how much braces
cost back then like I said I never had
to have braces luckily it was '90s so
yeah I mean they were expensive when I
was a kid but they got payment plans for
them though they do yeah so I'm just
glad I never needed any actually I don't
think any of my did any of my siblings
have to have any I don't think so we all
had Fairly straight teeth we locked out
one of them cuz she's got little braces
and that probably helped her get
hired I'm sure Jeff probably liked that
well that yeah she was on there talking
um Michelle I think her name was and um
yeah she was like because when she was
younger because she had braces and stuff
she was super cute though but you know
you have braces you kind of think of
yourself as an ugly duckling I know how
that was but um she's like so when
Epstein got her in there and was was
like talking to her like that like
talking about pretty she was and stuff
it's I kind of feel like she maybe she
was like she kind of fell for it cuz
nobody really like talk to her like that
but she was still creeped out though you
know I feel like she was still pretty
creeped out yeah I mean got to give
credit where credit was due everybody
said that that that Epstein was could be
real charming and real manipulative he's
real good with people he had High human
engineering
skills and well and half them girls
liked him yeah like yeah some people
wouldn't like some of the girls no now
they did get a [__] ton of girls that
came forward and was like this is [__]
up but um some of them wouldn't testify
some of them wouldn't like wouldn't talk
to them like when the cops came doing
the investigation and stuff so some of
them actually did come which is kind of
sad in a way because like I said these
are kids that you're talking about yeah
not all of them no not all some of them
were older yeah some of them were some
them but a lot of them were minors yeah
but he did like get some that were like
19 20 21 something like that so he it
wasn't all underage but that's just
that's what he needed for a lot of to
make money you had to have underage ones
yeah that's what he was using in his
operation so yeah so um so he knew all
these people he knew uh you know prince
Andrew obviously and this guy named Tom
uh baric I think is how he pronounce his
last name he's Big Rich like real estate
investor um you know and he went to
these big he was high up in New York
society and West Palm Society like West
I don't know if y'all know but like was
West Palm is kind of like it's near
Miami West Palm Beach is kind of like
just a regular working class kind of
town but then like West Palm like the
island that's like where all the rich
people live so there's like this big
Causeway that you go over and it's kind
of like two different worlds sort of
thing so it's that um so yeah so he's
kind of high up and said he goes to
parties with all these celebrities and
[__] like that um he had in his uh
contact book he had like rert Murdoch's
name was in there Michael Jackson was in
there like you know all these big
Richard Branson like the guy that owned
virgin whatever um also prime minister
of Israel um was in there Tony Blair who
at the time was British prime minister
and um you know the Saudi Arabian Crown
Prince all that kind of [__] so um yeah
two of the people that obviously like a
lot of people um knew that he knew were
Bill Clinton and Donald Trump so Clinton
um he uh gave a lot of money to uh Bill
Clinton's like f various charitable
foundations and Clinton was actually on
his plane several times I think at one
point cuz I think even was it Virginia
or it wasn't Virginia it was that other
woman that was like 21 at the time she
was like acting as their um assistant or
whatever it was I can't remember what
her name was but she went on the plane
with them they were doing this trip to
Africa for this AIDS charity or whatever
and she's like Clinton was there um uh
Kevin spacy was there and Chris Tucker
was there yeah um and she said nothing
weird went on on that trip um but she
you know she had been abused to by
Epstein like prior to this and it
continued after that but she said
nothing weird happen on this trip but um
but yeah so uh Trump was on the plane at
least one time maybe more than that um I
don't remember where he was going to he
he didn't go to the island he borrowed
it to fly from Florida to New York I
think yeah and um and he was by himself
Este wasn't with yeah I don't think yeah
Clinton was seen on the island once or
twice but like I said he was seen on
there like he wasn't doing anything I'm
not saying he didn't do anything I'm
just saying nobody saw him doing
anything yeah well none of the girls
came forward to say yeah nobody yeah
they saw him there but they said he
wasn't doing it nobody said that he did
anything and because and even Virginia
said she's like well you know just
because somebody was at the island she's
like that doesn't mean they did anything
because people came to the island all
the time yeah Virginia and Virginia is
the one of the best Witnesses she's the
one that fested up to the most stuff she
said just cuz you were on the island
that doesn't necessarily mean you were
there to have sex with those girls yeah
because that wasn't they have parties
there too and there nothing parties and
meetings and [__] like and nothing would
happen there Happ it was just it was
special parties that they were having on
that island yeah so it wasn't every time
and none of the girls said anything
about Bill Clinton or
Trump although um I'm going to get into
one really bad thing from all right one
girl said it didn't happen on the island
it happened at Epstein's house okay that
Trump was involved in allegedly
allegedly yeah and it's bad it's bad
yeah I don't know if it's true or not
you know of course not I mean I read the
complaint it's bad yeah but um what did
it say it happened in the 90s I'll get
to it ' 90s okay happened in the night
oh I uh that was the uh the tweaking of
the nipple story no do not that one it
doesn't have anything to do with
tweaking nipples all right doesn't have
anything to do with tweaking nipples um
yeah Steve Bannon was another person
that uh hung out with epine a lot um
then it was and uh Bill Gates yeah um
had a relationship with him like he
later said I was just trying to get some
money for my [__] Charities but yeah
Bill Gates wife beged to differ though
divorced him behind that [__] yeah so I
don't know what was going on there but
like I said so he knew a lot of people a
lot of people like I said just because a
name was associated with him that
doesn't necessarily mean they were doing
anything illegal I you know maybe it
does I don't know but a lot of people
were trying to get money out of him too
that that was a very small group of
[__] American and European
billionaires they all knew each other
they all knew each other they pretty
small real small
right um yeah so EP
727 apparently the locals in the Virgin
Islands called it the Lolita Express
yeah because it was always coming there
with like underage girls on it which you
know that's that's probably a red flag
right there the the the island is
actually called little St James that's
the official name of the island it's not
actually called EP or pedo island or
whatever they want to call there was a
there's a YouTube channel used I don't
know if it's still up there it's called
Rusty
Shackleford and that was the name of the
channel and whoever owns that channel
has Drone footage of the island it flies
the Drone all over probably about six
seven videos this was right after all
this [__] came out it's pretty cool
Drone footage it's kind of weird they
even get down and look at the damn
little Temple that was there they get
pretty close to it the guys working the
the the black guys who are working on
the lawn see the Drone and [__] [__]
funny yeah they actually the Netflix
documentary is really really nice
footage of it like it's it's also Drone
footage but it's really nice you can
still see all the [__] there yeah drone
evidently was launched from a boat yeah
well there's only another because they
actually on the documentary they had a
guy that lived on St Thomas which he
said it's only like a 10-minute boat
ride from that Island you know what I
mean so it's not like in the middle of
yeah you see other Islands right so
there people live all around there yeah
you know it's not that isolated Jeffy
yard said uh Palm Beach island is east
of West Palm that's where the super
bougie folks live uh check out the
breakers great Sunday brunch buffet and
mamosas we'll have to go down there one
of these days I haven't been in the
Miami area for years and years and years
uh Brad says I thought you guys were
only on Friday well now you know the
main show Wednesday is the main show
Monday night we do a movie review and
Friday night we just do free yeah get
drunk and talk about whatever yeah which
is always fun but yeah so uh so yeah so
the story is about um about L Trump
there oh was that um from the 1990s
until
the 2000s when they apparently had a
falling out like about it was either
2004 or 2007 I'll get into it in a
minute um Trump and abste used to hang
out all the time them and Tom uh baric
or whatever his name was the real estate
investor dude they said they um well cuz
Epsy and Trump both had houses their
houses were only like a mile apart in
West Palm and they also both had houses
in New York city so he said they'd
always go the three of them would always
go clubbing together um they called them
the nightlife Musketeers uh so they were
going out all the time and
um they and also they said they were
like all they were like they're each
other's wingmen that was another thing
that somebody that knew them
said um one quote that gets thrown
around a lot that
um that Trump gave to New York Magazine
he said I've known Jeff for 15 years
terrific guy he's a lot of fun to be
with it's even said that he likes
beautiful women as much as I do and many
of them are on the younger side yeah I
remember this no doubt about it Jeffrey
enjoys his social life which again you
know now apparently in late 2004 they
had kind of a falling out over like a
property they both
wanted um I guess they were both after
the same house and I guess like Trump
ended up getting it and he sold it for a
bunch of and I guess that was enough for
them to have like a little [__] fight
or whatever and they didn't talk after
that I guess I also heard and I no one
could confirm this but in 2007 um
Epstein was reportedly banned from Mar
Lago because he was going after young
girls like too obviously I guess yeah um
but but nobody could confirm that cuz
like that it was in the complaint but
like the lawyer that he tried to confirm
that but nobody could confirm it so I
don't know if that's true the story I
heard is that the girl was a daughter of
one of Trump's friends
too and that you know she was like a
rich girl so she she turned right around
went to her dad yeah and then the dad
told Trump that dude's hitting on my
daughter she's like yeah it could be
like I said but that was the rumor that
he'd been B from there but I don't but
no one could confirm that it could it
could true Trump said he did he kicked
him out said he wasn't allowed back said
he wasn't a fan but no he said that per
publicly Trump did I know yeah I'm just
saying that there wasn't any paperwork
you just told him don't come back here
right yeah um yeah so there were there
is a video from
1992 um of trump and Epstein at marago
together the funny thing about that is
that showed up cuz it kind of you know
it kind of got popular so Borat like you
know the Borat movie the second one uh
subsequent movie film they put that
footage in that movie and then Borat
tries to
go give his teenage daughter as a gift
to Mike Pence like in that movie and I
and and Rudy J Giuliani I think like he
like like he's like I saw he's like I
saw that footage and it inspired me to
give my teenage daughter to you as a
gift so so yeah that was in the second
Ione um and actually Virginia said she
worked at Maraga right yeah she was like
a she worked at Cabana girl or something
like that like she she she was only 15
or 16 at the time so she was like she
got towels for people she was by the
pool or [__] like that yeah by the pool
she was like a towel pool girl right
something like that so she worked there
and did laundry and [__] and they found
out like Epstein apparently found or
somebody found out was it g gain SAR and
then found out that she wanted to be a
massage therapist like oh I'm glad you
said that like why don't you come over
this dud Mass that's how they got her
all of that kind of [__] yeah um and
then that started a sick little family
yeah Virginia was uh Danny's asking who
Virginia is uh Virginia Roberts um now I
think jefra is her last name now cuz
she's married but she was Roberts at the
time um she was uh she was one that was
abused by them over several years she's
the one in the photograph with prince
Andrew he's got arm around her way she's
real pretty blonde
yeah uh skinny real pretty blonde look
like a model and uh now she's aged you
know along with the other ones and most
these girls kind of aged into looking
like people's moms you know what I mean
yeah um so she's not
recognizable but as a kid you can see
why Jeff and gilain wanted her see
gilain was into the [__] too yeah and
actually when they they talked about
gilain like a bit like you know quite a
bit on the abene one but then they gave
like they had a whole thing about just
her like they did like a 2hour
documentary just about her that's also
called filthy rich but it's called
Filthy Rich gilay Maxwell according to
the girls that knew them the best and
were working with them that's if that's
what you want to put it they work
together I don't think I would put it
that way that's what they thought that's
what Gil but anyway um they said that
out of the two say gilain was worse they
said they didn't like gilain at all she
was evil and evidently Jeffrey kind of
didn't talk much and was just yeah yeah
he the weird thing about it is that a
lot of people on there that kind of knew
them yeah said that Epstein was kind of
an introvert yeah um like he didn't
really like to go out much like he
wasn't you know he'd go to parties and
[__] but you know he didn't he was just
kind of dress like a slob like he
couldn't be bothered but they said that
gilain was actually very uh socially
very Charming I mean she had grown up
you know she was the daughter of a very
big deal dude in the UK was like a big
newspaper publisher and stuff and um she
had grown up very wealthy she'd gone to
Oxford she was very educated she was
very charming and a lot of people said
that she facilitated a lot of the [__]
because she could get him in a lot of
higher Social Circles that maybe he
wouldn't have been able to get into
because like I said he was new money
yeah um so she could kind of get him in
more old money so like with the royal
family and all that kind of [__] cuz she
knew all those people yeah now I have I
haven't read any of like luid details
from the victims I can only pick up what
the victims will talk about and what
they're describing is
not okay basically what they describe is
is that the girl's kind of there under
false pretenses she realizes it's false
pretenses that she's actually there to
[__] she becomes kind of like deer in
the headlights as you would they're like
14 that's right the girl says no but
Jeff just ignores that just climbs on
now they they don't physically fight
because they're terrified of the dude
he's older and he's [__] super rich
and in some cases he's on an island with
you and there's no way off that Island
other than the this aircraft that their
boats and [__] that they come
on so they can't physically resist
they're too scared to they think he
might kill him you know which he very
well might have I mean we don't know
then he lets it go like nothing happened
and they do more and then he might grab
her again later on that night and
[__] jump on her I got the impression
they're just like a deer in the
headlights just bracing themselves you
know I got the he got the impression he
liked that yeah and I got the impression
too that he didn't really see them as
people no no like they were just
things um he didn't really Kea said they
were nothing they were garbage yeah she
said that um yeah a couple of the
victims said that that she said that
about them yeah well G call them slaves
he called called Virginia well you don't
think you're a slave you are a slave
yeah yeah so they were kind of uh into
that so I kind of feel like it's kind of
shitty because even though you have to
remember I don't know it I think it was
good in this case because you know
people did actually after all of this
time like after all of these stories
coming out they did actually believe
them like all the [__] up [__] they
were saying because all their stories
lined up you know what I mean these
girls didn't know each other and then
they all just came out and started
telling the same [__] story about
this dude yeah and um but I kind of feel
like people may maybe are like well why
didn't they say no or why didn't they
run away or why didn't they punch the
dude in the balls or something like that
it's just kind of like one you have to
remember these are kids I mean some of
them are like 14 years old um you know
they're in this house they don't like
it's surreal they don't they don't have
the mental they don't have the mental
capabilities to defend themselves I
can't if i against against basically an
exceptionally
intelligent Psychopathic bill iire who's
very well
connected like and he threatened some of
them outright I own the Palm Beach
Police Department like you can't do any
I'll [__] up your family like he about
could he had all those private
detectives and everything yeah yeah some
of after some of the stories coming out
like he would hire private detectives to
like stalk the cops stalk the cops stalk
the victims like they would just follow
them around everywhere so he could do it
he had the resources and I think that
these girls knew that and they were
[__] terrified of him so Jeffrey
wanted to ask you really you could say
no but he was going to do it anyway well
and some of the girls he just forcibly
raped them like and then afterwards he'd
say I'm going to help your sister out
with her education and [__] yeah I'm
going to pay for her to go to Europe go
go to Europe in a private school I'm I'm
know to her he goes over there and hits
her too yeah later on but some of the
[__] is just handing money out to him
and favors so now they can't say
anything so he's con he was constantly
keeping them all
trapped you know and then he take
sometimes take them on trips where
presidents and [__] would be their
ex-presidents and celebrities and [__]
he wouldn't do anything to them it just
you never knew what it was going to
happen yeah because it didn't happen
every time yeah so he kind of I mean
they he they were kind of like [__]
with the people and like I said you have
to think these were just like teenagers
and a lot of them were they had never
been out of this town they never had any
money they're from a Trader park right A
lot of them came from abusive
backgrounds or you know neglectful
backgrounds or had trouble in their past
and [__] like that so they were
vulnerable [__] prince Andrew show up
and Gan [__] grab Victoria and goes
oh by the way Virginia Virginia yeah you
grab Virginia and go by the way um what
you do for Jeff you're going to do for
him yeah like oh there's no choice they
just told tell you you're going to do
that for him and then it he's gone with
her yeah yeah and she's what like 16 17
something like that
underage yep so you know not not great
it's not a great situation and um I felt
really bad like for all for all of them
because the thing about I kind of tried
to put myself I don't remember what it
was like being 14 years old really
because that was a long [__] time ago
but I tried to put myself back in the
shoes of if I was 14 and I you know grew
up fairly poor like I said I wasn't you
know abused or I didn't have like drug
addict parents or anything you know my
parents were cool but I didn't have a
lot of money or anything if somebody had
come to me when I was 14 like at my
school and said hey we you know we can
make some money doing this doing this
easy [__] you know who's to say I might
have falling for that too and then like
when you get there you feel like oh [__]
like you can't well you see the massure
the massage thing is is
ingenious okay
because the girl knows that this is
something physical okay it it it's a
little bit sideways it doesn't she it's
a legit thing do get normal massages but
the water the water is not on full on
hot it's just it's just it's just warm
yeah so you go like well is it just my
imagination my my my dirty imagination
is thinking this is going to be
something sexual or you know what's the
point and she go maybe it's not going to
be that bad I just rub you know he's got
money and she goes down there and no
it's like the Trap gets sprung on her
and she oh I guess it was what I thought
it was or what I was afraid what I mean
it would start out what he would do and
a lot of the victims said this is
basically exactly what would happen like
with all these teenage girls he would
get them in there like and sometimes he
would have another one like hey I'll
give you another $200 if you bring a
friend tomorrow so and then the friend
would bring them and then would leave
them in the room yeah hold I got to go
so he would just be laying there cuz he
had a whole massage they had pictures
from the um when they raided his house
you know what I mean so they have like
video of like he had a whole massage
room with the steam [__] and everything
and so like he's into this massaging
thing and his houses were big but they
look like crap they did look like crap
that's what I thought too he could
decorate he he could he had [__] taste
he had the taste of a poor guy yeah they
looked really terrible well I mean like
I said he he was new money he didn't
grow up rich so maybe that's what it is
but yeah so he would have them come in
there and then the massage would start
out normal like he would just have like
he'd have he'd be laying on his um
stomach like there'd be a towel over him
like they'd be like there's lotions over
there just start with the feet in the
legs which like I said not that weird um
but then like the more you did it then
he would turn over
then he'd be like hey boner yeah better
you know do something about that oh [__]
he go and and then he could he could oh
and then he'd make the girls take their
clothes off and then a lot of times like
he'd like reach and like try to put his
fingers up in them and [__] like that
he's breaking them down yeah because he
wants to see like where their boundaries
are right well the thing is is that it
could be like well you came here to me
for work you knew what this was didn't
you yeah so now you're you're you're
applying pressure on her in the form of
guilt yeah
you we know you're a you're a hoe you're
here for the ho and then she gets sucked
into that and all of a sudden she goes I
guess I am yeah they're young they don't
have the defenses that's what I mean
it's just it's [__] horrible and like
I said they knew that they knew how
vulnerable those girls know you're here
with your hands and to make the make the
money you know oh oh you think it was
just the massage no that's euphemism so
it's a good H you should have known that
you should have known you know you're a
bad girl so you know just you know you
wanted to you know you wanted you know
you're here for the Money Ho they
absolutely knew so that's a very good
psychological hook he didn't say come
down here and paint my fence right come
here and wash my car for 200 no massage
yeah you know baby you didn't really
think that you could make $200 giving a
massage did you come on you knew better
than that you're not that stupid I
wouldn't even go to a rich dude's house
to wash his car for $200 he was lazy
about it man just sound like he just
would steamroll his way in here just he
just go grab her hands okay let's go
yeah and just climb off like a beast and
gilain was there to facilitate yeah gain
[__] laughing yeah jump on that yeah
yeah get on top of she said get on top
yeah and she's got him [__] she's on
top they would either have to like jerk
him off or or he or like she would stand
there naked and like massage him and he
try to like stick her fing stick his
fingers in her [__] and [__] like that
while he was jerking it and then they'd
have to like clean up the jizz yeah bet
you that girl's eyes are big around as
[__] saucers like a deer in the
Headlights
yeah well I mean like I said and the
thing about it is that these girls I
don't think they have any experience
with this kind of [__] so it's like they
they would go there they think they're
just going to do something make some
money and go home and then all of a
sudden it takes this sideways turn and
it's like surreal yeah for some of them
so it's like they don't really know
other ones though that other girl was
recruiting them right from high school
telling them what it was and they would
still she still some some of them did
know knew exactly what it was yeah like
what the expectation was because like I
said they they had this weird it was
funny cuz one of the attorneys like the
victim's attorneys was like he's like he
essentially had like a like a
molestation pyramid scheme going he's
like which I've never heard of ever but
um you know he would get like G gilain
obviously was would go out and procure
she was like on the Madam actually she
was like The Madam um but yeah they
would get high school girls that you
know they're like hey we'll give youle a
bounty yeah some of them were Middle
School we'll give you a bounty if you
bring your friends do you have any
pretty friends like you bring them with
you and we'll give them money too and
then we'll give you extra money yeah and
what's funny is like one of the main
ones that was doing that she was
traumatized by the whole thing but she's
like but you know what I probably could
find more girls to do this she she said
she feel guilty about it now but she was
only 14 or 15 well she was 14 or 15 and
she was probably like well I'm getting
$200 and I don't have to [__] this D
yeah I'm going make these girls do it
but she still feels bad about it yeah
and she she was honest with them she
told them what it was
and they would still do it so that's
what that's one she said she told them
what it was she said she told the but
that's that's the disturbing part to me
is that you can you can just tell an
underage girl what it is and she go okay
for the 200 unless they unless they
really don't think that's what's going
to happen or I don't know she said she
told him exactly what it was yeah like I
said I don't know if she really did but
that's what she told the cop she said
she told that now in in as as in the sex
infiltration or the the sex operation
that he was buing he actually wasn't
looking for that kind of girl
because he wanted they had to look real
sweet and innocent they had to look like
a real civilian they didn't have to they
didn't he didn't want them to come off
as as
hookerish because then the value would
go
away you know he hook him up with these
old dudes and what's funny is that these
dudes Allan dtz and
[__] who's that dude in the damn
[__] wheelchair see hay Stephen
Hawkins these these dudes are not
players they wouldn't they probably
wouldn't know a hot lay if it hit him in
the face so really these girls are
probably at their level in terms of
sexual experience as dudes they're not
Don
WS now the prince probably was he looked
like a real [__] Predator that dude
but the average one that supposedly ends
up in that these girls are mentioning is
a [__] simp and I mean a bad simp but
he
he's got some kind of a powerful
position and they're weak to this
because they didn't grw up getting
it Alan DWI says I never even had sex
with an underage girl when I was
underage that tells me he's damn he was
a virgin till he was probably 20 or 18
at least oh yeah he was probably a
virgin at 20 he probably didn't get any
any until he got out of
college how D with well don't shame
people for losing their virginity later
that's not cool but I mean he I don't it
was aedo well probably all right but I
don't think I mean he he very very vifly
denied because Virginia said that she
had sex with Alan ders with six times
five or six times that she remembered
yeah I believe her and yeah and J was on
the documentary and he look like talking
about other [__] like talking about the
defense and everything but he was just
he very categorically denied it but I I
don't know if I believe it or you have
to understand something I mean he wasn't
Epstein's lawyer lawyer directly because
he didn't he wasn't a member of the
Florida bar so he couldn't defend him in
Florida thing but he put together his
legal team alen dtz is a lawyer never
ever trust lawyers
no they don't they can't tell the truth
they don't know what truth is their
whole job is to CL that everybody is
like sketchy as [__] until they prove
other yeah lawyers are sketchy much
safer that way sketch as [__] if it's
not true they're gonna make it true by
by just painting the facts a certain way
they don't they don't believe in truth
they believe in power Zan said this is a
very particular type of Psychopathic guy
who does this if I had a billion dollars
i' build a compound to keep people out
yeah yeah same I why the [__] would you
waste it doing this [__] that if you got
caught you're going to prison it just
it's why okay we were talking about this
when we were watching the thing too
because we were talking about this whole
massage thing that he was into and he
was super into that well like I said you
know whether he was using that for other
purposes I don't know but he was
obviously got off on this this was like
a fetish for him and Tom was sitting
there going be like ma'am massages like
two or three times like his employees
said he got two or three massages a day
like from different girls and stuff so
that was obviously his thing which
seemed a little weird I was just like
wouldn't he get bored of it or something
but it was just like some kind of weird
fetish that he had but it always had to
be these girls that were super young and
seemed like they weren't super into it
like they didn't really want to do it
but I think that he got hit a chubby
from him making them do something they
didn't want to do they had to come off
and look like they were resisting he
wanted virgins some came cross is like a
virgin which is [__] up like I said if
you have all that money why would you
[__] wait you have to be a [__]
psychop I'm going to tell you because he
was
recruiting remember that's how he got
Virginia he was recruiting they were job
auditions him getting off was only part
of it he was looking for select ones he
was trying to put an A team together of
exact perfect types that that could help
him conquer Rich powerful men and most
of those girls from the trailer park
don't didn't have have What it Took only
a few did which you know what's her name
Victoria no uh Virginia Virginia was one
was one of
them he would home in on you if you had
any damn sexual abuse in your past boom
well yeah sexual predators go after
women that are vulnerable and the most
vulnerable are women that have had that
have been sexually abused before right
so that's usually what they Target and
they know what to look for yeah now the
Germans probably have a whole the old
Germans that were trying to perfect this
back in the
30s uh
through in know child abuse studies and
orphanages and [__] they could they
probably had an explanation it's
probably an easy way in to the kid and
you can use guilt or maybe they're using
the fact that a certain barrier has been
broken down so they can't resist quite
like okay a girl who had never had that
happened cuz it happened early on in her
in her in her life formative years so
she's more susceptible and more obedient
maybe if it's happened earli oh yeah big
time so it's something like that more
submissive because the thing about it is
that yeah and this is a generalization
obviously because everyone reacts to
things differently but
usually younger uh you know children
that are um you know exposed to sexual
abuse from a young age uh particular
girls will get to a point where after it
happens for a long time they start to
think they deserve it yeah um which is
why that a lot of sexual predators like
to Target those kinds of girls because
they're like oh well I can do whatever
to them and they'll just turn it back on
themselves oh well I'm a [__] person I'm
a [__] I'm this I'm that um you know so
you can do anything you want to them and
they'll just turn it back on themselves
that's very common I heard uh in one
program that was talking about sex
operations is that it might be another
uh an alternate way of looking at it is
that because the the
sexual attack happened early in their
formative years they can then uh kind of
normalize it go through it like oh well
that's just nothing that's just what
happens well that too because a lot of
them do kind of dissociate and it's like
a dissociate like sex they
compartmentalize yeah sex is nothing
it's just something I can do on command
and put on a good show in order to get a
reward so there's no real deeper
emotional significance to yeah that's
another aspect it's like breaking them
in very early to be kind of immune to
the effects because if you yeah if
you've gone through that kind of abuse a
lot like as a youngster you would just
kind of like almost become a multiple
yeah because you're just going to go
somewhere else you know it's like I'm
just going to check out so they for a
little while while this is going on or
they get into it but they're downplaying
the importance it has no emotional
impact yeah like I said different people
react to it different ways depending on
what the personality is but I think she
just I think he just wanted a
performer real pretty little performers
that were submissive that would do what
he said and get the information or get
the dirt on the guy and then he could
take them back because they they you
know he and gilain would [__] around
with their star students you know
regularly but they would also go scuba
diving and four-wheel then they'd have a
threesome and then they go do some other
[__] and well they said and sometimes it
would break them in like because I think
this what I don't think this was
Virginia I think this was the other
woman that was on there talking but
she's like sometimes you'd be like over
you they' just be doing normal [__] like
you know we just went out for dinner or
we went out for like a Excursion that
day or whatever just and it was regular
and then you'd go back to their house
and then abstein and gilain would start
making out or like [__] on the couch
and like making you watch and then
they're just kind of like hey like
trying to pull you into the [__] right
and you didn't really want to do it
right um and actually like uh Sarah
Ransom even said when she was on the
plane going to the island and she was
older I think she was 21 or
22 um she's like you know I was kind of
like half asleep on the plane and she's
like and I see Epstein like just [__]
this girl just like in front of
everybody yeah and she was like and I
thought that was super weird but
everyone else was like pretending it
wasn't happening yeah so she's like I
probably should have you know that
should have been a red flag but everyone
else was acting like
asleep I think she yeah so she's like it
was just like super weird she was just
[__] this girl on the plane yeah well
he was just making sure that everybody
knew that it was he was trying to
normalize it trying to make sure that
everybody on the plane knew that he was
gonna [__] if he wanted to yeah that's
what you were here
for it didn't mean anything to him
obiously it wasn't supposed to mean
anything to
you well and I feel like he's kind of
one of those people that seemed like he
could not
not I mean I think he was like a classic
sociopath like he couldn't put himself
in the shoes of anyone else so he just
thought well he didn't give a [__] about
it like I said people were just like
objects to be used so apparently that
was yeah you weren't supposed to care
about it either because obviously that's
okay with me so it's okay with everyone
else yeah you know cuz I'm the only
person that matters like I said I wasn't
there I didn't talk to the guy I just
going that's the impression that I got
by what the girls were saying yeah and
like from interviews I've seen with him
and stuff that's the impression and
surprisingly from everything I heard the
the the the sex sounded what we vanilla
just regular it's just the fact that
he's basically forcing it on somebody
some chick who's just like a deer in the
headlights yeah that was his and they're
underage that's other thing but yeah
yeah Hiers it's so gross it is this
whole story is [__] gross um yeah
yeah and Mike said The more I hear about
this the more sick it gets oh just wait
uh it gets worse it gets worse I haven't
got into the [__] yet really we were
just talking about like the early [__]
yeah um Zach says what I want to know is
where did all this [__] come from the
the massage thing that it became a
fetish for this guy yeah it's like look
everybody has I don't think everybody
has fetishes but everybody has [__] that
they like they have preferences okay
like I fetish is a particular thing um
but everybody has preferences about [__]
they like would I go out of my way as
much as this dude did like for a [__]
F no [__] way no [__] way it just
seems to me and Virginia said this too
um not on the documentary but she said
it in another interview that I
read that
all that Epstein and gilain they were
just like sex obsessed you know what I
mean it's like all they thought about um
all pretty much and when they actually
when they raided their house they said
it's just like even though there was
nothing illegal at first until they dug
around a little bit but they said it was
still pretty creepy and weird because
you go in there and there's just like
every everywhere there's just like nude
photos like all the artwork was nudes
all the you know what I mean they said
it's like not illegal but they just
thought it was kind of strange so they
were just like really really sex
obsessed clearly if you're getting
sexual massages like three times a
day that's a lot that's a lot hold on I
want to say something to Zach Zack I
don't think the massage was the
fetish the power was the fetish the
power play over the chick I think that's
what it was and that was just his
favorite way of like
right the the the the the um the massage
ad was a
ploy that's that's still that was used
even that was always used like on
Craigslist that's how a that's how a
girl would find clients okay it's all
euphemism but what he's doing is he's
putting out a very gray advertisement
$200 for massage come to my house that's
like the spider calling in the
fly it's a
hook any girl that would [__] take
that offer is a girl that's willing to
touch an old a young girl willing to
touch an older man for
money you push her a little
bit little bit further you're already
you knew what it h you knew what it was
you answered you going to you going to
mess with older guys for money you know
what this is baby exactly and he got so
good at he didn't say anything about it
he it might even not that he was like
super into massage he just liked that
because it was like an in because like I
said Mass like people do get massages
and that's not weird but the fact that
it was still physical and you could turn
it into something else really easily
yeah and it was deniable too and it was
deniable if she showed up and he didn't
like he he got a bad feeling she didn't
trust it like this might be a this is a
cop he could say okay okay massage is
over yeah cuz I mean evidently I don't
know if this is the case but the
impression that I got was that maybe
some people showed up and they just gave
him a massage and left and that was the
end of it yeah probably that happened
quite a bit he probably looked at her
and goes now I can't use her cuz he's
using it as a recruitment tool he's
trying to get him on the island yeah cuz
girls would bring other girls said and
I'm sure he wasn't into all of them well
maybe he was he using this as a as a
scam to get his hands on the best girls
he possibly can so he could take him to
this island yeah so that was more like a
job interview the massage was a job
interview in his mind and it's um he's
running 3 day at least which is crazy
thousands of girls local right how much
viagro is this [__] on that's I was
wondering I was going this [__]
here I I was wondering that I didn't say
it out loud I know you were wondering it
though because I know how you I'm like
yeah I'm like how the [__] is dude
keeping up with this [__] cuz [__] I I
could be on test and steroids and
[__] Viagra and I I could I could do
that maybe once maybe twice a day but
that would get bored that would get
bored yeah that's what I mean that's
that same thing over and over again yeah
even even that's what I mean that's even
if it's a different little
chick you go n I'm not in a mood come
back tomorrow I mean you would think you
would think yeah cuz I was just kind of
like everybody
is I mean everybody has like mood where
some days you're just like I don't
really feel it or I feel fat or ugly
today or something like that you know
what I mean I I think it was a mi a
mixture of sex addition sex add yeah
that's what High Desert said sounds like
he was a sex addict yeah I think a
mixure of SE sex addiction and and and
um ambition
he wanted to put together a team of
really good girls so he could get lots
of money and lots of power either for
himself or whatever whoever it was he
was working
for one of those girls thought that
there was a whole ring of
them he been an employee it's possible
or something like Spectre some [__] like
that Dan said what dirt did he get is
anyone in jail because they were
associated with this guy no no they got
the videos but they never really
released the videos but evidently they
got the videos off that
James Holmes said oh I wanted to bring
this up this was something they brought
up in the Netflix documentary uh I
wonder if he was embarrassed by his
egg-shaped dongle we were
laughing there's a there's in the in the
they got video one of his interviews are
his depositions yeah um the victim's
attorney yeah was trying to get him
enraged get him mad Yeah so basically
the first question that he asked um is
it true that you have egg-shaped penis
like I don't know if that's exactly what
he said but it was along those lines
Jeff [__] was great in that though
he's like
what he's like I'm sorry one of the
victims said that like you know it was
big at the bottom and small at the top
and she compared it to an egg that's not
my words that's her words he was trying
he was deliberately trying to cuz he
knew that um that Epstein was a
narcissist and he so he was trying to
like rattle him and get him angry pissed
which kind of worked kind of worked he
knew what it was though he he knew that
it was a a technique to make you mad he
was kind of laughing though he's like
these [__] I EG shaped he's
like like yeah that seems really weird
but I know what I know what they're
talking I don't know if he has an ex sh
I think he took the mic off and [__]
stood up and walked away yeah he had a
little bit of a man he like you're
[__] full of [__] I had that
although my reaction to that question
and [__] este's reaction we had the
same reaction at the same time we're
like what the [__] is
this and I honestly I I don't actually
know if anybody had described his penis
as egg shaped egg shaped or if the
attorney was just saying that to try to
get him upset like he was trying to like
make him angry so he would maybe say
something that he wouldn't could have
normally say could have been that the so
I don't know if somebody said that could
have been that one of his girls kind of
Drew it and he goes and then he [__]
around and [__] made it exaggerated
it to be like a egg Humpty Dumpty had a
great fall I'm going ask him [__] if
he's got an egg
shape I kind of love that that attorney
that attorney dude I kind of love that
dude like he seemed like a cool dude and
he was just like he after they showed
that clip the attorney dude that had
been asking that question he's like was
I trying to piss him off yeah you know
what I mean and I was like that dude's
awesome so yeah I liked him a lot but
well like I said he was cool because he
represented a bunch of the victims and
he hung in there for more than a decade
really I mean he was really trying to
get this [__] dude I think by by
listening to [__] by seeing him and
seeing what he
did estein was high IQ probably 130 at
least yeah they said he was super smart
especially like mathematically he
skipped two grades in his which like I
said a lot of people 130 to about 140 I
don't think he was genius level you know
but uh he but he was exceptional he was
so he knew that that dude was [__]
with him yeah it was [__] hilarious
it was very funny it was hilarious he
thought it was hilarious too but he but
he got pissed too he like these
[__] are [__] trying that
[__] I don't even know why they
bothered interviewing him because he's
just like I'd like to answer that
question but according like my attorneys
say that I should take the Fifth
Amendment blah blah so he didn't really
answer anything um Zach said do you
think Epstein himself may have been
abused as a kid I wouldn't be shocked
they did ask him that question
um during his deposition and he would
not answer yeah he wouldn't did he
wouldn't answer so it makes me think he
probably was um yeah I don't know but I
guarantee he [__] that rich dude to
get that money I kind of suspect he
probably did too well because the thing
about it is that that other dude that
knew Wexner said Wexner like adored him
yeah and like I said even back then
which was the 80s or the 90s or whatever
it was in New York City everyone called
him the boyfriend so people thought [__]
was going on back then yeah that he was
[__] that dude that's how he was like
manipulating him out of his money estein
by the time he was middle-aged you know
when you see when you got famous he
looked like a [__] troll but if you
saw him when he was young he was a
good-looking guy he was young so it
doesn't surprise me if if he [__] we
Wexner Wexner probably thought he was a
dream
boat yeah good-looking Jewish guy and
like I said you know Wexner might have
been maybe he was
closeted um you know and he didn't want
anybody to find out that that was going
on um you know there could have been a
lot of things that I think was holding
over him I think he just stole his money
and well he did steal his money I think
listen I think listen to what I'm saying
because I heard what Wexner said he just
said he just said I you know I shouldn't
have trusted a sick individual like that
I think what it was is that [__]
estein put charm on him all right and
was in a in a fake relationship with him
for many years until he could get into
the position of trust where he could
steal the money and then he dumped him
but I think wexer loved him and didn't
want to [__] go after him that's what
I think it was yeah because the thing
about it is that allegedly yeah um
Epstein stole a bunch of money from him
and Wexner didn't file a complaint yeah
yeah and how much did they say it was it
was 4 million I think when I no it was I
thought it was 45 million 45 million it
was a lot yeah but that guy had more
money than that I mean he probably
didn't even notice that be like stealing
a couple Grand from me sure you know
what I mean and I think he loved
him that's what he meant well one of the
other dudes that knew him kind of said
that like not in those words but he kind
of implied that I think he loved him and
didn't want didn't want him to go to get
in trouble and I think he was pissed off
that he he his heart was broken I think
why he was calling him sick is because
you know he played with my emotions you
know mean told me he Lov me he didn't
love me you know he took my [__] as sick
[__] you know what I mean and
and I think I think it's what happened I
mean there had to be something going on
there for sure oh only F like I said
that's that's sex operative [__] and
like I said that dude would not have
just GI he gave Epstein power of
attorney over all of his [__] this dude
was like a billionaire yeah he loved him
he owned Victoria Secret he owned the
limited he had all the money y why would
you give somebody power of attorney he
could like Epstein could do anything he
wanted he probably stole all kind of
money from that dude just because that
dude was rich didn't mean that he didn't
need love yeah yeah he thought he found
it yeah well I mean they they pretty
much know that he did steal a bunch of
money from that dude but the dude didn't
press any charges women have done the
same thing to dudes and the dudes didn't
go after him you know I mean it happens
all the
time D said it just goes to show if you
want to be rich and have power you have
to be a psychopath and a sexual deviant
you can't be nor yeah pretty much yeah
yeah because the thing I mean not just
to be like regular ass rich but to be
like super super rich yeah you kind of
have to be because you have to do stuff
that's not legit that's not to crush you
have to crush opponents and those
opponents are other businesses employing
thousands of people anybody that has
that much money is just prob I mean
99.999% of the they're just a terrible
person a good person doesn't ever
usually get that risk yeah and a lot of
these big [__] firms that these guys
were coming up in were were were scams
yeah well like I said where he made most
of his like initial money that was all
like that hedge fund [__] that was
all that was a Ponzi scheme that's where
he made his initial 500 million or
whatever yeah and that's not the only
scam the best scams are going to be
enshrouded and protected in in in laws
that protect them so I get man
I I guarantee you the [__] medical
industry is [__] gonna have a lot of
element of scam in it and some of that's
come to light like that company that
Tred to scam people on the damn blood
test machine the DNA machine it turned
out that I wanted to do a show about her
that whole thing was a scam imagine
Elizabeth holes is that imagine a lot of
I wanted to do a show about that imagine
a lot of them uh of the American Medical
system is a scam in terms of like
especially like the the drug companies
they're probably well everybody trying
to get money that's yeah they're
probably pretty by any means possible
yeah there's probably a lot of
corruption in that which I get that but
and then I I know there's a lot of it in
the military industrial complex making
military equipment there's a lot of scam
in that
too Russia's kicking ass with little
[__] qu copters that are under $1,000
they can destroy a million dollar tank
easy to fly and it's like something like
a toy what it looks like our military
industrial complex would never make
anything like that it's too cheap they
would have to want to make something
that did that but a million dollars each
and huge contracts and repair repair
contracts maintenance contracts all
kinds of [__] that they would want for
that they would never want a cheap
Solution that's just an example I
imagine a lot of our Industries are
scams
Mrs Evans art party said loving this
episode and your insights guys thank you
very much we thought this would be a
very popular episode yeah yeah it's an
interesting topic yeah so we haven't
even really got into like the horrible
[__] like we've kind of touched on it
but Epstein was apparently doing this
[__] like all through probably the 80s
and the 90s but nobody really knew what
was going on until like the mid
2000s like I said um there were two
girls that had one kind of older girl
and her younger sister who was a minor
uh they had reported him to the FBI in
1996 but nobody really did anything
because at that point you know there
weren't any other complaints and there
might have been other reasons as well
but in
2005 uh a woman called uh the Palm Beach
Police
Department and she had a 14-year-old
stepdaughter and this stepdaughter
I guess she had gotten into like a fight
at school or something like that and
they found
$300 cash in her purse and she wouldn't
tell them where she got it from now
later on she actually admitted that she
had got the $300 from going to this old
guy's house and giving him a massage
right um
so she said later like because the thing
about so the mom called the cops the
Stepmom she called the cops and they
said okay well I think that at this
point cuz didn't they say this on the
documentary that at this point they'd
even started being like thought
something a little bit fishy was going
cuz Palm Beach is kind of a small you
know it's an island so there's not that
many and you know people talk and they
had thought there's like well man
there's like a lot of young girls like
different girls like going in and out
out of that house so there was like kind
of rumors about it but nobody really
knew much about it so the mom calls and
says yeah my 14-year-old daughter said
she got cash from like massaging this
middle-aged dude on Palm Beach and when
she got there she said she was just
gonna go give him a massage but when she
got there she had to take all her
clothes off and you know like some bad
[__] happen so at this point um the cops
are kind of like okay well she's a minor
obviously so they're going to
investigate that so they did more than a
year of like an undercover investigation
like I said they had kind of cars they
were watching people come and go and
like interview people and stuff like
that now while all this was going on
they got a lot of evidence that they
thought something sketchy was going on
that there was miners going in and out
of there um because of her story and she
was saying you know all the all these
girls in school were like saying they
were going there and stuff so the police
chief at the time whose name was Michael
Ryder he's just like man we really need
to do something about this and he went
to the St State prosecutor at the time
whose name was Barry kers
kerser and he said he was going to look
into it but then they didn't really do
much about
it so fair play to the police chief he's
just like all right [__] this I'm going
to over their heads so he goes to the
FBI because he's like we need to do
something this is miners you know what I
mean now so the FBI gets involved in
2005 2006
um now as I said they had previously had
a report which they did actually dig up
after a while like from a couple of
girls that from 1996 who had reported
them to the FBI back then but this was
kind of when they uh found that
out so as they conducted this
investigation they were kind of doing uh
you know the local police were doing an
investigation the FBI was doing an
investigation they found out that
Epstein was doing this with a lot of
girls that he was basically like paying
all these girls to you know essentially
come over and massage him quote unquote
but then he would end up raping them
making him you know jerk them off jerk
him off um or making them watch while he
was jerking himself off like it just
[__] like that uh gilain was also
implicated in a lot of this sometimes
she would molest the girls as well or
kind of facilitate the the
[__] so they ended up getting uh
initially they had five victims and 17
other people that knew [__] about it um
they also kind of uh staked out they
were like putting him under surveillance
they went through his trash um they
found [__] that belonged to some of the
victims like I think they found like a
report card or something like that from
one of the victims like in his garbage
and [__] like that so they knew that
they had been there and all of the girls
that came in and said about it all of
their
stories you know kind of corroborated
each other like they described the
inside of the house correctly um all of
their stories kind of matched up like
the [__] that happened to them and stuff
like that so they did kind of believe
them at first now the youngest girl uh
that was involved was 14 most of them
under
16 um so they eventually got enough
evidence to execute a search warrant at
um Epstein's
house now they did about this on the
documentary they kind of you know they
showed some of the footage uh from the
search now when they first went in there
they found I believe a couple of hidden
cameras they found a bunch of photos uh
in the house and some of the photos were
of the girls that they had interviewed
that were
minors
now evidently Epstein even though they
thought that he didn't know that he was
being investigated someone must have
tipped him off or he must have figured
it out because most of the real bad [__]
they think was gone um they went in his
office for example and one of the
computers was missing like the guy said
he's like well there were all of these
cords there like there had been a
computer there but the computer was not
there and I believe it was later
discovered that one of their assistants
had like gotten rid of it like so he
must have like called and said hey get
rid of that one computer cuz that was
probably the one that had all the you
know Kitty prawns on it so he's like get
rid of that I mean they did find it some
later but not at this point so the cops
go in there and they said they didn't
find anything super super incriminating
but they did say it was kind of weird
because like I said there was just like
[__] nude photographs everywhere some
of the people in the photographs might
have been miners [__] like that they
also found uh a receipt from Amazon this
is what you were talking about before
uh where he had ordered a bunch of books
about
SNM so the books that he ordered were
called sm101 a realistic introduction
there was one called slave craft road
maps for erotic servitude principles
skills and tools and training uh and
there was one called with with Miss ABY
that was that uh and then there was also
a workbook for erotic slaves and their
owners so this is the kind of books that
he was uh
reading so as we mentioned uh several of
his
employees said that he would get three
massages a day now initially the FBI
report had
34 people that were miners that were
willing to give testimony that this [__]
had happened to them uh later six more
came to light so they had 40 initially
like for that now in this portion and
they did ask Epstein about this in the
in the deposition because you can see it
in the
documentary one of the um
allegations was that on his birthday I
think Victoria said this too on his
birthday they flew
in uh a set of triplets that were 12
years old from France especially so that
he could abuse them and then they flew
them back the next day yeah it's funny
she said she said that he had bought
them yeah I guess to keep but he sent
them back so he said he bought them from
their or he just rented them he bought
them from their family which is [__]
up was what was said but yeah so that
was I mean obviously triplets or twins
triplets okay yeah obviously he denied
this but that was one of the things that
was alleged uh you know allegedly um it
was also alleged that he had bought
girls from several other countries
particularly in South America uh and
former Soviet countries yeah and also he
one of his main ons I think was
Ukrainian yeah she came out of I think
she was Ukrainian she's that vet the one
or one that was did yeah she was one of
the procurers evidently but she was also
a minor at the time I yeah EV evidently
she he basically owned her yeah he
bought her and she lived somewhere he
kept her somewhere but you know they
were basically sex slaves is what they
were I mean there's really no way around
it right but you know she also had
access to his Empire though she said she
would she' recruit like crazy she just
saw it as her job who knows what
happened to her yeah I don't know what
ended up ever ended up happening because
once he died I imagine all his money
vanished she was on her own yeah we'll
talk about off somebody else yeah what
else are you gonna do now somebody's
asking about Jeff Jeffrey
Epstein's ethnic group and whether he
had anything to do with the tunnels down
there I got hold on I got I'm GNA get
another drink to yeah okay that's some
funny [__] you asked that friend of mine
Rob
levenson we were talking about the
tunnels down there in New York coming
out of the synagogue he wants to make a
movie he's a he's a Jewish guy he wants
to make a movie about him but the thing
is is that we don't have all the
information I think I want to do a show
on that synagogue but all the
information is not there
yet I think what it was based on the
videos that I've seen it looked like it
was two factions inside that
synagogue and the faction of the younger
guys started to make basically bunkers
and tunnels that would go in and out of
that
synagogue and then the older ones
evidently told the
cops and they they tore the place open
and filled those tunnels up with
cement I think what it was is that they
were well
one what's happening in Israel right now
between Hamas they're probably worried
about that there's probably Hamas
supporters inside of New York so I think
they wanted a way to get in and out of
the [__]
tunnels uh so they could defend the
mosque if it came under
attack um
but it looked like but you know thing
that mitigates that it looks like it
took a while to dig those
tunnels maybe years of work so that
might predate the war that Israel's in
right now it might had something to do
with like BLM riots maybe they were
afraid of BLM riots that they saw and
they thought that somebody would tear
the mosque down so it looks like they
were trying to fortify the mosque turned
into like a not a mosque what
synagogue and uh looked like they were
trying to turn the synagogue into into a
place that you could defend and or hide
in it till whatever Riot was over that
was our idea and Rob uh was kind of
agreeing with me like yeah that must be
what it
is
now both Jeff and gilain were
Jewish there what's her name
um that wasn't like a central part of
what was happening here but what was
that girl Victoria is that her name or
Virginia Virginia irginia yeah like the
state yeah yeah just like the state
Virginia did say that they would [__]
get kind of ethnic with her un certain
you can see interviews with her it's not
mentioned in the in the in the uh
Netflix
program but they were in an abusive
relationship and I think they've just
[__] with her when they could well
they're going to use anything that weak
anything as a weakness that they could
get on you they were saying you know
you're a nobody you know
so yeah there was an ethnic angle to it
but that wasn't the central part of it
the central part of it was is they were
trying to get dirt on real Rich dudes
that's what they were trying to do I
think that was just kind of their whole
thing yeah and they would use whatever
means me necessary and
Gan and
estein you can profile them out into
being the kind of person you would need
to be sex operative I think they were
sex
operatives Epstein maybe a self-styled
one I think G Lane learned it from her
dad and this was a business that they
were
running selling selling influence and
information yeah and these girls were
the hook the bait and the
hook that's what I think it was yeah now
did they work for a foreign did they
work for for for for the Mad do they
work for CIA they might have work they
might have worked for anybody who'd pay
them that's kind of what I'm thinking
kind yeah I don't even know if they like
did they I don't know but it just kind
of seemed like they had the information
so they would probably just sell it to
whoever to anybody sure they uh and if
somebody if any intelligence group came
to them and needed help can you get this
done for us he if the price was right he
probably do it or get the information
you know what really freaks me out about
stories like this cuz this isn't the
only story like this this probably is
the best known one but it kills me that
so many dudes particularly in positions
of Power are willing
to put their ass on the line like just
just to get like have sex with a
12-year-old like why like you would
think that if you had all this money and
power and like all these eyes on you and
[__] like that you'd be like yeah no
thanks um even if you wanted to do that
you'd be like that's really dumb for me
to do that cuz I'm going to get in big
[__] in trouble could be several
things could be like I said before just
stupid they do that for like gang
initiation they do it so they can be
recorded doing it so they can join the
team you're giving the team dirt and
power over you same way when you join
like a criminal gang you might have to
kill somebody in a robbery to join the
gang like [__] like that now now they'll
trust you because they know you killed
somebody yeah cuz they have dirt on you
sure because they have dirt on you it
might be that it might be
um the guy has a lot of
money but maybe he's uh a PDF file okay
and this is uh I mean I guess we don't
have to worry about using eism now
because this is about of
time although I do think it's funny like
calling them so he's got high class
people around him of his of his caliber
sourcing his materials for him and he
can get involved and yeah they get dirt
on him now now they control
him another thing it could be is it
could be that the dude is not a PDF file
he's just a [__] horn
dog and
uh he kind of likes it because it's
[__] not legal that it's uh it's a
cake you know it's a taboo and so he's
going to go for it that way because if
you have a [__] ton of money and you're
so used to getting instant service you
know from employees and yeah I can hire
any kind of porn I hire 20 of them we're
have this big that probably get old
after a while because these are all
things that you can have maybe you start
wanting things you can't
have yeah I could see how that would
happen well like I said it's just kind
of like it's the same pathology as
serial killers it's like they start out
with some stuff and then it's like they
have to keep escalating and escalating
because it doesn't do it for them
anymore right too easy so it's a might
be a living on the edge type of
thrill yeah which I I don't know I just
I mean I get it but I kind of feel like
especially if I was in a position of
power everybody's looking at me and at
all this money and stuff like that I
would be really careful about not doing
anything that would be seen as I mean
you know maybe that's just me those
dudes don't have a lot of game they
don't have and they don't have street
game because they never live like normal
people cuz I would kind of be like yeah
I don't want anybody seeing this [__]
[__] so it's like I'm not going to do it
I think the way they would it is is like
oh I guess these are the Forbidden
fruits that rich guys like me can can
partake in no one else can have these
but we can have them my friends are
doing it yeah so you know he we're
getting away we're getting away with
some [__] you know what I mean which
yeah that's that's adorable like that
all of these children are being
exploited just for these [__] dudes
well you're dealing with a dude that
never really kind of had to grow up now
did he I guess not you know well yeah
that's exactly Sil SP in his mouth from
[__] Cradle to grave yeah they just
had everything given to him everything
given J so it might be that and they're
used to like you said they're just used
to getting whatever they want right so
they want something that they can't have
and they can get away with anything too
yeah like CU you know you all everybody
knows the story about like some rich
dude that like you know killed somebody
in vehicular manslaughters because he
was drunk or some [__] like that and his
daddy got him out of it you Howard
Hughes did that yeah that's what I mean
it happens a lot it happens a lot yeah
if you have money you can get out of
anything yeah murder it doesn't matter
so so this might be a Big
Thrill yeah because like you said said
it's it's a taboo I mean it's still it's
probably the taboo yeah um well in the
west there are other countries where
this is well yeah yeah I'm just I'm
talking about like from our point of
view yeah you know because you know
obviously other [__] you know back in
the old days uh when other [__] was you
know just [__] that's normal now like
you know being gay or whatever was not
acceptable then that was something you
could blackmail somebody with but
nowadays you can't do that anymore
because you know who the [__] cares
about that everybody adults the Germans
became evidently the Germans
intelligence became good at this during
the vinmar Republic era
when Germany was [__] it was it was
totally collapsed it was at the it was
at the edge of [__] the abyss and
prostitution was
rampant
um there there were especially like in
the Berlin er er era and they already
had kind of Germany already went through
kind of like a sexual Revolution being
gay was not blackmail on anybody even
with the uh the Nazis Ernest Rome who
was leader of the saaa who brought
Hitler to power was openly gay and a
predatory leather daddy all right and he
was friends with uh Hitler and U most
people at the time thought that he and
Hitler were in a relationship most
people thought Hitler was was bisexual
all this stuff kind of left out of the
history books today because the LGBT
community oh they don't want to adopt
him oh oh no he wasn't one of us well
nobody wants to [__] claim Hitler
come on right the white the white people
don't want him either we also don't want
him but mustache man mustache man and
the other guys you know what I mean he
they they kind of had they were more SE
what you call jit or
fluid but uh so you couldn't use in the
1930s gayness as any kind of dirt on
somebody only only K children so that's
when they started Focus well like I said
that's kind of the last taboo because
that's probably always going to be well
hi Pokey I didn't even know you were
under there so what they're kind of what
they would do is that they had access to
uh excess people or disposable people is
what the uh the Germans would call it
people that technically could probably
be sent to a concentration
camp from a from a say an orphanage well
why do that why not turn some of these
orphans into sex operatives which
evidently is what they did
they learned how to do it through trauma
based mind control which is like
pavlovian
conditioning to force them into a
multiple personality disorders and some
of the personalities were sexual and
some of them were more murderous so not
only were they a sex operative they were
also an assassin and you're talking
about you know somebody who's between
the age of like seven and maybe
12 that takes us some inhuman
[__] well that was the right
Bunch actually the Germans at that time
they were the right kind of people to
experiment with with that kind of
Technology you're going to take a kid
and just abuse it to turn it into a
multiple personality
disorder assassin I mean you can't be
human really well under their laws with
youth in Asia anybody who's living a
life not worth living could be
euthanized and that usually meant sent
to a concentration camp any any enemy
political enemy who was disloyal to the
part party could be euthanized they were
living a life that wasn't work yes I
know that all that [__] was done legally
under German law well doing that to a
kid well instead of euthanizing it let's
turn it into something we can use that's
what they're that's yeah that's some
weird [__] man inhuman [__] like I said
it's inhuman because you're treating
other humans as though they're not human
they're just
objects which okay well that's kind of
the textbook definition of Joseph gathy
Joseph Goble uh said um uh how can you
know and he was like the head of the
really he was the one that really
invented a lot a lot of the stuff that
you know of as as that party they said
um how could you do these kind of things
kill living how can you kill living
people like that or you know and he goes
and he goes uh well everything lives he
goes think about it maggots live and you
can stomp a maggot I can't even do that
yeah yeah being alive is nothing even
maggots live that was that was the that
was the philosophy not on purpose yeah
go to rest the only thing I can kill is
a cockroach cuz [__] cockroaches but
other than that I just I can't kill
anything not even a bug other than
cockroaches cuz [__]
cockes High Desert said that asteroid
can't hit us fast enough I I kind of
think that too but the thing about it is
that the reason this is kind of try how
I try to make myself feel better is that
the reason that we talk about these
[__] is
because they're largely outliers I think
most people you don't hear anything
about most people because most people
are fine I'm not just saying most people
are cool or good or nothing like that
I'm just saying most people are
inoffensive is is what I'm saying I mean
most people are not going to do [__]
like this um so I think that's kind of
why people have you know a a fascination
with them why I have a fascination with
them because you don't see it that often
thankfully like I said I think most
people I don't think most people are
necessarily good or bad I just think
most people are just like average
they're just like inoffensive they're
not going to do anything
this egregious I guess you know I want a
word stronger than that but I can't
really think of it right now but you
know what I mean it's just you know it
there aren't that many people like this
in the world probably more than we know
of but it's still a minority I don't
think most people would do this kind of
[__] although I will say that if you
gave an average person this much money
and
power I don't know what percentage I
want to throw out
there 85% of them would probably do some
[__] like this maybe not as bad as this
but I think probably most people would
do this if they were given this level of
money and power which most people do not
have I like to think I would not do that
but
I don't know I I don't think I would I I
think I'm too the way I am to like do
anything like that but it's just it's
unusual that's why you hear about
it so all right so after these initial
complaints so the Palm Beach Police
raided his house in 2006 like I said um
you know they found some weird [__] but
some of the [__] had clearly been
removed so somebody had like tipped him
off but they did find some hidden
cameras in his house um they also
discovered later uh cuz this was his
Palm Beach house they also discovered
later that his house in New York also
had a whole video surveillance system
that pretty much filmed everybody
everywhere at all times like even in the
bathroom and everything like that so
they were watching everybody and filming
it um and they found out later too that
on the island um pretty much everything
was filmed there also uh and like I said
they were doing that for blackmail
purposes um they found like I said and
this is jumping ahead some but during
the second raid on his house after his
2019 arrest they found Stacks and stacks
of um you know like DVDs that he had
recorded of various underage girls with
various people that they had recorded
and he kept all of it in a safe yeah and
I bet you you'll never find those
probably all destroyed yeah I don't know
what they did with them like they took
them as evidence but I don't know what
they did them cuz they did find him in
the safe it's all their bosses in those
vide tapes so they they're going to be
destroyed um yeah
so so after all of this so the cops um
they basically want to charge
Epstein with initially four counts of
unlawful sex with miners one count of
sexual abuse I guess that was all they
could prove at the time even though like
I said that I think at the time they had
34 people coming forward but I don't
know if they had enough evidence to uh
back all that up so they had enough
obviously so they arrested him in Late
July of
2006 now the charges initially were
procuring a minor for prostitution and
solicitation of a
prostitute so he gets in there they only
gave him $33,000 bond which of course he
paid because he's a [__] billionaire
allegedly um they had like a grand jury
which was kind of
unusual but in front of the grand jury
they only had two victims that came
forward to give evidence and the jury
only came out with like one charge of
felony solicitation of
prostitution Epstein pleaded not
guilty um and that was pretty much as
far as that went now as I mentioned
before there was this woman Maria farmer
now she was an artist and she had
reported Epstein to the FBI back in
1996 now she said that Epstein had
showed
her uh all of the hidden cameras in her
in his New York house and said that he
was filming everybody like I said even
in the bathrooms and everything so that
kind of freaked her out a little bit and
there were also as we mentioned before
like allegations that uh Epstein was
lending girls out to various people uh
to get blackmail information or for
favors or whatever and he had all these
compact discs DVDs like in his safe and
he would write on them either he or
gilain would write on them um you know
young whatever the girl's name was plus
whoever the big deal person was yeah and
he yeah and they were all in the safe
like I said they found them all in there
when they raided his ship this is
Epstein's main job this is why he's
doing all this [__] out of Florida and
uh having three girls meet him a day
that it's it's to recruit for this
operation this is where the [__]
money is the money and the
power is it the purpose of it
all yeah I mean like I said I think he
got off on it it was a fetish but not
saying that but for real he was doing
all this for money oh don't for one
second think he wasn't having fun he
enjoyed his work yeah and the kind of
guy you need to assemble an army like
this is a dude that's into it so yeah
hell yeah he was super into it but yeah
he was doing it as to make money too
like for blackmail purposes money and
power cuz he recorded all of that [__]
power is worth more than money all of it
power is worth a lot more than
money money can't buy you out of trouble
power
can that's why they had to silence him
or at least or get him out of
there he He Knew Too
Much yeah had too much dirt yeah I mean
we get we're only in 2006 dude we have
like so much stuff left to cover
um okay July 2006 uh the FBI starts an
investigation of their own like a
parallel investigation uh they had a
name for it it was called operation leap
here I don't know why they called it
that but
whatever um from what they could glean
they actually got a 53 page
indictment which they then presented to
uh the then us attorney for the southern
district of Florida who was Alexander
aosta
now what happened with that it's kind of
sad because all the lawyers and stuff
like that for the victims they were like
holy [__] it's like we have 53 pages of
the [__] we have all of this evidence
like they had a [__] ton of stuff
they're like this guy is going away
forever they were like super happy about
it but then um so it goes to
aosta
and he got a plea deal and when I say he
got a plea deal he got like the best
plea deal in the history of plea deals
basically um they told him if you serve
18 months in jail and as we'll see it
wasn't even it was like a [__] cushy
18 months it wasn't even 18 months it
was like 13 months it ended up being but
it's just kind of like if you plead
guilty to this one [__] charge like
that's not even anything to do with
minors really um you plead guilty to
that
um then it'll be fine you will get
immunity like all of your conspirators
and Co like conspirators and
co-conspirators like named and
unnamed will have like
immunity forever like essentially which
several people in the Netflix
documentary like that had been in law
enforcement for decades we're like I
have never seen anything like this ever
this is the craziest [__] thing I've
ever seen um um never have I ever seen a
plea deal where everybody's like even
people we don't even know were your
conspirators they're also immune like in
perpetuity they're like that is the
craziest [__] that I've ever seen it's
like probably not even legal but yeah so
so he gets this [__] sweetheart deal
where he basically agrees to plead
guilty to a couple of [__] charges
serve 18 months that was a sentence he
didn't actually serve that um and
everything will be like forgotten and
he'll get and all of his people will get
immunity so he got that which is [__]
crazy also um they didn't tell any of
the victims any of this until after it
had already taken place which if you
were not aware is not legal um so that's
something that would come back to bite
them in the ass later on but much later
on now aasta at the time um he later
later on said oh well I gave him this
super lenient plea deal because I was
told by my superiors that Epstein was um
he was in the intelligence thing and he
was quote unquote above his pay grade um
and that he should leave the whole thing
alone that's what uh he was told so
that's why he didn't say that in the
documentary like they had clips of him
uh you know talking about it and like
justifying the decision but later on he
did say oh well they told me like just
don't just leave it alone just give them
a deal and shut up about it so it was
that kind of [__] guarantee that's what
it was yeah well that's what he said
later on yeah now um Epstein did say he
was going to have to pay restitution to
36 of his
victims um which I believe he did do but
I'm not really entirely sure about that
so don't whoop me on it um he did they
did think like from looking at his
financial [__] that he did pay some [__]
out but that might have been
lawsuit settlements because he got sued
a lot um probably justifiably
so so so yeah now the thing about it too
was that one of the things
that um was maybe a factor in him
getting off was that because Epstein was
real up in that whole be Sterns thing
like that whole financial collapse like
he was supposed osed L like turning on a
bunch of those people that he knew a
bunch of dirt about um and he was one of
the key Witnesses in a lot of those
cases so they were kind of giving him a
break because of that too so there might
have been other things but that was
another thing that they were that he was
involved in that they wanted him to talk
about so they were kind of giving him a
break so not too long after this in
early
2008 this other woman comes forward like
I said this is going to be a lot I
couldn't even like put all the if you go
to his Wikipedia page there's a whole
section of lawsuits that were filed and
it's this huge list of like [__]
lawsuits that were filed against him I
can even count like the number of women
that came forward and like said that he
had done [__] to them it's crazy and
like I said the um on the documentary
they had the the dude that was like one
of the attorneys for the victims and
he's just like we made this chart of all
the people that have been recruited that
said that they had been abused by him
it's like this chart could be like five
times bigger it's just like it's crazy
it's like hundreds of people so there's
that so uh in 2008 in February of 2008
uh there was a woman in Virginia who as
far as I know is unnamed um they just a
lot of the victims when they first came
forward they didn't want to be
identified um for fear of repercussions
so they would just be Jane do uh so she
was Jane do number two and she actually
filed a $50 million lawsuit against him
um and she said that when she was 16
years old this was in 2004 um that she
was
had fallen into that kind of thing she
got recruited oh come give this dude a
massage and then she gets there and then
he you know basically like showed her
his dick and then like raped her you
know what I mean and then paid her
$200 um and then later on uh another
woman alleging the same stuff like also
filed a lawsuit against him too so there
was a bunch of these lawsuits happening
around that time period um and abstein
settled a bunch of them out of court
that doesn't mean that it's guilty but
you know what I mean he did settle a lot
of these out of court because he had the
money so why not that's part of his
system sure yeah he's like well like I
said people that have this much money
they can pretty much do whatever they
want because they can pay and have
things go away you know what I mean and
that's pretty much what he
did so in summer of 2008 abste pleaded
guilty
to basically just a [__] charge it
was
procuring uh for prostitution like a
minor which doesn't necessarily and I'm
not saying that he didn't do this
because he did but the charge is not
that you had sex with someone that was
under 18 but that you just procured
someone for the purpose of having sex
with him but it doesn't necessarily
imply that you did that so that was the
charge that they that was the thing they
charged him with which is a [__]
charge so he gets to his 18
months now normally if you were
convicted of sex offenses in Florida you
get sent to state prison um Epstein was
not sent to State Prison he was instead
taken to uh the Palm Beach County stock
Aid and was put in a private wing all on
his own and after he served a couple of
months he was actually put on work
release and was allowed to leave his
cell which was not locked by the way
um to go to his office for 12 hours a
day six days a week probably getting
girls dead um they think that he
probably was oh sure uh nobody was
watching him yeah so he basically just
lived like I said the the lady that was
um the journalist she was just like yeah
it was just like staying in a real
shitty Motel like pretty much like it
wasn't even like jail cuz he could just
leave like no one was really watching
him like I said even when he was in the
cell they didn't lock it and they gave
him access to as as far as I know he
didn't like he had the wing to himself
they got him a TV they got him like all
this other [__] so it wasn't like jail
you know what I mean just hanging out D
he was just kind of hanging out he would
go to his office probably get underage
girls and [__] him on his desk or
whatever like I don't know what he was
[__] doing
allegedly um so yeah and they kind of
try to justify it even though sex
offenders are generally in Florida not
given work release uh sex offenders
can't trust him no uh yeah as far as I
know they don't give any sex offenders
Work Release um but they they made an
exception for him because he had a lot
of
money so yeah so he was basically able
to come and go as he pleased which is um
you know kind of shitty uh also he paid
what he did was he paid a bunch of the
cops to supposedly like watch him while
he was out and about um I believe they
showed the [__] on the documentary that
said he paid about
$128,000 uh in the salaries of the cops
that were supposedly supposed to like
watch him while he was out doing stuff
but I don't think they [__] watched
him uh he also was allowed to use his
own driver to shuttle him around places
so like I said he's not it's not jail
like a normal jail you know uh so he
wasn't even in there for 18 months he
wasn't even in there for 13 months he
was let out about uh before like 13
months he got released uh in July of
Late July
2009 and then he
supposedly was going to have a year of
house arrest like while he was on
probation did he really stay in his
house absolutely not um actually there
was a private investigator who talked
extensively on the Netflix documentaries
who was following him around said I
photographed this [__] [__]
everywhere he was going all over the
place going to hotels like meeting with
his friends and like going shopping and
[__] like that he went to the island he
went to New York he on his plane and
[__] like that it's like he was
absolutely not under house arrest he was
just walking around everywhere the thing
about it was Chicken on him no they
weren't well the thing about it was that
in New York and this was a little bit
later on but in New York he was
classified as um as a level three sex
offender uh which means that uh that's a
high risk of repeat offense and that
stays with you for life like you can't
really you know so everybody has to be
informed of that so technically when he
was in New York he was supposed to check
in with the cops every so often like
every 90 days or something like that did
he do that no uh legally he was supposed
to do that but he never did it and
nobody checked um so he was just flying
all he was just living a normal [__]
life even though he wasn't supposed to
be so there was that nobody was [__]
checking on him now the thing about it
after all of this [__] came public now
some people did still keep hanging out
with them for whatever reason um but a
lot of people that he had given money to
in the past gave it back because they
didn't want anything to do with that
[__] um like some of the uh political
figures that he had donated to like
Elliot Spitzer Bill Richardson people
like that um I think also the Palm Beach
Police Department gave all the money
back too because they're like yeah [__]
this dude they didn't want anything to
do with it um so as you mentioned before
um there were reports that I think came
out in
2015 um in and it Israeli newspaper that
said that um that Epstein had invested
in a startup that was like a um defense
industry thing like in Israel and it was
headed by the former Israeli Prime
Minister who was you know a friend of
his because he had been one of his
clients like back in the day when he was
doing all his you know hedge fund fraud
and all of that um so and apparently
those two were like good friends like he
would stay at his house and everything
like that um and then there were
allegations too there were three
journalists that wrote a book called
Epstein dead men tell no Tales um and
their whole thing was based on like an
Israeli intelligence officer whose name
again I'm not going to attempt to
pronounce um who basically said that he
was um a spy and that was his whole
thing was like you know blackmailing
people um and they think that he you
know connected to mad uh and that maybe
the connection had come through uh
gilain because her dad might have been
there were rumors that he was in that as
well so there was that whole thing going
on now for the next decade following
Epstein's release from jail the first
time um many many many women came
forward uh that claimed to have been
victimized by him and I don't doubt it
now a lot of them to and a lot of them
talked in the documentary what they were
trying what they took issue with was the
non-prosecution agreement that had been
given to him by aasta because they
alleged that this agreement was illegal
because they had not contacted the
victims and told them what was going on
because the victims didn't know what was
going on until after it had already
happened the deal um this is actually a
violation of the crime victims rights
act so they sued on that on those
grounds
um now thankfully they did eventually
end up winning but it took like a really
long
time so one of uh his accusers who we
talked about uh Virginia who had said
that you know uh you know she her abuse
like started when she was 17 and she had
been trafficked essentially to a bunch
of different people can't loaning her up
yeah um prince Andrew was the big one uh
and there is like a widely circulated
picture of her when she was very young
uh when she was 17 with prince Andrew
and actually the guy that worked on Epi
Island like on the telecommunication
[__] said that he saw prince Andrew with
a girl that looked like her and she was
half naked and he was like grinding up
on her and [__] and the crazy thing
about it is and they showed part of this
on the documentary it kind of made me
laugh is that like on British TV or
whatever like they actually interviewed
prince Andrew and they asked him about
that [__] they're like um they have a
picture of you so what what's the deal
with that and he didn't even try to make
up a live or nothing he was just I have
no recollection of that picture being
taken that's all he said and it's just
like and everybody was like well that
just made a look more [__] guilty
it's like you at least could have come
up there I mean you know and people
probably would have thought you were
lying anyway but it's like at least come
up with something instead just I don't
remember that for a while Virginia was
like their top star yeah she was with
them for a couple of years yeah and they
were like a threesome so she said it was
kind of like a twisted family it was
like having sex with each other yeah she
said it was like a Ed family that was
that was a quote that she said and and
evidently kind of emotionally and
psychologically abusive towards her but
then they'd go out and have fun and then
weird [__] would happen and they'd have
some fun again [__] you know go
snorkeling and go it was just a weird
life that they that they were have it
together weird threesome I can't imagine
what that would be like yeah and you're
dealing with this the civilian chick
who's doesn't come from any kind of
fetish background I mean it wouldn't be
weird if like everybody had gotten
involved in it like in a normal way like
you would if it was right where it was
like but she was just kind of like kind
of groomed or like yeah she's too young
to be in a situation like that you know
because she can't defend herself from E
either one of those she said out of the
two she said gain was the worst a lot of
them said that yeah but I that that
usually happens now they had a thing I
think on the gilain show um you know
they had somebody on there that said you
know statistically you sex crimes or sex
abusers um only 5% of them are women but
in a lot of the way and we've talked
about this when we talked about like
serial killer couples which I find
fascinating like I find that whole
dynamic fascinating like how does that
happen um it's weird because usually
generally women do not become serial
killers on their own it does happen I'm
not saying it doesn't happen but it's
rare but in the cases where there's a
couple a lot of times the victims the
surviv driving victims will say that the
woman was worse yeah than the dude was
which I find very interesting based on
what Virginia said
gain was very demeaning and kind of uh
made made you feel like [__] well she
was very old money so I kind of feel
like she grew up uh in wealth and
privilege so she just probably thought
everyone was beneath her yeah like
you're a piss an and then and like it
wouldn't occur to her to think any
differently and the truth was that they
were beautiful girls and she was and
gilain was very she was pretty when she
was young but she was past her Prime and
Jeffrey really wasn't interested in her
well I heard that they stopped having
sex after a while like they just kind of
became friends and like partners and
like he was just she was just like
facilitating him banging 14-year-olds so
I think her cruelty towards the girls
was really manifestation of jealousy I'm
sure yeah I'm sure that was a huge
Factor she's jealous of these little
chicks little trailer park girls were
beating her you know to the there well
that's got to be yeah the little
considering the weird thing about this
whole relationship and a lot of people
brought this up on both documentaries
was that they thought that there was
something in gain because nobody said
outright that they thought she was
[__] her dad okay but some people
kind of implied that or like
euphemistically kind of said that maybe
or they kind of like hinted at it they
did say that they had kind of a weird
like very very close relationship and a
lot of people also implied that she was
using Epstein as a replacement for her
dad I don't know when they met how much
older he was than her yeah I'm not
really sure what the age Dynam I don't
think it was huge but and I think it was
quite a blow to to gain who
was basically a [__] very
spoiled rich
British socialite okay and the guys that
she liked like Jeff was really attracted
to [__] little blonde like teenagers
teenagers from Florida from the Florida
trailer parks like an actual like
middle-aged woman is not going to appeal
yeah so no matter how rich or fancy she
is doesn't matter how rich or fancy
elain was or how sophisticated as well
she couldn't compete with that [__]
16-year-old from the [__] trailer
park and so I imagine that's a huge blow
already inflated ego you know oh I'm
sure yeah and that probably manifested
as cruelty cruelty yeah
yeah I mean I don't doubt it I can see
that was my read I can see how that
would happen that was my read of that
was my read of the situ because like I
said I don't you know nobody knew really
because they weren't watching the [__]
but a lot of people did say that it's
like I think at some point their sex
that you know gilan's and jeffy's sexual
relationship ended even though they were
still in a relationship kind of but it
was just kind of more like a friendship
after that point yeah and I think that
maybe that was a factor even long before
she ever met Jeffrey gain was a freak
she did weird [__]
sexually and was daring other people to
do weird like she was at a party and she
wanted all the guys to put blindfolds on
and the girls would be pared to the guys
one at a time and the guy would try to
identify That Girl by her tits by
feeling up her tits feel her tits and
the chicks were like um L of ran I
didn't sign up for this [__] she was
super flirtatious and super [__] yeah
they said she was like super sexual like
she would always bring everything back
to you and tried to be in the center of
attention all the time and then try she
tried to be a daddy's girl all the time
and then [__] trying to get [__] from
her dad and crying when she didn't get
what she wanted for her dad she sounds
like [__] [__] sex
operative yeah well somebody who was
groomed from an early age to to use sex
as a as a weapon and a means of
control you know and when she got too
old to do it personally she maintained
her control over everything by being a
Madam she was the one [__]
facilitating and finding these girls for
her see here's on top and I think like I
said this is another thing and I know I
keep comparing to a serial killer but
it's kind of similar like the pathology
is kind of similar seral killers are it
occurred to me yeah well serial killers
are is a sex is a sexual [__] that's
what I mean so I kind of feel like even
though he didn't kill anybody that we
know of I'm not saying he didn't it
wouldn't surprise me if he had it's the
same thing because but it's the similar
it's a similar psychology I feel like
and it's the same psychology and you
kind of see the dynamic between the two
of them reminded me of Sero killer
couples because you would see [__] like
the dude who was like super uh you know
was usually abusive toward her as well
but she just was kind of into it and all
this other kind of [__] and then she
would he didn't want to [__] her anymore
yeah so she would try to please him by
going and finding victims for him and I
kind of feel like it the same Dynamic
was out play here it is the exact same
it seemed like orentation it's a sexual
orientation and it's the same
thing a serial killer is nothing more
than a serial rapist that kills the
victim
Jeffrey Epstein was a serial rapist yeah
just he just didn't need to kill the
victim he didn't need to he he had that
wasn't his thing because he could make
it go away he could make it go away he
had enough money to where he could just
make all the sh Advantage I mean had he
beenal had he been poor he probably
would have been a seral right right
that's the exact same mentality the only
way to protect himself would have been
the killer yeah that because he had the
exact same mentality yeah it is it's the
same thing yeah well that really to me
when I was watching this [__] it's like
you know but he's monetized his sexual
orientation yeah he's using it as a as a
[__] scam and he came from a Ponzi
scheme and other scam organizations so
yeah so he was yeah every like his whole
entire life was built on imagine if you
were to [__] hook him up to some kind
of [__] electrodes and EKG look at
his brain waves he was probably always
happy he was probably a very happy dude
because he's living out his [__] FES
and he can do exactly whatever he wants
to he can do whatever he want it wasn't
until the very end would never suffer
any consequences and honestly yeah he
suffered some consequences in the end
but not really not much yeah not really
wasn't until the very end where he got
locked up to where [__] started to suck
for him and it didn't suck for that long
cuz he [__] died then they allegedly
they either killed him or they got him
out of
there we'll see he better not be still
alive if he everybody's telling you to
put on the Danzig wig yeah what is this
people wanted me to [__] put the wigs
on you haven't put wigs on for a long
time [__] what Tammy says I don't think
Tom is ever gonna wear a
wig man putting on a wig ain't [__] man
they [__] they're [__] jet Jeff
abstein was making dudes put on dresses
at the island was a painting of Bill
Clinton in a dress yeah I think Danny
said something yeah so uh [__] man I put
the wig on and the dress that'll really
[__] yall up if I show up in the dress
but what's weird is that um you could
probably get in some I've also heard
rumors I'll give you I'll give you $20
if you do that I've heard that I've also
heard rumors that big Hollywood execs
would make dudes males dress up in
dresses to get in like a ceremony of
like
submission evidently The Rock he had to
put a dress on and they they take
pictures and they [__] laugh and have
a party and [__] you're in a dress
you're like it's like joining the team
that's some weird [__] I don't know it's
true I mean the thing about that it's
like yeah it seems pretty harmless on
its face but in a way it's just kind of
bothers me because you're I mean the the
very fact that you're using that as um a
way of humiliating someone it's a way of
speaking somebody's submit it yeah
you're willing to do well it just shows
me what they think about women yeah well
they want it to be gender bending you
know yeah
I mean because if you didn't think women
were inferior that wouldn't be funny to
you or that wouldn't be you know what I
mean so it's just like that I don't know
that just kind of bothers me yeah that's
who you're dealing with well yeah I
know people suck don't you don't think I
don't know that I know that I knew that
when I was a kid so uh one quote that
Virginia gave and this this was not on
the documentary I just found this
elsewhere I'm not going to wear a wig
until I get a [__] super chat if I
get a super chat I wear want yeah y
y'all want [__] high quality
entertainment for free it doesn't happen
man this is this charity this is Tom is
not pimping himself out yeah yeah for
not well he is pimping not pimp myself
out just if you're pimping it costs
money I'm not slutting myself out that's
what okay that's big difference big
difference you're not giving it away I'm
not giving it away I'm not SLP myself
out it out you should put on one of my
wigs I got they're in there I'll get
whatever wig I want if that money shows
up cuz your cuz your uh black wig is
kind of tangly yeah you haven't brushed
they want me to put on the daig wig
that's what I mean it's kind of tangly
Cu I think it's just like in that closet
and I had I didn't hang it up so it's
kind of like awful and Knots and stuff I
never brush it because I don't wear it
but you know what I mean um so yeah so
one of her quotes was my whole life
revolved around just pleasing these men
and keeping gilain and Jeffrey happy
their whole entire lives revolved around
sex
basically um so yeah so there were all
of these lawsuits going on between
Virginia and uh various other people
including Alan ders she uh she sued him
he sued her for defamation it was all
this I think a lot of it was settled out
of court you know what I
mean um so yeah so this is what I was
referring to earlier so there was a
federal lawsuit filed in uh California
in April of 2016 now this was against uh
Epstein and also against Donald Trump
now this was a woman who was 13 at the
time of the uh
assault now she um I don't think she
gave her name at the time but uh her
name later was uh Katie Johnson I read
the complaint it's on the internet if
it's on the way back machine if you want
to see
it um it's pretty [__] up so what she
alleged happened and this was back in
the '90s in 1994 I believe this was um
when Epstein and Trump were hanging out
all the time in New York and this
happened at Epstein's house in
Manhattan uh this woman alleges uh that
there were four separate occasions she
was initially lured to Epstein's house
uh like I said she was
13 um because he said that he could help
her modeling career and he would like
give her some money like take pictures
and [__] like that and you know she's 13
what what are you going to do so she
gets there and this [__]
happens she says the first
time uh she was there she was forced to
give Trump a hand
job second time uh it was a
[__] third time she was forced to
make out with another girl who was 12 uh
while he watched them while Trump
watched them then they both had to give
him a
[__] and then
after uh he was done he pushed them both
away and yelled at them because they had
performed poorly there was that the
fourth time uh kadye got tied to the bed
and Trump raped her she actually asked
him to wear a condom and he hit her in
the face and said he'd do whatever he
wanted afterward Katie asked what would
happen if she got pregnant Trump threw
money at her and told her to quote get a
[__]
abortion uh there were also a few
occasions where epin was present while
Trump was getting a massage from another
underage girl uh Katie said she heard
the two of them arguing over um who was
going to take her virginity Epstein was
mad because Trump had already raped her
so Epstein then attempted to sodomize
her but couldn't do it so raped her
vaginally instead uh Epstein then beat
her about the head because he was mad
that he hadn't been able to quote pop
her
cherry um Katie also said that both she
and her family were threatened with
violence if she ever said anything about
what happened like I said this complaint
is online you can read it if you want to
it's in the Wayback machine that's where
I found it so you know um I believe that
this suit was uh dismissed but I don't
really know
why 2017 Sarah Ransom who was on the
Netflix
documentary uh filed a suit against both
Epstein and Gillan Maxwell uh she
alleged that Maxwell had hired her to
give massages to Epstein and then later
threatened to physically harm her or
destroy her career if she said anything
about uh what had happened now this girl
she was a little bit older I believe she
was she was not a
minor um she was a little bit older what
had happened with her was that she was
she wasn't American I think she was um
where was she from initially I can't
remember remember she was on the thing
her accent her accent sounded South
African but I'm not really sure if
that's where she was but she moved to
New York she was at a
nightclub one night and she met a girl
her age who so she didn't think anything
about it and she's like oh I was hanging
out with this girl she was like my
instant best friend or whatever and this
girl was like oh I know this dude and
he's super rich and he has this island
and blah blah and so they're like we're
going to go there and have a party and
blah blah so she's like okay Private
Island private plane all right I'm down
so she goes there and uh essentially
gets uh forcibly raped multiple times
yeah she actually this particular one
actually seemed to be the one that was
the most
upset well I can't really blame her well
this I think similar things happening to
the other ones but this it seemed to
bother her the most I think it's just
because I really think she had no idea
what what she was doing there was no
there was no warm-up period the thing
about Ian go this right and it was a
girl her age that she just met in a
nightclub and it's just like you
wouldn't really think like if I was at a
nightclub by myself and I met a girl
another girl who's my age she's got no
and seemed kind of cool and everything
like that and they said hey let's go to
this part like I would probably be
skeptical but you know what I mean like
if you're in your 20s you probably
wouldn't
be especially you
know um back in this era
so I I don't really think she knew what
was going on so they get to the island
and she's like basically Bally the day I
got to the island you know I get thrown
in the [__] bed and he just like
[__] pins her arms down you know what
I mean and like that and it was like
multiple times a day now she tried to
get off the island and she actually did
try she went down to the um Shore she
was going to jump off and like swim away
yeah this is Story I Heard yeah yeah um
she was going to swim away but uh
apparently epine found her before she
could get off the island and that's she
said that's when I knew that I was under
surveillance the whole time she said the
whole place was loaded with Cam even
outside well I think even gain said that
later on like it was all [__] they
knew where everybody was knew right
where she was standing on the [__]
Coastline but um yeah they got her yeah
that
one that that girl seemed to be the one
that was the most disturbed by it cuz
uh because I guess she was just ambushed
into like a major operation without any
kind of grooming or anything and she was
old enough to know what was going on so
maybe it impacted her a lot harder CU
she she could grab it what was happening
yeah well later on she said that this
was not a onetime thing it was not a one
thing she said that was a big
International grooming yeah and so she
thinks there's more of it out there I it
doesn't doubt me I don't well yeah I
don't doubt it I don't think it looks
quite like this I think Epstein's
operation was very retro probably
something like estein is doing I don't
think that could survive the age of the
internet and cell
phones
um you know imagine I just during the
time when he was in Florida recruiting
all those girls I think texting was just
brand new and I don't think those girls
were had
phones phone is game changer for
something like this because you got
constant communication with the outside
world it's harder to isolate somebody
yeah hey stop it yeah sa said Pooky is
causing trouble yeah she's trying she
got over there that's my Christmas
wrapping paper that I still have over
there and she's just like I'm going to
go in here and tear this yeah
she she she just she's just bar down
knuckled into into the car she like no
no no I'm going to do it I'm going to do
it and she's going to do it again in a
minute and I'm going to hit her on a
butt she's going to go no no no no no
it's a battle of wills that's what she
does that's what you do don't you boie
she knows what I'm talking about her she
she's crch there at it but she's not
doing anything but her tail is going
like that yeah she's waiting for me to
[__] relax and then she's going to te
the paper she's going to do it tear the
paper see look here you the paper we
know how she does yeah I know we know
how she does but yeah that's [__]
yeah she does cost trouble yeah and out
of Mo out of most of the ones that they
showed this particular one actually I
don't want to be a dick or anything but
this one
actually she aged aged real well she's
she's still very goodlook a lot of the
other
ones they lived rough after all this
they were not from Jesus Christ they
weren't from good homes to begin with
and
um a lot of them were more deeply
involved for longer the ones that
testified ones that are on this program
and life really [__] tore them up
they're unrecognizable this one is still
pretty recognizable as that same woman
well like you said she was a older she
was older when it happened but she still
looks real good she still looks fairly
young and I mean she wasn't a child she
wasn't a child she had cool hair and
[__] she [__] moved to Spain cuz she
was like [__] this place maybe he can't
find me here she was your she was
Australian I think was she I thought she
was South African from that accent okay
but I don't think they ever said like
her accent I was like that sounds South
African to me but I couldn't tell at the
time she was in New York and got asked
to go to the island by the girl she
looked like a little model yeah you know
same build mod that's [__] up man it's
like it and it makes me mad that they
coerced or maybe they didn't have to
coers like other chicks into doing this
to other chicks that is [__] up
because that that right there like I
said you wouldn't think any bad about
that like I said you're at a nightclub
like some sketchy dude comes up to you
and like hey go to My Island yeah [__]
off like that's very obviously easy to
spot but like some girl comes up to you
and it's like pretends they're your age
and it's just kind of like they're
acting like your friend and [__] like
that and it's just kind of like that's
going to let your defenses down some
because that's just a girl it's your age
it's like you don't really think of
there no danger from that cuz usually
there's not yeah so and then like the
next day she's on this island bare
knuckling and he's man don't do that to
other CH he said he said that he said
that she she said that he was HD three
times a day and that he was doing things
that no man should ever do to a woman
yeah she didn't specify but I was like
was but I don't really like to think
what that is yeah what is that mean you
know I mean I I can
imagine maybe she just meant you know
forcing yourself on him like that might
have been maybe but maybe she meant
worse [__] than that I wasn't really
sure I mean she was really upset yeah
whatever it was she didn't whatever it
was it was bad yeah whatever it was it
was bad yeah so um you know I I don't
know what he was doing and and honestly
she
implied that he I mean that physically
abused her as well so I think he was
like smacking her around with [__] yeah
maybe
too although most of the other ones
didn't didn't report that but no but
that doesn't mean he wasn't doing that
to other people because I mean most of
the people reported similar [__] but he
seemed to like act differently toward
like he different to every person yeah
like he acted differently toward the
younger ones than he did the older ones
I noticed the older ones here's the
thing I and I don't know if this is true
but this is just the impression I got
from like watching all the interviews
with the victims I got the impression
that the younger ones the teenagers he
would more try to like finagle his way
like he was grooming like I said the
older ones he would just kind of like
rape them yeah and like hit him and [__]
you just say roll over brace yourself
woman right it was it was more that kind
of [__] so it's like I kind of feel like
when they were younger he had like more
this is going to sound [__] up to say
but he had like more patience because
he's like oh I'm gonna handling them
with kids gloves right right right he's
like I'm gonna ease this one into it cuz
he was more into that yeah if the if the
woman was older like over 18 then he was
just going to take it like a stream like
a steamroller just yeah that's the
impression that I got but just from you
know just from the different because
they had victims that were you know 14
15 when they met him and they also had
victims that were 18 192 when they met
him and there was a distinct difference
in the way that they were approached and
in the way that they were treated yeah
so I I kind of feel like he was more
into the
teenagers and I think he enjoyed the
process of grooming them so he kind of
took his time with that where it's like
you know older women you know older in
this case being 18 or 19 you know he's
just going to take it yeah he's probably
seen him well she's a veteran I don't
have to [__] foot around right I I can
just [__] I'm just going to throw her
on the bed and like you know and that's
what he did I'm going to give her money
she's not going to give me any problem
it's going to be like that and prob I
got that impression
probably he was probably mostly
right because we only have a few
complaints out of probably thousands of
girls so it probably mostly
worked cuz the on either that or like I
said I imagine
in yeah I imagine there's a percentage
of girls that were just kind of like oh
they liked it or just were in love with
them or put up with it or whatever and
put up with it because of the Rewards or
and the thing and the thing about it too
is that I think there's probably a
substantial portion that is like I don't
want to talk about it because it'll just
cause trouble because it'll just cause
trouble um I think they were afraid yeah
of what he could do to them which I
don't blame them one bit Yeah but here's
what's weird here here's weird they had
a couple of them they said they went
through that they said yeah he he raped
me and [__] but then she comes
back but that's the thing it's like at
that point she said well I needed the
money yeah that was that was the which
is like that's so sad to me yeah I'm
like what the [__] like look I need
money too but it's like I'm not going to
[__] let some [__] dude do that to
me I will knock your [__] ass out it
was just the mentality and then stab you
he's looking for a certain mentality and
it was that's kind of what it was
mentality of where you could force
yourself on him and she'd come back
anyway that's how she was see that's
kind of the shitty thing about it is
that like now I say that like if some
dude like did that now I'd be like cuz
you know I'm old and it's like I've been
through a lot of [__] it's like yeah
I'll [__] knock your ass out and like
probably kill you in you sleep but when
I was 14 no way I probably would have I
probably would have ended up during the
headlights yeah yeah because I can't
imagine I hadn't 200 then he puts the
200 in your hand and now you're now a
hooker you're guilty now it's like that
probably would have worked on me you
know I'm not going to lie like when I
was that age
because and I can see how it would work
on other girls like I said it's just you
know and when I was 14 I was kind of
like not you know I wasn't super popular
or anything like that so it's just kind
of like somebody was paying attention to
you and [__] like that and giving you
money you might be like well I don't
really like it but I'm getting something
out of it I'll get I'm getting something
out of it but but I would have been I
mean I know myself and I would have been
like oh my God I'm the worst person ever
I'm such a horror blah blah blah I would
have been like that so it's just and I
feel like a lot of them probably felt
like that too yeah but then they what
they do is they double and triple down
on it well the damage is done so I may
as well do it again that's what I mean
that's what's so Insidious about this
kind of grooming is that they absolutely
know yeah that that's what will happen
he he would before he do anything during
the massage process he's interviewing
them and if they he asked some questions
and if they answered that they had been
abused then [__] they go to the top
of the list oh he loved that that's what
he's looking for like I said they're
going after that [__] that's what you're
vulnerable yeah he's going to Triple
down he's going to double down on your
abuse okay like I said all sexual on top
all sexual predators will go after
vulnerable women like that yeah all of
them I guess they love women that have
already been abused because you're
already primed for that [__] you're
already blaming yourself you're already
think you're worthless the victim button
is there so you can now press press it
yep you don't have to make a victim
button it's already there it's already
there and all yeah all you have to do is
just kind of like just keep priming that
that's what evly what he did in Virginia
yep she said she'd been abused and that
was the girl that they met at Mari Lago
yep and she's massaging him one minute
he just roll rolls over and rolls over
get on top and she
did
yeah girls are FD well I mean I can't
imagine I just I'm trying to place
myself back in that mindset like what if
this it happened to me when I was 14 cuz
it could have I didn't live in West balm
but I lived in Florida like what would
have
happened I don't know I like to think
that I'd be too cynical to be like yeah
I'm not doing that [__] but you know
what I mean some girls thought they were
going to get mared I'm not I'm not
touching some old dude the cops said
that some of the girls said said that
they wanted to marri get sadder to me
that's even sadder to me that's even sad
because they absolutely knew who to
Target
absolutely so so yeah so there was that
whole thing we talked about um about
Sarah yeah she was on the um thing like
I said she moved to Spain uh you know
she's she's doing good it looked like
she got a dog and everything now uh
later on in 2019 April of 2019 Maria
farmer who had first filed a complaint
against epsi and uh Maxwell back in 2000
or 1996 actually um she actually finally
went public because she's like look I
reported this [__] back in 199 nobody
did [__] but now everybody's kind of
like coming forward so I'm going to come
forward so she filed uh an affidavit in
federal court after all this [__] came
got public now she said what happened
now she was not a minor at the time uh
but her sister Annie was she was 15 what
had happened was that uh Maria she met
Epstein and gillain uh she was an art
student she was was graduating and so
when you graduate you get an art show
and she had three pieces in the art show
and she was like I was so excited
because the my three pieces like sold
right away for like $122,000 each
right but then she says you know the
lady that was uh curating the thing
which was um the uh the Guggenheim lady
she came up and said uh no you're
actually going to sell the paintings to
this couple here which was abstein and
uh gilain and she's like no these I
already sold these to like somebody else
no you're going to sell them to them and
you're going to give them a break on it
so she had to sell these three paintings
for like half of what she had initially
agreed to sell them for that's what she
says so after this nothing happened like
initially what they told Maria
originally was that like we bought your
paintings we'll make it worth your while
Jeffrey said to her and then they said
oh we're going to give you an artist
Residence at you know Wexner the dude
that owned Victoria Secret and the
limited and all that he had this huge
huge huge mansion in Ohio and they said
you're going to go there and do like an
artist residence you can go there and
live and you can paint and we'll pay you
and blahy blah so and we're going to
help you with your career and she's like
okay awesome they're philanthropist know
they hadn't asked her to do anything
weird so far so she's like okay fine so
she goes there to the house and they're
like um hey she had um done these
paintings of about like she had done
like a series of paintings about uh
puberty and she had done um some
paintings that she had used her sisters
as models they weren't like you know
salacious or anything like that but she
had the I mean they weren't nudish they
were kind of topless and whatnot but
they were kind of they were good too
they look good yeah they were nice like
I really liked her paintings actually
but um but she had used her sisters as
models and so they kind of asked about
it and they just like yeah I have a you
know I have a couple of sisters my
15-year-old sister is named Annie and
then they said oh well we want to meet
her and blahy blah so she didn't think
anything of it because like I said
nothing weird had happened yet so they
um so they said oh we want to we'll send
her to school and we'll do this and that
cuz her sister wanted to be a a
translator so it's like so we'll send
her to I think Spain was that I think
they were going to send her to Spain and
they were going to like teach her to
look which they did do but while they
went there they also were like hey Gotta
Give Jeffrey a massage yeah and then she
go over there and hit and then all of
that happened and then later on and then
like her older sister didn't find out
about it until like later because Maria
was like I didn't know cuz she they
eventually started abusing her too but
she didn't know they were abusing they
didn't mention where the parents were
yeah I don't know I don't know somehow
they got her away from the parents got
both of them away from the parents well
like I said the older sister was older I
mean she was a she was an adult yeah so
that didn't matter and she was kind of
like and I don't even know she said that
she was responsible for her younger
sister so I'm assuming the parents were
maybe like out of the picture or
something like that so they would have
been a good Target so yeah so Maria was
like her entire life she's felt like
horrible because she's like I was
responsible for her and I didn't think
anything of it I thought these were just
nice people that were going to help her
with her education and you know we
didn't have a lot of money so blah blah
and then they ended up doing the same
[__] to her that they had done to you
know what I mean so she doesn't forgive
her sister about it either according to
what she said she said well they didn't
talk to the sister they did talk to
Maria and she said um she's like I I
wouldn't blame her for being angry she's
like if it was if the situation was
reversed I would be angry yeah um you
know which I you know I get it I can't
imagine living with that kind of [__] I
just I can't imagine it but uh but yeah
so there was that whole thing but like I
said when she found out that was going
on back in 1996 she reported it to the
FBI you know fair play to her but they
didn't do anything they didn't do
anything yeah they knew about it and
they're like oh whoops we can't go after
that guy yeah they didn't do anything
until 2005 when the other reports were
and they then they looked back for [__]
and then they found that and then they
went back and talked to her like you
know N9 or 10 years later so then that
happened but like I said she did report
it so you know fair play to her oh you
know what Danny said something good he
said he heard that the that the the uh
the Bill Clinton painting of him in a
dress he heard that it was the linsky's
dress that may be true that that would
make sense he said it was red it was
blue wasn't it I thought it was blue
remember it was I don't remember what
what it was wasn't it blue I thought it
was yellow but the one the painting I am
90% sure that it was blue was it blue
okay but that would make sense that's
that would be like something they
wouldn't actually need the dress they
would just have to know what it looked
like did somebody do that in AI cuz I
could do that in AI pretty quick they
some painted it in
oil well I'm just saying you could do it
in Ai and then paint it yeah Bill
Clinton wearing wearing a dress the
dress yeah the thing about you could say
a lot about Bill Clinton like you know
yeah he [__] around his wife and [__]
like that but one Monica Lewinsky was
not under age yeah two she was
apparently into it yeah so she evidently
could never get a date after that poor
girl I kind of feel bad for her CU her
name was synonymous with that to be
honest event that she she was like she's
probably like man that was the worst
[__] [__] I ever G in my life it's
just like it ruined her whole entire
life yeah it was and like I said it's
not it's not great he was married and
[__] like that but like I said nobody
was unconsenting he didn't rape anybody
it was just kind of like yeah he was
cheating on his wife that's fck around
the office but she was into it yeah he
wasn't like raping people that weren't
into it they were [__] around in the
Oval Office that was it that's that
probably happens a lot I'm sure it does
um like I said so like I said it's not I
don't Advocate it but on the scale of
[__] it wasn't really a crime it wasn't
a crime no no one was doing [__] that
wasn't consenting what sucked was is and
I think it was about 10 15 years ago
might have been 10 years ago she it came
out like in the media that she's [__]
sick of that [__] that [__] she she
can't get a date she hasn't dated since
that well time and that [__] it's
totally [__] up her life because
whenever you Saye mon people start going
T and the dudes didn't want to date her
I said I I would be like man I'd have
changed my [__] name I would have too
yeah I would have changed my name and if
I had money i' gotten plastic
surgery like that wasn't bad looking no
I mean plastic surgery soon wouldn't
recognize you like not cuz she didn't
look bad cuz she was cute wouldn't it
wouldn't matter if they recognized her
it wouldn't matter if they recognized
her or not she just needed to get rid of
that last name I would get a whole new
identity yeah just because anything
that's that culturally iconic you are
never going to outlive that never ever
and dudes which sucks cuz that's a
person she's a person and like I said
she wasn't a victim she wasn't she was a
willing participant she wanted to blow
the president how old was she maybe
about 19 at the time 20 I mean she was
yeah she was minor so you know what I
mean she was into it so it's just kind
of like yeah that's cool but it's like
that's probably like the worst [__]
decision of your life right and then and
that's going to haunt her forever and I
feel kind of bad about that she said
she'd say I feel kind of bad about that
they said in that little article or the
news blur I don't remember they said
don't [__] famous people she'd be
talking to she'd be talking to guys and
then soon as soon as they found out her
name the dude would start laughing yeah
and then she'd ever see him yeah she's
like a joke she was like a joke yeah
yeah and like I said that's got to be
super shitty cuz like I said said she's
a person she's still a person and like
at this point she's like a meme yeah
she's like a meme a meme for
[__] imagine your girlfriend's a
[__] worldwide [__] prop that's
[__] funny hor that would be horrible
yeah I would kill myself probably yeah
it was rough but they were like if I
remember correctly they were saying like
[__] basically what what they were
saying was please leave her alone is
what they were saying I advocate that
like I said she wasn't a minor she
wasn't forced in anything like I said
yeah he was cheating on his wife that
sucks but it's just kind of like she
wasn't forced into it she was into it
she liked him he liked her blahy blah so
it's just kind of like yeah but imagine
it's not illegal but every time you say
your name people mean he I don't think
she really thought through the
consequences well they didn't think they
like I said that could have happened to
anybody don't [__] famous people yeah
don't [__] famous people that's the
lesson there yeah cuz that is going to
haunt you the rest of your [__] life
I feel bad for her actually I feel
really bad for her yeah they like she
wasn't thinking about it at the time
she's just thinking ah we're just having
a good time you know what I mean which
we've all done [__] like that but it's
just not with presentence or nothing
like that but you know what I mean but
some people do and it's just like hey I
kind of like this dude I'm G to give him
a [__] under a desk or whatever and
it's just kind of
like yeah and I tell you what though she
was eating up the attention I remember
that she'd be smiling for a Time she was
eating up the attention but after a
while yeah get yeah it got old [__]
it worked against her said she hadn't
dated since that time I do kind of feel
bad it was like [__] 15 years yeah I
feel bad for her since she couldn't find
a man I feel bad for her yeah you would
never you would never live that town
uhuh like I said you have to change your
name don't [__] famous people yeah she
was in the middle of a [__] huge
Scandal that's just especially people as
famous as that don't [__] famous people
because that will just bite you in the
ass bite you in the ass so yeah so
finally
finally in
2019 July 6
2019 uh Epstein's finally finally
arrested uh his victims never thought
this would happen but what they did I
could they kind of felt like I they
worked behind the scenes because they
said look this dude has a lot of
connections um you know he's was on to
us before when we tried to arrest him
like we thought we were being like all
[__] in
but we weren't um so they tried to like
really keep [__] on the down low so what
they did was they went kind of an end
run and they said we're going to do some
[__] we're going to like arrest him in
New York so when he flies in he was in
France I believe and he flew in from
France and he landed at um Teterboro
Airport and they arrested him as soon as
he got off the plane so they didn't
really give him any chance to know so he
apparently didn't know what was coming
so they arrested him then uh so yeah uh
so he was arrested that was in New
Jersey by the way so they arrested him
on sex trafficking charges so they put
him in the metropolitan Correctional
Center in New York City now after this
the FBI busted into his townhouse in
Manhattan they had search warrants uh so
they busted in there now at this point
because he hadn't known that he was
going to get arrested because they tried
to keep it on the download this time and
they were apparently successful unlike
the first time um they found some way
more incriminating [__] than they had
the first
time uh so what they found in his
townhouse they found thousands uh quote
of sexually suggestive photographs of
fully and partially nuded females uh
some of the photos were um of underage
females like uh you know women that they
knew that had made complaints and [__]
like that so some of them they knew knew
were underage they also found the locked
safe which I mentioned before uh and
they found those compact discs with the
labels on them that said you know young
whoever it was plus whoever this famous
person is um they had a bunch of those
um they also found a bunch of disc that
said like miscellaneous
nudes girl piics [__] like that um also
in another safe they found $70,000 in
cash uh 48 diamonds
and that fraudulent Austrian passport
that I mentioned before which like I
said had expired in ' 87 although it had
been used many times that was a getaway
kit yeah that's why um Diamond's money
like I said that's why they didn't give
him bail spoiler alert yeah um so
yeah now they asked him why do you have
this passport and he said I was afraid I
was going to be kidnapped which yeah
that's make a goddamn s uh okay well
that's what his lawyer said anyway I was
like oh I don't know why that makes
sense but all right
so so yeah so they arrested him they
charged him with uh sex trafficking and
conspiracy to traffic miners for sex but
you know very uh you serious
charges now Epstein of course because he
has [__] money he says well I would
like to be let on bond please and he
even offered $100 million for them to
let him out he says I'll even stay on
house arrest in his townhouse in
Manhattan um you know and I'll pay you
$100
million the judge was like nah bro nah
they said well and I love this because I
kind of feel like he'd gotten away with
[__] for so I mean he got away with [__]
for way longer than he should have let's
be honest but at least somebody finally
was willing to be like no you know
you're you're not going to get out $100
million no you're staying in the [__]
you're staying in [__] prison sorry
so I like that somebody like had the
balls to like stand up and say that um
they said no you're not getting out
because you pose a danger to the public
and you were also a Flight Risk because
we found all that [__] in your safe
which looks like you're going to you
know [__] get outle so no you can't
go anywhere so they left
him now on July 22nd of 2019 um while he
was still awaiting trial he was actually
served with uh another lawsuit another
civil lawsuit and this was another
victim which I don't think I've um
mentioned up to this point whose name
was Jennifer Aras I think it's how you
pronounce her last name um and she
basically said that she had been uh
recruited quote
unquote um for Epstein uh outside of her
High School when she was 14 years old
and that uh Epstein and Gil L had
groomed her for a year and then she was
raped in his New York City Mansion when
she was 15 years old so there was that
going on as well the day after this um
petition was
filed um which was July 23rd
2019 abstein was actually found in his
cell uh injured and only partially
conscious at 1:30 in the morning
so he's laying on the floor of his cell
he's still alive with um marks are on
his
neck now they questioned his cellmate at
the time who was a former New York City
police officer named Nicholas
taragon now at the time he had uh he was
awaiting trial for four accounts of
murder now this guy was questioned about
um Epstein at the time like I said
Epstein this at the time he was just
injured he wasn't this wasn't when he
was found dead he was just
injured so they questioned him about it
and he said I don't know what the [__]
happened now at the time the staff of
the prison thought that he might have
attempted suicide but they didn't rule
out the possibility that he had either
staged the attack for whatever reason or
that his cellmate had attacked him they
you know they were keeping all the
options open um you know uh and
different sources were saying different
things like some people were like yeah
he tried to kill himself you know some
said uh he tried to Stage it to look
like somebody attacked him or somebody
actually did attacked him those were
kind of the three options and like I
said this wasn't when he died this was a
couple weeks before
that now um a couple days after that or
um
he was actually placed on suicide watch
after this because they're like well we
don't know like maybe he tried to kill
himself so we'll put him on suicide
watch so they kept him on suicide watch
for six days um but on July 29th he was
taken off suicide watch and he was put
in a different housing unit with another
inmate like not the same
dude um at this point everybody that
knew him said that he was acting normal
he was in quote unquote good
spirits so when he was put in this other
unit um the jail said okay well he's
going to have a
cellmate and we have a thing where the
guard's going to look into the like look
in on him every 30 minutes because like
I said he's still kind of Pooky please
stop oh my God yeah she she's trying to
cherish it I okay you're going to be
punished come here okay she just wants
attention she she just wants attention
you sit down get up in the lap down down
bring her up in the lap she wants to
come up in the lap you want come up here
then she's like no she just wants
attention no she said no
okay but yeah so they had this whole
procedure in place evidently uh like I
said they're supposed to you know look
into the cell over 30 minutes whatever
however um uh apparently on the night
that he died uh this was not followed so
August 9th
2019 um Epstein's
cellmate at the time was transferred out
he was supposed to get another one but
another one never came in so he was in
there by himself now later on in that
later on that night um he was supposed
to be checked every 30 minutes but the
two guards that were assigned to check
on him evidently fell asleep and didn't
do anything so they didn't check on him
and then later on they falsified their
[__] either because they were covering
something up or they were afraid of
getting in trouble or whatever um there
were also a couple of cameras in front
of Epstein's cell uh that were
apparently not working that evening for
whatever
reason so uh the next morning 6:30 a.m.
on August 10th 2019 Epstein was found
dead in his
cell uh so they did do apparently some
life-saving measures uh and then called
an
ambulance now they took him to the
hospital but he was obviously uh dead
and at first they were kind of like well
it looks like a suicide but we're not
entirely
sure um basically they were like uh at
first they were kind of like well there
was all kind of like um negligence at
the time at the prison it's like look
the guards fell asleep it's like the
cameras weren't working um they did kind
of say that this prison which was
originally known as the tombs I think
I've talked about it before in one of my
True Crime uh
cases um is
notoriously understaffed and underfunded
so they were kind of going that angle
where it's just kind of like look
everybody that works here is kind of
idiots and they're underpaid and they
don't really like give a [__] so it
could have just been negligence perhaps
um but you know who
knows so but they didn't really want to
make any you know superfinal decisions
now uh so there was that
now they did an autopsy the next
day now what they thought at the first
autopsy was that he it looked like that
he had thrown like he had tied some [__]
around his neck and thrown himself off
the top bunk which isn't very far fall
very far now it looked like and they
talked about this on the Netflix
documentary they're like he sustained
there were three breaks in his uh neck
bones like the hyoid bone which like I
said if you know anything about True
Crime the hyoid bone that's usually how
they determine if somebody's been
strangled like especially if you just
find them like years later like when
they're
skeletonized um that's usually how they
determine if someone's been strangled
because their hyoid bone will be broken
it's a bone that's like up here it's
like kind of horses she
now they said it's not here's the thing
it's not
impossible um for someone who hanged
themselves for example to have a broken
hyoid bone and it especially more likely
when the person is older because their
bones are more brittle but it's not
super common um usually you see a broken
hyoid bone in strangulation cases is
what you would normally see um and ab's
family in particular his brother Mark um
hired another uh forensic uh you know
pathologist or whatever to look over the
autopsy again um and he thought I mean
he didn't come out and say because they
can't come come out and say because they
weren't there but you know what I mean
he thought that it was more likely that
um that it had been a homicide rather
than a suicide um so you know like I
said nobody knows nobody was there but
it does kind of seem weird that the
bones were broken in that particular it
very much checks out that he was I want
to it very much checks out that he's
some kind of an
operative like uh he's some an agent
that uh intelligence agencies use to
entrap people so they can control them
for the agency or National Defense or
maybe other countries can control I
think he may have been a double agent or
a multi-agent
but it follows that if your agent gets
compromised in a situation like this you
either try to save him or kill
him I would think that if you if you had
the ability to get into a prison and get
him out of
there under the guise of medical
treatment you could also get him out of
there alive it might even be easier to
get him out of there alive it'd be less
trouble you just say hey lay down and
then you cover him up and take him
out now the story that I heard was is
that it looked like they were choking
him and the guys that were choking him
he's saying breathe you know breathe
Jeffrey you know it's gonna be okay wake
up Jeff and that kind of [__] while
they're killing him and then they put
him on a gurnie and run him
out it' almost be easier to get him out
of their life because he would go
willingly
but maybe somebody decided if they did
kill him they decided that he was just
too dangerous to be left
alive maybe they maybe they were you
know they were afraid that you know he
had all that dirt he'd be able to
squeal but the FBI got all that dirt it
looked like the FBI that was turning the
place upside down they got some Drone
footage of them turning the place upside
down getting out out out of the out of
este's
Island so maybe they had recovered the
dirt already
so they just thought he was dangerous
they didn't need him anymore and they
just killed him could
be but that it follows it just if that
was guy was just a lone
offender just getting the dirt for
himself they wouldn't have bothered they
just let him R in prison because they
wouldn't consider him to be credible so
he could talk all he wanted and people
oh he's he's just making that up he's
he's in
prison
because they already had all those tapes
that he
had yeah they probably trying to see
what they what they would do they had
the evidence they collected it from his
[__] residences here's the thing they
got everything they got everything so
they didn't really need
him but they just I guess they just
decided to kill him just to totally
silence the whole thing so he couldn't
bring up even even throw allegations
based upon what was on those tapes
although the thing is like all the
shit's already out though the weird
thing is that at the end of
20123 they were like oh we're going to
release this list of like all these like
people but the thing about it was that
it wasn't really like I read all the
articles about it and it's like it
wasn't really any names that anyone
hadn't heard before yeah um and the
thing about it was that a lot of the
people that were named they're like
these people don't that doesn't
necessarily mean that they've been to
the island or they [__] under underage
girls or anything like that these were
just people that were named in cuz like
for example one of the names that came
up was Leonardo DiCaprio and it's like
that doesn't mean the the only reason
his name was in there was because
somebody asked one of the victims hey
did you meet Leonardo decaprio like at
something like you know what I mean so
he wasn't yeah so the fact that they're
in the [__] doesn't necessarily mean
anything yeah what I what I was talking
about though I think the evidence that
they got hold of that I was talking were
the discs the video evidence I believe
the C I believe the FBI got it and
they're not going to show it because
there's too many important people and
they would consider it a threat they
would say well it's a threat to
democracy that's what they would
say uh really what it is is that these
guys are
[__] some of the most important
people that run the world you know it
might be dudes that are [__] powerful
in the UN or in the military industrial
complex or somebody who helps people get
hired you know what I mean [__] some
just important Mogul and they don't want
to expose him you
know so they got the evidence you'll
never see that
evidence although I guarantee
you the intelligence agencies the FBI
CIA Democrat Party they hate Trump so
much because they see him as a threat if
there was videotapes of trump they would
have leaked it so he must not be on
there
you know I don't know about the other
allegations they said that that that
that chick dropped them or it got
vanished maybe they just maybe she
recanted
it I maybe she was paid off and recanted
it there's no no way of knowing she said
she was threatened since she was
threatened yeah yeah [__] anything's
happen these are [__] powerful dudes
man but I guarantee you that
[__] that [__] those tapes you'll
never see him you'll never see him
if anything the FBI has it or CIA has
those tapes now and they are using them
to Blackmail people that's another thing
that they could do well yeah probably
said they that's too much power to throw
away you oh look we got them we got them
we got the motherload score so an
intelligence agency would just use that
so Jeffrey outlived his purpose they
probably have more of those so I guess
they just went in there and killed him
they didn't want him
talking
even though I mean he didn't seem like
he would have but he he probably would
have he would have done anything to get
out of prison he would have lied to get
out of prison he said that he would give
all his wealth to get out of prison yeah
yeah and that includes lying so they
could use him as a political stooge and
and name people that he served that
weren't there you know you could get him
to say anything say he was too dangerous
they killed
him yeah for a minute I thought maybe
they got him out of there alive but now
now that I look at why would they keep
him alive though well you could silence
him by keeping him alive get but I just
I just feel like keeping him alive would
be too much trouble too much trouble too
much risk probably much easier he
probably wouldn't be able to control him
because he'd be back up to his own
tricks what I mean he's a Serial sex
effect yeah that's the thing like I kind
of feel like even though like whether
you know regardless of whether he was
some kind of secret agent or something
which maybe he was um he really seemed
to be into this [__] and he really
didn't seem to be willing to stop no um
or unable to stop so I kind of feel like
um he was not valuable to anyone alive
yeah he he was a so if he was indeed
bumped off he was bumped off I don't
think they would have kept him alive for
any reason why would they he was a
serial rapist because he would just do
the [__] again and get them in even more
trouble he was a high class serial
rapist that could move in the highest
circles and he learned to monetize that
wouldn't surprise me if Gan helped him
mon monetize it yeah she probably did I
mean she also seemed like a horrible
person yeah I me she probably taught him
everything her dad knew type of deal
these two I mean this was a match made
in Hell seriously um you know the two of
them and we talk about that a lot on
like the serial killer couple show
because I'm like I said I'm fascinated
by that Dynamic and I kind of feel like
a similar Dynamic was going on here
similar Dynamic this you know what this
reminded me of this is maybe Off the
Wall this reminded me a little bit of uh
the moris
murders um you know Ian Brady admired
him kind of like that because she left
her her own
devices um I do not believe that she
would have ever killed anyone I think
she would have just had a regular normal
boring ass life like everyone else but
when she met him um there was some kind
of
weird Synergy that happened
like a horrible Synergy and she ended up
wanting to please him so badly that she
was willing to
procure children for him to rape and
kill and she was like okay with it um I
think that was kind of a similar Dynamic
to what was going on here it just seems
very similar to Me Maybe extreme but
probably no no no yeah that's what I
mean but it's but similar like not
obviously not they weren't killing
anybody that we know of maybe they did I
don't really know I would imagine
they've made threats I would imagine oh
for sure imagine if they did think a
girl was was threatening enough they
probably would have had her well and but
they would have used how they would have
done that though most likely probably
wouldn't have been on the island or
anything that's unlikely be more likely
that they would do it at her home they
would hire a private detective to do
something like Runner over in a
crosswalk and like a hit R according to
did any of them show up dead maybe
suicides Maria farmer well one of them
did commit suicide but I don't remember
how it happened Maria farmer the artist
that reported them back in
1986 she said on the
documentary that not Jeffrey
gilain had basically said every time she
moved she said they knew where she was
like they would call her at her new
number and she said that gilain told her
um oh I know that you go jogging along
this particular Road oh it's not safe
you don't know what could happen aot
like they were going to run her over so
they absolutely did allegedly like
threaten yeah people and like some of
the other victims too just said that
they did like kind of lowkey like
threaten them and their families and
stuff I guarantee you they had people
clients ex-clients and friends either in
state
police police forces or FBI that could
trace you and find you wherever you are
just through your electronic foot
footprint that you used back then and I
mean it's much easier to find nowadays
they can find you nowadays if you got a
cell phone they can [__] find you oh
big time if you got a cell phone not
only can they find you they can turn
your cell phone on and it doesn't look
like it's on and they can listen to you
through that cell phone they can track
you through GPS know right where you are
that cell phone at all times they can go
through all your data every post
everything you've ever seen and have a
AI
program scour your entire internet
footprint for keywords to see if you've
been talking about certain things some
of the AI programs evidently can read
your whole internet activity and over
time come up with a psychological
profile of you and then where you are at
certain times of the day your schedules
when you're working when do you go to
Starbucks when do you [__] go to the
club where do you park normally when you
go to the club that's [__] powerful
information I dare somebody to stalk me
I am boring as [__] yeah but if you have
that kind of information you can hand it
over to a [__] agent to do Black
Operations like say say you uh got good
pull with the Mexican Mob Mexican
cartels you just hire them say hey we'll
let your buddy out of prison or hey
we'll let you uh we we'll pay you a
million dollars if you uh or 500,000 if
you uh take care of this target she's
going to be here next week th on
Thursday that that kind of [__] just be
right there and she'll be there she
always shows up there and that that's
how good that that kind of technology is
well yeah it's much easier nowadays to
like Stock People which they'll know
right where you are they know your
patterns not great and and all of us
have that
footprint the only difference is is that
they don't they're not putting that
laser on you they're not they don't have
the microscope on you they haven't
looked at you you're not important
enough to look at but if you ever
[__] became important or a threat to
them they would know Everything About
You in
minutes it's spooky yeah well like I
said I don't really worry about it
because no one gives a [__] about me but
it's just kind of
like if I ever you know got into a
position where somehow I had power or
money or something which I don't think
is ever going to happen yeah it's just
kind of like yeah I understand how easy
it is to St people although like I said
now yeah go ahead and stalk me you'll be
bored as [__] and [__] within an hour
I guarantee
it you know um so here's the thing so
after this [__] [__] heel died
however he died we don't
know um so he had they figured out he
had actually signed his will a couple
weeks before cuz remember I said a
couple weeks before he actually died
there was an incident where he they
don't know if like he was attacked or he
tried to Stage some [__] or or attempted
suicide or
whatever so he had made his
well um around that time like two weeks
after that and in his
will um he moved all of his money to a
trust I believe in the Virgin Islands
what he was doing at least according to
you know some of the attorneys and stuff
that talked on the Netflix documentary
they said what he was doing is that he
was moving all the [__] offshore um so
that he wouldn't have to pay any
reparations to the victims if anything
happened like after he died um you know
and one of the attorneys said yeah it
was like a [__] you to the victims like
basically I'm taking all the money you
can't have it um is how they interpreted
that which maybe that was what it was I
can't believe this is a 4H hour show
well I told you it would be long man
it's I told it went by fast though well
yeah like I said there's a lot to get I
didn't even get get into I mean there's
so much stuff yeah we got like I said I
was kind of worried about this cuz it's
like I had I had this huge thing of
notes like you see these notes and I'm
almost at the end now but it's like I it
was like twice that long yeah so I had
to go through today and I had to like
pair it down cuz I'm like going to take
this out I got take this because this
going to take too long so I went through
and like mercilessly paired stuff down
so there's like a lot of other stuff out
there about it but I try to like kind of
get all the main gist you know what I
mean so so he moved all his money to an
offshore
trust some of the lawyers think it was
because he didn't want to pay
reparations to any of the victims um is
why he did that I don't know if that's
why he did that but it it seems likely
that seems like some dick move that he
would
do um uh evidently after he died uh a
bunch of other women um came forward and
like you know sued obviously trying to
get like some [__] and and honestly like
uh I think like a month after he died
they also started investigations in
France because he also had an apartment
in Paris which I don't know if anybody
knows but um and they assume that he was
doing some nefarious [__] over there too
so they want to like find out what's
going on over there so in um August of
2019 they also launched an investigation
in France to see what he was up to over
there because they can't imagine that he
wasn't doing some bad [__] over there
also um so yeah
now also I thought this was interesting
and I actually didn't know this the US
Virgin Islands sued ab's estate in
2020 uh they were saying you are running
a sex trafficking thing for 20 years um
and you know they're suing I think
that's still pending um and they allege
that children as young as 11 years old
were on that island
so they're suing for that reason uh the
US government also sued uh JP Morgan
Chase in
20122 because JP Morgan the bank uh was
allegedly
facilitating the uh the sexual abuse and
the sexual trafficking so I believe that
case is also still pending as if they
knew yeah that they might have known
what was going on yeah so um so they're
being sued also the bank is being sued
also by the Govern
government now uh as most of you
probably know in
2021 gilain Maxwell uh was put on trial
and was found guilty of child sex
trafficking and uh various other uh
crimes in connection with all of that uh
she was sentenced to 20 years
imprisonment but she also faces a second
criminal trial for uh two charges of uh
perjury essentially like that's a life
lying under Earth yeah um because she uh
evidently allegedly lied about um
Epstein's Abus of underage girls so
they're going to get her on those uh
they're trying to get her on those
charges as well so she is probably going
to spend the rest of her life in prison
uh like I said Netflix has a good the
Jeffrey Epstein um Netflix documentary
is very good it's four parts it's about
four hours uh but they also have one on
gilan Maxwell it's only one episode I
think it's an hour an hour and a half it
put faces to this yeah yeah yeah they
show the girls yeah it's really
interesting they like watch all that
[__] we watched all that the girls are
on there the ones that talked they're on
there and uh shows what they looked like
when they were you know kids on that
island and um it's messed up man yeah it
it sounds like something okay somebody
mentioned that uh Alex Jones [__]
talked about this in 2013 and it was all
true I think it was even before that I
well like I said a lot of people knew
about this well the charges were from
2005 yeah um you know it was first
reported to the FBI in 1996 but they
didn't really do much about it uh the
main charges came out in 2005 yeah first
time I heard about it must have been
around 2011 2010 no 2005 was when it was
in Florida at least that was when it
went um you know Florida a wide
Statewide I don't know if it went
Nationwide but the FBI did become
involved in 2006 I believe yeah first
time I heard about it was like
2010 and
uh and AJ was talking about
it and he named a lot of [__] I didn't
believe it it sounded too [__]
Fantastical billionaires on the islands
with all these [__] underage girls he
even said yeah the plane is called
Lolita Express all that [__] checked out
well like I said they knew all that back
then yeah I don't he wasn't reporting
anything that wasn't known I don't think
that like people didn't believe it
though I don't think that people like
The Wider public knew about it but it
was known cuz like I said they started
investigating him in 2005 most people
didn't believe it I didn't believe it it
sounded like something that was made up
sounded like something out of James Bond
movie cuz that was when the first yeah
that wasn't the first report the first
report was in 1996 but they didn't do
anything about it but the first like
major report that they actually like
decided that they were going to
investigate was in 2005 yeah it wasn't
in mainstream though they weren't
talking about it at all yeah well it was
still local I think it was still a local
case at that point CU it was still
Florida but he was talking about how
important it was you know what I mean
and he the little details about gilan
and her father he he said that people
involved in it had called him too and
told him a bunch of stuff so it may have
been some of the girls had called him
may have been some of the staff that
worked there that quit that's the thing
it's like a lot of people knew that's
another thing that I think these dumbass
Rich [__] don't consider you
guys have a whole staff of people yeah
that work for your dumbass yeah and you
probably don't pay all that well right
you [__] them over they are going to
tell all the [__] dirt of what you
were up to and some these some of these
billionaires you know [__] guys like
Gates and [__] they have these delusions
of
grander and uh they're going to do
things they're doing things they're
talking about you know [__] getting
rid of meat and [__] making people
eat bug protein and [__] and getting rid
of all [__] farming and everything uh
they're [__] crazy all right that
that's a mad Dream On on par with the
Nazis they don't live in an am in in in
an amount of security as they think that
they do they have private security
around them that have family in the real
world if they're seeing the world fall
apart and money becoming worthless they
look at a dude like Bill Gates and they
gow that motherfucker's not rich anymore
money doesn't mean anything I'm gonna
kill him you know and and take this [__]
for myself or look what he did to my
family they they can't trust anybody if
they start doing [__] that bad and and
EP is kind of like that same type of
situation serial sex abuse of people's
children lowincome children you know
you're not going to be able to get away
with that forever I mean here's the
thing this is why I've always been kind
of like they own turned against him
sometimes this is why I've always been
kind of like you know I and I've always
been poor so maybe it's easy for me to
say this but it's just kind of like um
just approach everyone as if they are
the same as you yeah well don't like
look at yeah that's what I mean and
that's kind of their weakness yeah I
feel they think that everybody is stupid
some of the [__] G told people was and
and she thought that they would actually
believe that ID like we a stupid [__]
yeah you know she would tell people some
[__] that was just insane and she I'm
poor but I had a decent education yeah
you know but they they're they're so
used to being surrounded by employees
and yes men that they think that they
think that everybody's stupid and they
can just say any old random thing and
you'll believe it uh now I grew up
partially in Brazil in a very expensive
when my mother was in the state
department I went to a very expensive
International High School in Brazil
called Escola Gru de s Paulo and all the
presid sons and all the captains of
Brazilian industry all their sons were
in there all the consulate and Embassy
kids were in there from [__] a bunch
of different
nations so I grew up around the children
of this type of people the malies the
Melos they were real powerful the Santos
family they they owned the [__] um
the the media but pretty much all the
movie theaters and uh I think two of the
television channels the big television
channels Luffy his his
dad I knew the son his dad just robbed
Brazil blind he was a president um I
think Ricardo
Melo his older brother ended up becoming
president of
Brazil one of my buddies was the K he
would have been the king of Brazil but
they were no longer a monarchy at the
time I was there he was kind of like a
deposed king of Brazil and he was just
some kid I used to pick on in class you
know what I mean [__] goofy Louise
was his
name they think because they grow up in
these little
insulated really expensive schools and
everywhere they go is basically kind of
like an enclosed hermetically
sealed rich people capsule they think
they think regular people are just
stupid or another species they're their
servants you know so
they so they can do [__] like this but I
mean y'all got to live in in the world
too yeah they do they just don't realize
they don't realize that they do
eventually you'll find
out but I think they what it's like for
the rest of us in some countries they
can go generations like that though oh I
know all I know it's just that you just
look at other places you know like Rome
and other civilizations you eventually
you run a civilization into the ground
the people just kind of rise up and kill
you oh yeah revolutions and [__] that's
going to happen that'll eventually
happen and Empires all go the same way
which might be why they're all get too
big for your britches yeah which means
maybe that's why guys like Zuckerberg
and these other guys are building these
damn [__] bunkers out in [__]
Hawaii and stuff but you can't hide this
is not this this is not the 20th Cent In
the End you
really there's a lot more of us than
there are of you right right and it
would end up like the end of the Third
Reich where all the leaders are tried in
like a nurg tribe for crimes against
humanity
and you're all strung up yeah you hang
them all and the family members too well
I don't know sometimes they do that just
so there's no way no one left to inherit
their power so the so the the families
are accused and convicted of crimes
because usually this is done in some
kind of a revolutionary court it's not
about Justice it's more about
elimination you know yeah I get that and
but there is something to be said about
not
um descending to the level of your
enemies
also GNA a civilized person might think
so but but by the time this [__] happens
that's not what's happen yeah I get that
I get that you look when you look at the
French Revolution they got so pissed off
they were killing
revolutionaries that started the
revolution for anti-revolutionary
[__] I
know yeah and they killed [__] King
Lou that really turned into a cluster
[__] yeah they killed King Louie and
[__] uh uh Maran toinette and they
weren't really guilty they were kind of
just symbols of they didn't really do
anything they were just symbols of an
old they did but it's just kind of like
they didn't do anything unusual yeah it
was the same [__] that's been going for
hundreds of years they were just there
at the time they were just kind of like
representation of everything that people
hated and Lou Louie and
Marie uh ran but they ran too late they
should have run [__] a year before
that but they just thought it would they
had normaly bias they could have run to
the United States and
lived you know Incognito or just kept it
low key you know in the end he was
trying to escape in a carriage and
revolutionaries got him and [__] hung
him and didn't hung him they chopped his
head off chopped his hat off and the
same with Marie y they both got their
heads chopped off yeah which freaks me
out still right beheading is like freaks
me out Kenny says great podcast
presentation Jenny is on a roll tonight
information I didn't know
yeah isn't that something yeah like I
said I cut so much stuff out yeah I cut
so and this show is so long but I I'm
glad I cut all that stuff out some of
those uh girls agreed with me that it
was an international blackmailing ring
that it didn't really have anything to
do with yeah well like I said Sarah
Ransom said that too she's basically
like this is like just the tip of the
iceberg and like a lot of them said that
but like I said it's you know it's um
you know a docu series they're trying to
like keep things focused so they did
kind of allude to that but they're not
going to go like super into it because
one they can't probably can't prove the
allegations I would imagine and they
don't want to get sued and two that
wasn't like the
main I did like that they focused a lot
on um the victims you know what I mean
it seemed like the the large portion of
it was kind of focused on the victims
but they did kind of go into Epstein's
background and they went into gilain and
like I said they had a whole other you
know show about gilain like about her
[__] deal and [__] like that but you
know they can only do so much in four
hours but I think they did a good job
I'm a mythicist I love to see things in
mythological terms it helps me process
information and put things in a proper
light um Ian Fleming was a OSS member he
was an early Special Operations guy from
England and he ended up writing the7
books and
he said in his private life that there
were gangs of oligarchs and stuff
meeting up in hotels that are actually R
running the Earth running the world and
causing a lot of problems like Wars and
they're they're doing Insider bet
insider trading based on things that
they're going to tell politicians to do
all right and um he called him
Spectre and that's what this that's what
that's what Jeffrey Epstein was it's
kind of a similar thing he was a high
level Spectre
agent and I would you know that that's
how Ian Fleming would have describe yeah
it's like I don't think it's quite as
organized as that no it's a culture like
a mafia kind of yeah well the thing
about it is that and like I said this
I've said many times on the show before
I'm not like a big conspiracy theorist
or anything like that there are
conspiracy theories and blah blah but I
do kind of feel like if you have
billions of dollars and you're in those
circles and blah blah it's it's going to
be you're going to end up getting into
that kind of [__] I don't think it's a
conspiracy in the sense that we're
planning this kind of thing and blah
blah
but they do kind of end up hanging out
together they do kind of end up they do
project influencing things together like
yeah I don't I don't even know if they
necessarily know what the repercussions
of that are going to be no this is
another thing I think they're just kind
of and the thing about Epstein and
people like that I don't even think they
were giving a [__] about that they were
just was kind of like we just want to
[__] underage girls we just want to know
how we we can get that
facilitated um and then the other stuff
was
just yeah well I don't know
um I kind of grew up around this type of
people in
Brazil and uh the thing that will
Astound you is how average most of them
are that does not Astound me at all
they're not that bright most people are
they're not that bright the [__]
basically has inherited his father's
Empire it's been going on for [__]
three four
generations and maybe he's 110 IQ a
little bit above average he's not a
genius it's easy to bamboozle him and uh
Epstein got in with him because he was
probably higher IQ than a lot of them
and could bamboozle him he definitely
Bamboozled [__] those dudes into
keeping his job and then just he's a
bamboozler you know yeah a lot of people
said that they're like he was really
good at like like manipulating people
and like just a lot of these guys
inherit their money and their wealth
their dads and grandads might have been
a lot more talented and than they were
and they maybe they kind of came up from
the through the ranks and had to work to
build but this guy's just kind of
inherited he's just Joe Snuffy he's just
G yeah and he hasn't really lived he
lived a pretty isolated life he doesn't
have any [__] Street wisdom or Street
knowledge and a dude can go in there and
bamboozle his ass
because he's soft you know he can throw
a couple underage girls his way get
video of it now now I got this soft
[__] yeah it's like look I got a
video of you doing that you wouldn't
want me to show that to your wife I
favor I'm call you it's going be that
kind of [__] I got all that [__] on
video [__] and I got you already might
as well keep coming back to the island
you know so they do you know bring your
friend I'll get his ass yeah I mean once
you've already recorded him it's just
like well you just might as well do it
again well just keep doing it yeah and
dudes will [__] do it cuz dudes then
you got you got you got them they're
loyal to you they keep coming
back dude man it's an ingenious [__]
plot it's ingenious because you're using
thees that [__] oh yeah you're work
using you're using the weaknesses of
people's of of human nature the
weaknesses if you were a billionaire
with a lot of power would you do this no
I would hope not no cuz it' be real
labor intensive itd have to be you'd
have to be Jeffrey like a lot of you all
this [__] work and you'd have to uh
other than it being morally
reprehensible um you know I would just
want sources of income that just keep
flowing to me that I don't really have
to do much I just want to be lazy if I
had all that money I don't want to
work that I would just have regular
people over and party sure and uh I
wouldn't even want rich people to come
see me [__] them they're no fun I'd have
[__] working class workingclass
hotties and [__] and [__] you know my
favorite band and yeah we're gonna have
a goth [__] concert on the island
everything's free yeah we could have an
island and we could like build a house
however we wanted we could have whatever
bands we wanted we could have all our
friends there we could fly them in that
would be awesome have a whole [__] I
it would never honestly it would never
occur to me yeah to fly in like underage
people no I fly in just cool goth that
would never I would just fly I would
just I would just flying cool goth
people to have a party yeah it's like I
would fly the like our friends in who
are all celebrities obviously like over
18 yeah I call in [__] Amy Lee so she
could [__] all the [__] all the
bands come yeah you know [__] maybe
have clan of zyo come come play on the
island yeah get Andrew Eldridge to come
over so we can listen to some Sisters of
Mercy so if anybody wanted blackmail
[__] on us it'd be super boring cuz like
look they all the people there are like
we're making porn anyway in their 40s
and 50s they're making porn but they
everyone's I'd have the youngsters too
I'd have I'd it had be 21 plus like I
said nobody underage cuz yeah cuz
there's going to be booze and [__] yeah
we don't want anybody that's under
drinking age come on everyone has to be
21 yeah the under 21 Crowds Are pay the
ass anyway they are yeah we we don't
want any of these youngsters here but
yeah like I said that's why that's why
this [__] is mystifying to me yeah she
we were talking about it and I'm going
why is he bothering with this why would
you bother it's because that's what his
job was he was he was trying to help and
he was into it I think he was also into
it he was agent of Spectre and whoever
else he was working with he was the part
the the the the blackmail arm of of of
the organization there was more of them
there had to been and I think some of
the money was coming from the guys above
him they were paying him to get this
done or loaning him the money to buy
these islands loaning him money for this
kind of [__] to get it done and it might
have been might have been China might
have been the Chinese government that
wanted that information it could have
been lots of people might have been two
two or three governments that were
paying him that he was he might have
been not a double agent but a
multi-agent kind of like a information
collection and control for hire he'd
work for probably anybody who came to
him you know like China says look we uh
we want this certain law passed in the
United States to help of the industry
that we have in the United States if you
know not to pay all these tariffs or
taxes you oh yeah I got a guy I think I
can help make that happen you you send
me $2 million all make sure that this
that this Senator will put that put that
[__] uh uh law up there and we'll
we'll bribe him if you give me the money
and we'll get it passed that way you can
bring the rest of your operation over
it's going to be [__] like that probably
a lot of it going to have to do not with
[__] real sexy7 [__] it's going to
have to do with [__]
industry well yeah industry probably
industry Banking and education [__] like
that because he was interested in
University professors
so that means he's trying to get control
of the of the tech trying to get control
of the technology he's trying to get
control of science so he can get these D
he gave a lot of money to yeah that's
what he's doing yeah that way he
controls what science says you know you
can't disobey the science science is
taking place of religion you know so if
you can have some Bamboozled people with
scientific mumbo jumbo all kind of [__]
well and the shitty thing too is that
lot of scientists don't have a lot of
money so it's like if some
philanthropist comes there and says hey
I'll give you money for the research
they're like okay we'll take it and like
I said a lot of them did after they
found out what happened they they gave
the money back but and I guarantee you
when he says I'm going to give you the
money to write your scientific paper but
the scientific paper must say this when
it's done when it's over and okay yeah I
can do that I can I can give you a study
that says that and then then well you
got got Jeffrey Epstein in charge of
science
now maybe he's doing it to help somebody
else make money you know well yeah I
mean the where he placed his
money um really does seem like you kind
of knew where he was going with that
[__] he was just really kind of trying
to he gave a lot of money to like
scientific research and all that kind of
stuff mostly it was just like Eugenics
type stuff and transhumanism type stuff
yeah there's a good professor his name I
believe his name is is Eric Weinstein he
and he did an interview I listened to
him off and on pretty regularly uh he
was a university Professor je Jeffrey
estein invited him to his house I'm I
believe it might have been on that
island but it was just
him or his house when he said his house
I'm not sure exactly where he was
talking about he had a lot of houses and
then um he said he met them to and he
said it was like something out of a
[__] movie he said it was he goes
there and he's sitting behind a table
jig giggling he's got he's got he's
sitting behind a table over the table is
it draped a huge American flag and it's
long he's at one end and Jeffrey's at
the other end he brings he brings a
[__] gilain comes in and sits on his
lap and while he's talking to him he's
jiggling jiggling her tits up and down
trying and and they're trying to get him
to do something but he never quite
really knew what it was they were trying
to get him to do what exactly he he said
he immediately started to shut down that
this was some kind of a scam uh yeah
yeah Eric go go let's not come right in
with the titties because that's a little
it up and down jiggling her implants cuz
she she actually had a nice rack uh and
did she yeah she had big old implants
she's she's Tom noticed that of course
I'm a
man and he's jumping up and down with
the low CL blouse boobs jiggling and
[__] and and Epstein is like
assisting the jiggle and [__]
offering him stuff I think to drink and
[__] and and and he he's not sure why
he's
there yeah I kind of if I was a
scientist and I got brought to
somebody's house it's like hey there's
this philanthropist that wants to your
research yeah right and I went there if
I was a dude Okay and like somebody's
like shaking their tits in my face and
like offering me liquor I'd be like yeah
I'm just going to go yeah I think that's
basically I haven't listened to to
Weinstein I don't know what's going on
but it's not good whatever it is yeah I
don't remember all the details it's been
a while since he just said that it was
extremely surreal and he said it just
seemed like a huge put on like a
huge act you think they would know
better that's very try hard no he said
that he said that he was not under he
was not in the impression he was not
under the impression that that uh
Jeffrey Epstein was particularly
intelligent he said he he felt like he
was pretending to be intelligent that's
what he said yeah he might have been
intelligent in C very yeah in very
specific parameters yeah but sometimes
people that are really intelligent in
very specific parameters are not
intelligent he had good math skills he
evident had very good math skills and he
had great human engineering skills which
means he was very manipulative a lot of
people said that he was really good at
manipulating people and doing [__] that
he wanted yeah like he was I don't know
if anybody said he was Charming a lot of
people said that Lane was Charming um
and that she facilitated a lot of the
[__] a lot of the [__] but um a lot of
people said that he was real good at
manipulating people though yeah into
doing what he wanted which I don't know
I never met him so I don't really know
if that's true or not but you
know Kenny says and the conspiracy
theories are in Full Effect some wacky
tele evangelist swears that Epstein
Epstein has been smuggled to the dark
side of the moon okay apparently aided
by some Jewish cabal yeah I mean that
sounds like well here's another thing
though is that is
that one of the main functions of
intelligence Community is what's called
information
Warfare if the public starts to become
aware of something that they think is
sensitive they don't want the public to
believe that they will do things to
Cloud it like they call in and and call
in and say yeah Jeffrey is on the Dark
Side of the Moon uh the Jews smuggled
him there and that gives the and they go
oh get out of here but then the news
agencies that they control because
they're all hired that happened with the
[__] uh Patriot Act they will say
they will say the estein um con talking
about ebstein is anti is
anti-Semitic these crazy people are
saying that epin is on the dark side of
the moon the Jews took him there
the whole thing was just an an
artificial distraction it was the it was
the intelligence agencies that planted
the [__] fake conspiracy theory and
now it's them using the media to try to
Cloud the issue saying if you look it if
you talk about this subject you're
racist that's basically what what how
they do it it's a bunch of different
ways it's just different
games um you you can talk about
something's true well you make up a
bunch of conspiracy theories that aren't
true and then claim all conspiracy
theories are not true although one of
them's true in there five of them are
lies but one of them is true but they've
clouded it they put a bunch of Lies out
there it's it's it's called information
Warfare It's disinform people or
misinforming
people you can know something and then
they put that [__] out which will cause
you to unknow it because you oh I must
be wrong I thought that was true but it
could couldn't be true look how crazy
these people
are so that that's how information
Warfare
Works boyfriend the women know it as
gaslighting the boyfriend's gaslighting
and [__] abusive Behavior we're very
familiar with that yeah you saw me
[__] her but it wasn't me you just
thought it was me you know that it's
just [__] like that you know what I mean
you're saying sound like some [__] you
come up yeah I walked in you walked in
and saw me and it just looked like I was
[__] you you know you were wrong that
day you know just just just weird [__]
it wasn't me it wasn't it wasn't me
[__] the chick it was me [__] you
you just got confused what who is that
comedian I can't remember what comedian
was it um it wasn't uh [__] I can't
remember what comedian said it but he's
like who you going to believe me or Your
Lying Eyes yeah that's yeah yeah so that
sounds like some [__] you'd come up with
information if I walked in on you you'd
be like um you're not seeing what you
think you're seeing no this is is
actually you down here you're just
having [__] identity crisis just
weird [__] like that yeah you come up
with some I'm I'm just trying to come up
with this [__] on the top of my head
that's not a perfect example I wouldn't
fall of the way of the way an
intelligence or PR firm which is an
intelligence agency just a mercenary
intelligence
agency
they discredit stories they discredit
the truth by
putting other theories that are real
close to it but associated with racism
or Nazis or some [__] like that to make
the whole subject toxic that's what
they're trying that's how they do
it I mean I hate to say but you kind of
have to get to a point where you just
like trust nobody yeah and nothing yeah
everything's
suspect because well I don't I don't
think it you can't believe you know I'm
not saying you can't believe anything
I'm just saying
that um from the outset don't just
believe anything you hear no if you
believe something if you hear something
that sounds like but that sounds kind of
believable like look into that [__] yeah
that's all I'm saying any kind of
corporate media and corporate media is
not mainstream media it's corporate it
serves Corp corporate interests and
government interest it's just like
Pravda in the Soviet Union all those
three-letter news agencies are for
higher they will say whatever you pay
them to say because they don't make
money off of advertising anymore and the
the Patriot Act made it legal for the US
government to propagandize the people
using those a uh uh news agencies they
just use them as mercenaries the same
you'd use them a mercenary Soldier as a
mercenary you just pay him and you this
is the mission so they're just towing a
line not for the government they're
towing a line for the corporations that
own and control the government because
the government is not the ruling class
they're the servant class they serve
these [__] these billion
Whoever has all the that's who they work
for yeah they don't work for me or you
they work for them they got all the
money and the power without them that
government would not
exist okay
so if you hear it on the news whatever
they tell you on those on on that
corporate news the truth is probably the
opposite just look it up I mean it's not
necessarily the opposite but just look
it up a lot of times it's the opposite
just look it up like they're telling you
that they are straight up saying that
Russia has been defeated Russia has not
been defeated Russia [__] Ukraine up
they're winning that war you're going to
see it they won that war already it's
getting ready to collaps they lost a
half a million men and Russia has got
stronger it makes its own Hypersonic
missiles and everything it's rich now
but they're not going to say that on the
news because that doesn't fit the
corporate narrative that they
need they're going to try to start a war
over this and they're going to lose
because the US can't fight any wars it's
it's got a shitty Army now they don't
know that though the these guys couldn't
fight their way out of a [__] paper
bag but you're going to if they go to
war with Russia or China they're going
to get their asses [__] kicked and I
don't know what army they're going to
use they don't have enough
dudes and they'll never make it across
that
ocean those Russian Subs carry [__]
Hypersonic missiles they'll send
everything to the [__]
bottom but you can't tell these guys
that they're they're dumb even the
people in the in the Pentagon are
dumb uh they're not supposed to be in
there it's just the the they were slowly
replaced by
idiots over time because these
universities can't turn out Military
thinkers there are no military schools
you know and what they learn in
university is the exact opposite of what
you need to know to learn how to
effectively run an army or or or a
war they could barely run McDonald's you
know they're just corporate
guys Kenny says uh Clinton was just
having good oldfashioned fun with Monica
Lewinsky um Tammy says uh the cigar
jokes didn't help either yeah yeah I
kind of like I said I kind of feel bad
for her because like I said nobody was
exploited in that situation it was just
you know yeah like I said exra marital
sex he was cheating on his wife which is
[__] up but she knew though nobody
yeah one she knew uh two nobody was
being forced into anything um so you
know nothing illegal was happening it
was um ill advised yeah sure but um not
illegal the clintons are married but
they're I don't think they're they've
been husband and wife for a long long
time they're they're more like business
partners well I mean uh Bill always um
seemed like uh he was open yeah he was
open to everything and honestly I he
never struck me as anybody that was like
he wasn't really into underage girls he
just he was just like a poon Hound kind
of but everybody that he slept with was
like of age and seemed like they were
down with it I always thought so I
always thought Bill Clinton was kind of
slimy but I never had I never had him
pegged for a a bad guy per se he doesn't
seem like a pedo I mean he seems like a
very chilled out laidback yeah um kind
of a just a bum kind of guy you know
that's yeah he put on a good speech and
yeah whatever um now he is rumored that
they sold a bunch of cocaine back when
he was governor and that yeah they used
that money for for uh to run campaigns
which that makes sense that the timing
was right in that and I think a lot of
them do that involved in drug drug trade
to help help raise the money to [__]
run for office but I'm not really even
that bothered well like I said yeah it's
drugs are illegal and [__] like that but
it's not like I said it's not like
they're they shouldn't really be illegal
that's what I mean it's so I'm not that
bothered I'm not that bothered it's just
another scam um um Scott says I think
they both had their side pieces yeah
they probably so and I think they both
knew the score yeah they were in open
they were business part like I said I
don't I don't know why everybody had
such a
fit think Hillary was into girls
actually I mean maybe so and the thing
about it was that I don't know why
everybody's had such a fit about like
him and Monica Lewinsky but because like
yeah he's cheating on his wife but one I
think she knew and two Monica was not
underage and she was at the time
consenting so at the at the time the
Republicans rep Republican party wanted
to get elected all right so they just
wanted to use that as a smear to to to
try to win the next but doesn't bother
me that much that's what they did it
didn't work no didn't nobody really
cared no why would you because like I
said it's nobody's getting hurt by it
everybody seems polities are the
political parties are always me and
culturally behind they they don't know
what regular people actually think
nobody is underage nobody is being forc
into anything what they do is is they
thought oh you know what if people knew
about this they'd be scandalized and we
could win the next election but people
didn't give a [__] they didn't give a
[__] because they they don't they don't
really know who the American public it's
not the 50s anymore yeah they don't care
yeah sorry they don't neither side knows
the the Democrats don't really know what
the American public is neither the
Republicans they don't know what the
American Republic is republ is like and
they're a uni party they they they'll
they they serve the same oligarchs it
it's just two different um sales
techniques it's Coke and Pepsi and it's
just to give you the illusion of
Truth um if you give the people the
illusion of of choice excuse me the
illusion of choice if you give them the
illusion of choice like I
can pit Coke or Pepsi you know it's all
Cola though you know part of the problem
with the Soviet Union is that the
Communist party was just one party there
was just Communist Party red there was
no Communist Party green if they had two
communist parties they could the people
would have a sense of having some say in
things you know it would be an
artificial sense of
choice but it would hold together a lot
longer and that's what we got we have an
artificial sense of choice but really no
matter who you vote for you're going to
end up with John
McCain which is just the same [__]
thing over and over again it doesn't
matter because they don't work for you
old white dudes doesn't matter what
color they are because they serve the
same oligarchs you're you are not their
boss their boss is above them and he's a
billionaire out on that
island that's who really runs that
[__] although are I mean do we really
think that abstein is still alive I do
not think that I I thought so for a
while but now that I think about it no
it'd be better for them why would they
keep him alive it'd be better for them
to kill him even if he was killed which
I don't know like I said I wasn't there
but if he was like why would they keep
him Alive's only one reason I'm going to
tell you there's only one reason why if
you go in there and rescue him the other
Spectre members real think oh well if
you're a spectre member they can't take
care of their own so they'll come and
rescue me but the thing is but I mean
probably what happened is is that the
other Spectrum m a liability though let
me say something let me finish probably
what happened is is that the other
Spectre members said no he [__] up and
got caught he has to die sure that's
probably what happened that's what I
said he's a liability yeah like I said
you [__] do this [__] you want to
have sex with 12-year-olds so badly yeah
that you're willing to like
contravene multiple International laws
to do so
um you get killed I feel like no one
should really like stand up for your ass
really um had he lived had he lived and
then you it would have been he's I feel
like he's a lot more of a liability
alive yeah but had he lived he would
have had the power to dismantle the
[__] Empire he would tell you all the
dirt that he had and if you could find
it and you can get it you could expose
the very top here's the thing though I
kind of feel like in good for us had he
been alive it would have been good for
them in this well that's why I think
that he was not kept alive another thing
too is that had he like
hypothetically had he still been alive
had they like kept him alive which I
don't think they did but if they did um
would anyone if and he came out and said
oh this that and the other person did
this that and the other would anyone
care no I don't think they would care
care no one would care look at all the
[__] that powerful people have done and
no one gives a [__] nobody gives a [__]
so it's like why would they give a [__]
that he had done it oh this person did
that this person did that no one would
care they really wouldn't
so okay well I'll tell you what Jen it's
midnight probably time to shut shut the
show down yeah what do we got coming uh
next week do you know well Friday okay
we're going to do the Sidetrack show
yeah but for next week's show I don't
know because okay we we haven't done the
poll yet okay all right poll opens if
you are a patron or if you are a member
on
YouTube you can vote on whatever the
topic is going to be for the following
week I put the polls up at 10:00 a.m.
eastern standard time on Friday mornings
and you can vote all the way through the
weekend until Sunday at noon Eastern
Standard Time um you know but only if
you're a patron or only if you're a
YouTube member uh so I don't actually
know what the Topic's gonna be until
Sunday at
noon so I don't know what the Topic's
gonna be but Friday night will be our
normal show I don't think we're going
out Friday night are we I don't know yet
maybe I mean I don't know we went out
last Friday but we'll see how it goes
okay what
happened Scott says I also think Bowie
is still alive and probably Elvis yeah
yeah okay how old would Elvis be oh he'd
be in his 90s now nowadays if he were
still alive we would all like to think
that Elvis and Boe were still alive I
think Bowie Bowie's death upset me more
than any other Celebrity Death ever I
don't normally care because they're
celebrities and I don't know them but I
don't know Bo's hanging out with Maj Tom
David Des really got me it got me I mean
you know all right so we're going to
wrap it up for the evening because we
have been on for several hours at this
point four at least almost hopefully you
guys have enjoyed the show I tried to
like really did I do a good job yeah
okay yeah I feel like I I tried to get
all the notes like put together and [__]
like that it was difficult but you know
what I mean to kind of winow everything
down but I think I covered all the major
points so hopefully you guys like
enjoyed the show uh please join us again
Friday evening for our Sidetrack show
where we're just gonna drink and talk
about [__] and that's always fun for
the week yeah so thank you very much for
dropping by this evening we'll see you
guys again on Friday night good night
right